, jetzt läuft die Aufzeichnung. Ja, ich hoffe, dass mein Computer jetzt auch aufhört zu blasen. Der bläst nämlich viel.
Du hast noch den Audio-Output von deinem Rechner mit einem Flow hier.
Das gibt's ja nicht von Loyosenspruch, es saugt und bläst.
Von Auto meint's.
Der Heinzelmann.
Womit die sonst nur blasen kann.
Okay, herzlich willkommen, um das Berufsstum anzupacken.
Zu MobileMax, dem Podcast, Ausgabe Nr. 009.
Und ich hab mein Getränk schon vor dem Beginn leer gesoffen.
Wir haben noch mehr. Da musst du dann durch die Küche. Ich hab sogar noch einen Kühlschrank. Hier wird natürlich die goldene Club-Matte gesoffen, wie das so Hacker-Tradition ist. Dennis mag sie am liebsten kurz vor Eiswürfel. Zustand. Sie klirrt es so ein bisschen, wenn du das...
Ich kann nicht so kalt.
Nee?
Ach komm.
Aber ich musste sie ja extra noch in den Tiefkühlschrank legen.
Die ist doch schon supraleitend.
Supraleitende Club-Matte, das wär's ja mal was. Ob man damit noch eine Supercomputer aufbauen kann. Da fällt mir ein, dass auch wieder gemeldet wurde, dass diese Virginia Tech Jungs, erinnerst du dich, die diesen Super-Cluster aus Macintosh gebaut haben, den nächsten Streich starten und wieder die Top 100 reinmarschieren wollen. Wieder so aus Mac Pros.
Wie Mac Pros? Keine Server? Die haben ja damals auf Server gewechselt.
Ja, aber diesmal war komischerweise wieder von Mac Pros die Rede. Na, ist nicht ganz so komisch. Ich hab auch ein bisschen mich gefragt, was geht. Aber ich glaube, der Grund ist schlicht und ergreifend der, dass dieser Clusterbus, den sie verwenden, braucht ja eine Karte.
Und den Findiband haben die ja benutzt.
Genau, und was jetzt nicht genau, ob es jetzt was anderes oder die nächste Generation, wie auch immer, ich vermute mal, das gibt es nur als PCI, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Passt nicht in den Server rein. Geht da ein volles Slot rein? Nein. Keine Ahnung, da stand auf jeden Fall Mac Pro, vielleicht war auch der. Aber die sind da wohl immer noch nicht so ganz aus dem Rennen.
Haben die denn überhaupt die gleichen Prozessoren wie die Mac Pros? Weil die Mac Pros haben jetzt doch mit null Quad-Core weiß der Teufel was.
Genau, das war der Grund. Das waren natürlich die acht Cores. Du hast in so einem Mac Pro einfach mal mehr Dampf pro Netzteil als in dem Server.
Die sind ja natürlich auch dementsprechend größer.
Die sind größer, aber ich glaube Platz haben die da. Ich hab mal so Fotos gesehen, wie die das da aufgebaut haben. Die haben die dann einfach so hochregallagermäßig einfach übereinander gestapelt. Eine ganze Halle voll irgendwie die Dinger übereinander. Ich glaube der Platz war weniger das Problem, sondern irgendwann ist einfach die Kohle für die Stückzahl ausgegangen. Aber unterkriegen tun sie es wohl. USA, großes Land. Ganze Wüsten voll mit Serverfarm. Nur den Strom dafür zu bekommen. Gibt es auch so Serverfarm Cowboys? Bestimmt. Ich glaube die reiten auch durch ihre Halle.
Am Abend setzen sie sich dann irgendwo an einen Server und machen sich den Boden warm. Ich stelle mir das so schön vor.
Ja, genau. Sie können so Dot-Mac-Pakete, die Apple jetzt wegschmeißen müssen, einfach so zusammenwürfeln und sich da ein Lagerfeuer draus machen.
Dabei wird Marlboro geraucht.
Oder Camel.
Come to verse, Mega-Flops ist.
Oh man, jetzt sollten wir schnell das Thema wechseln. Auch wenn ja immer wieder einer dabei ist in den Kommentaren, der sagt, wir sollen nicht so viel über das iPhone reden, ist es einfach in diesen Zeiten, wo es einfach mal so wenig Mac-News gibt und so dermaßen viel iPhone, inklusive zwei iPhone 2,5G-Besitzer hier in der Podcast-Runde vertreten sind, die jetzt mit so einem ganz geschmeidigen Handbewegung, machen sie mal eine typische Handbewegung, das iPhone aus der Tasche gezogen haben und stolz ihre 2.0 Software zeigen. Ihr habt's geschafft. War auch ganz einfach oder wie?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Also...
Einfach Update und fertig.
Meine eigene Doofheit, naja Doofheit auch nicht, aber Unwissen hat dafür gesorgt, dass ich es zweimal machen musste, aber jetzt wüsste ich, wie ich es gleich auch beim ersten Mal geschafft hätte. Also eigentlich war es ganz easy. Wenn man so ein bisschen weiß, wie alles so geht und so.
Ich bin irgendwie so mittelbetrunken von einer Party nach Hause gekommen am Sonnabend, zwei Uhr morgens oder drei, ich weiß nicht mehr, relativ spät, und hab dann noch irgendwie kurz einen Rechner aufgeklappt, noch durchgeblättert, gesehen, alles klar, Tool ist draußen, Pornos-Stuhl, hab den Rechner wieder zugeklappt, so nee, machst du morgen. Zehn Minuten später war mir klar, es wird morgen nichts, das muss jetzt werden und hab dann angefangen, die Software runterzuladen, hab dann noch diese Pornos durchgemacht, dauert ja nur höchstens eine halbe Stunde, irgendwann um sechs Uhr morgens war ich dann fertig und alles lief super. Aber bis dahin war es ein steinigerer Weg, als die Software, als sie uns versprochen haben.
Warte mal, was heißt, du hast Pornos durchgemacht? Also das 2.0-Update gibt es ja für alle iPhones. Das habt ihr auch einfach eingespielt.
Nein, so einfach ist das ja nicht. Hätten wir es eingespielt, also ich hab es mal eingespielt, ich hab eine ältere Version, mal so ein Beta eingespielt. Und da man ja, wir sind ja so Jungs mit, wir brauchen halt diesen Unlock. Weil wir haben halt keinen Vertrag. Sondern dann die normale Software einspielt, dann geht halt dein Telefon nicht mehr, weil es dann halt gelockt ist. Kannste nichts mehr damit machen.
Okay, das Update hebt die Sperre einfach wieder auf.
Update hebt die Sperre auf, also man braucht das Telefon nicht zu aktivieren.
Also es schaltet die Sperre wieder ein, sagen wir es mal so rum.
Achso, das Update schaltet die Sperre wieder ein, genau.
Das offizielle von Apple. Genau, die Software nennt man Baseband.
Ich glaube am Baseband ändern sie gar nichts. Aber die Aktivierung ist auf jeden Fall noch nicht drin. Das ist ja zwei Sachen.
Du redest jetzt von dem neuen iPhone?
Oder was? Ne, von dem alten noch. Also ich meine das Baseband wird ja nie aktualisiert von Apple. Das machen sie ja nicht. Wie Software meinst du dafür? Ich hab ja zum Beispiel auf meinem, da haben wir ja gerade drüber gesprochen, ich hab ja nach wie vor, obwohl ich ja nur 100 Mal eine neue Firmware mittlerweile installiert habe, habe ich immer noch ein 3, 9er Baseband drauf.
Ne, das ist der Bootloader.
Ist der Bootloader ein Baseband?
Weil das auch ein bisschen zu riskant ist, weil wenn der hops geht, dann ist wohl vorbei. Und da gibt es zwei Versionen, den 3, 9er, da haben sie früher einen Patch gefunden, dann kam mit, irgendwann kam dann den 4, 6er raus, dann hatten sie ewig halt keinen Patch dafür, oder keinen Exploit, und dann mussten sie eine Weile warten, dann kam der irgendwann und dann ging ja im Februar die große Welle mit den Zipfer und Tool durch, weil das war dann der 4, 6er Exploit auch. Ist egal. Jedenfalls, den ändert Apple nicht. Der ist weiterhin gleich. Das Baseband ist da, wo man den Unlock macht, und da gibt es jetzt auch für die alten 2G-Telefone eine neue Version, und zwar 04, 05, 04. Und vorher war es 04, 04, 05.
Das Baseband ist die Treiber-Software für das Modem, was quasi für die Telekommunikation zuständig ist.
Für den geheimen GSM-Chip. Weil das ist auch abgenommene Software, das ist ja bei GSM so eine ganz heilige Geschichte. Da kann man halt nicht so ran. Also auch so sogenannte offene Telefone, wie das Open-Moco, auf das wir ja auch nochmal zu sprechen kommen wollen, hat da sozusagen, stößt da an eine Grenze der Freiheit.
Genau. Also diese Pwnage-Software, um noch mal kurz ein bisschen drauf rumzureiten, die ist relativ hübsch gemacht. Das ist so weit, es scheint wirklich alles relativ einfach zu sein.
Das ist die von dem iPhone-Dev-Team, ne?
Das ist die von dem iPhone-Dev-Team.
Wir wollten es Oma-kompatibel haben. Es ist ihnen fast gelungen.
Das sind überall große knuffige Buttons und so. Es gibt einen Experten-Modus mit Albert Einstein und es gibt einen Anfängermodus mit Gaucho Marx, glaube ich. Und da wird man dann relativ hübsch durchgeleitet. Und so ist es eigentlich auch relativ simpel. Aber die Software hakt an einigen Stellen. So Formulierungsprobleme, was wir zum Beispiel beide hatten, das habe ich gerade für euch festgestellt. An irgendeiner Stelle wird man gefragt, ist ihr iPhone legit? Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich es ausgesprochen habe.
L-A-G-G-E-D?
L-E-G-E-T.
Legit mit E-T.
Ah, mit einem G.
Genau.
Ein legitimer.
Ein legitimer User. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, nee, mein iPhone ist nicht vom iPhone gefallen. Klar, bin ich ein legit iPhone user. Das hieß aber so viel, wie danach wird einfach kein...
Mehr oder weniger, ob man AT&T-Kunden ist in Amerika oder T-Mobile-Kunden oder nicht.
Ob man diesen Unlock machen muss. Und es wird halt nicht gefragt, hast du einen offiziellen iPhone-Vertrag? Man könnte ja noch eine kleine Erklärung dazu sagen. Ja, ich habe ein legales iPhone. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass ich die Software irgendwann drauf hatte, und zwar theoretisch einen jailbroken iPhone hatte, aber die trotzdem nicht erst hätte aktivieren müssen und zum zweiten hätte die SIM-Card.
Wie hießen die Buttons?
Natürlich. Also an solchen Stellen hackt es ein bisschen, da müssen sie echt noch nachlegen.
Ja, man muss auch immer sagen, was man als nächstes tut und nicht die blöde Janne sagen.
Ja, also ich musste das machen, ich musste in den DFU-Modus, du weißt bestimmt, wofür die Abkürzung steht, auf Anhieb. Genau, also so ein spezieller Modus, in dem man in dem auch wirklich Software neu eingespielt werden muss. Das ist relativ kompliziert reinzukommen. Man muss einfach eine bestimmte Tastenkombination beim Hochfahren des iPhones halten. Und da hätten sie ruhig vorher mal eine Anleitung schreiben können. Übrigens, wir gehen jetzt folgende vier Schritte durch. Zuerst kommt das, dann kommt das, dann kommt das, dann kommt das. Also die haben das mit hübschen Animationen gemacht und weiß ja teufel was, aber du sitzt da panisch davor und weißt nicht, was als nächstes kommt. Das könnte man alles noch ein bisschen besser machen, aber irgendwann hatte ich dann ein iPhone auf 2.0 und hab jetzt auch ein iPhone, das ständig abstürzt, wie alle anderen auch. Also deutlich öfter als die alte Firma.
Das habe ich auch gehört, gelesen.
Also ich hatte einmal, dass ich bei SMS was tippe und bevor der Buchstabe dann kommt, dauert es irgendwie 5 Sekunden oder so was.
Was? Das hör ich noch nicht.
Ist aber auch wieder verschont, hatte ich nur einmal. Aber es stimmt schon so richtig, dass irgendwie was schneller wäre oder so, kann ich nicht behaupten. Das einzige, was deutlich schneller ist, wäre schon der Safari.
Also Safari ist sehr, sehr viel schneller.
Da gab es auch schöne Benchmarks bei Mr. Gruber.
Mindestens 1,7-fach war, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen JavaScript Benchmarks.
Faktoren habe ich gar nicht genannt, aber von den Balken her war das im Vergleich zur ersten Version.
Aber auch zu 1.24 war es schon dramatisch schneller.
Also es gab schon Verbesserungen, aber jetzt ist es noch mal viel schneller.
Und das ist wirklich, das ist echt, also Surfen kann man damit jetzt richtig angenehm, was ich sehr angenehm finde, weil ich immer noch an meinem kleinen Twitter-Kleinsitzer namens Edwin sitze. Was ich dann gemacht habe, das sind Haufen Features, die in Safari 3.0 drin sind. Die sind jetzt im neuen Safari auf dem iPhone auch drin. Also zum Beispiel, dass man Datenbanken anlegen kann im Client. Direkt SQL-Datenbanken, das geht endlich. Was ich nutze um die JavaScript-Files, weil ich lade 100 KB JavaScript-Files nach, dass ich die erstmal beim ersten Aufrufen der Seite lokal speichere in der Datenbank. Was dazu führt, dass ich jetzt nur noch knapp über einen Kilobyte laden muss, was auch über ein GPS unglaublich schnell geht. Cool. Das ist echt eine hübsche Sache.
Cookies waren gestern, jetzt wird vielleicht der ganze Code abgeworfen. Oh Mann.
Wobei, da könnte Apple auch durch cleveres Caching, die das ja auch irgendwo abspeichern könnten. Alles klar, die Datei hat sich ja nicht geändert. Das ist ja Safari, Firefox, auf dem Desktop kriegt das ja alles ohne Probleme hin und her.
Also, die speichern bei apple.com oder was?
Nee, auf deinem Telefon. Wir könnten ja einfach sagen, 200 Megabyte auf deinem Telefon sind für Dateien. Irgendwas müssen sie cashen, aber nicht allzu klarer, habe ich das Gefühl. Irgendwas wird auf jeden Fall gecasht, aber ich habe das Gefühl...
Das kann auch immer vom Server abhängen, wie gut diesen Header eigentlich wirklich auf Cashbarkeit des Contents hinweist.
Ich habe einen auf Cashbarkeit des Contents optimiert. Und es hat so ziemlich gar nichts gebracht.
Ich mache ja seit Jahren, bin ich ja immer mit diesem Proxy auch am Fummeln und der casht ja dazwischen. Und das ist eigentlich alles Voodoo-Magic. Das ist auch alles nicht so easy. Der Client muss es können, der Server muss es können. Das ist auch vom W3C oder wer auch immer hier die ganzen Standards macht. Es wurde nicht vorgesehen, wie doll was irgendwie wann gecasht wurde. Haben sie früher nicht aufgepasst. Dann wollten sie es später nachbessern. Und dann war es natürlich zu spät, weil dann alle schon irgendwie ihre Produkte am Start hatten und das nicht mehr so einfach änderbar ist.
Es gibt so ein paar Standardtechniken zum Caching. Und wenn man sich an die halbwegs hält, dann sollte eigentlich alles überhaupt kein Problem sein. Aber man kriegt die meisten Browser damit auch deutlich schneller. Aber das Erfahrung ist doch relativ, also auf dem iPhone nach wie vor, wo es eigentlich gerade drauf haben sollte, scheint mir da relativ schlecht zu sein.
Aber die User und auch die Developer kotzen total ab, weil doch die Stabilität von dem 2.0 nicht sehr toll sein soll. Also Programme, also es gibt so einen Effekt, dass wohl beim Starten von 12 Party-Ups die Kiste häufiger bombt und wenn man gut ist, dann bringt es das wieder. Und zwar bei allen Programmen. Also sozusagen das Launchen als solches bombt.
Genau, das ist nicht der, außer bei Apple-Programmen, bei denen die mitgeliefert werden, ist mir aufgefallen.
Ja, weil die wahrscheinlich schon die magische Api der nächsten Generation bewussten.
Ich nehme an, dass da das DRM rumbombt.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach ein scheiß Bug.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Bit ist. Also meine erste Idee war...
Es ist immer irgendein Bit.
Es gibt zwei, zwar auch zwei.
Man muss zu dem Pornoschopf dazu sagen, das ist nämlich ein neues Feature von der 2.0-Firmen-Ware, oder nicht nicht Firmen-Ware, sondern Software, dass das iPhone jetzt nur noch Code ausführt, der signiert ist, und zwar komplett von vorne bis hinten durch. Also der Colonel startet nichts, was nicht signiert ist. Und deswegen mussten die Pornich-Jungs von diesem Hacker-Tool schon ganz früh irgendwie in den Colonel reinhacken, damit sie halt ihren eigenen Code ausführen können. Weil die auch ja diesen Boot-Neuter jetzt starten, der irgendwie den Unlock macht und so weiter. Und dieses Zylia-Wirt kann man jetzt ja installieren. Und das ist so neuer als Dollar, der alte ist, geht irgendwie nicht mehr.
Also sollte man vielleicht mal dazusagen?
Und das heißt, dass jemand, der sein iPhone jetzt mit dem Pornich-Tool aufhackt, der hat dieses Feature nicht mehr, dass der Code gecheckt wird.
Also unser Code wird aus... Mein Code... Generell sozusagen. Mein Code, das heißt, man ist...
Generell, man ist dann malware-freundlich.
Das könnte so sein, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, aber...
Na ja klar, ich meine, wenn sie den Check auf Code-Signing aushebeln, heben sie damit das aus, was ja eigentlich mal wer recht zuverlässig verhindern sollte, in Anführungsstrichen.
Also das ist, um das nochmal kurz zwischendurch zu sagen, wenn man dieses Pwnage gemacht hat bei seinem iPhone, dann kann man ganz normal über den App-Store, genauso wie bei Apple beworben, kann man alles, kann man sich Software kaufen, kann man sich Software kostenlos runterladen, das geht alles ganz großartig. Man kann über diesen...
Aber, muss man auch nochmal dazu sagen, weil es kommt wieder das Apple is Evil der Woche-Ding.
Das kommt heute nicht nur einmal.
Aber Apple hat es nicht drauf, und Apple is Evil ist ja ein Unterschied. Und zwar, ich wollte, weil ich bin ja gar nicht so der Zeugkäuferkäufer, aber ich wollte das Apple Remote-Tool haben, was ja umsonst ist. Und ich konnte es mir aber erstmal so nicht holen, weil man dazu so einen iTunes-Account haben muss, wofür man wieder eine Kreditkarte braucht. Also du musst dich auch für freie Software, die nicht kostet, einen Account mit Kreditkarte erstellen. Weil sie natürlich wollen, dass du danach schneller irgendwie geneigt bist, dann auch doch mal den einen Dollar auszugeben, weil der Account ist ja schon da, dann brauchst du ja nur noch klicken.
Aber das stimmt übrigens nicht. Ich hab ja auch keine Kreditkarte.
Du musst dich anmelden und du musst irgendwie was angeben, womit du dann bezahlen kannst.
Ja, so war es auch schon immer beim iTunes Music Store. Ja, da hab ich es ja auch schon nicht gemacht. Ja, aber es ist nicht wirklich was Neues, hier fällt es bloß ein weiteres Mal auf.
Ja, ich werd das auch machen, aber ich hab gerade keine Kreditkarte.
Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt da irgendwie, ich glaube, First-Gate-Click-and-Buy oder irgendwie sowas. Kann man da drüber auch machen, bei iTunes.
Hab ich auch irgendwie gesehen, aber kannte ich erst mal nicht und bei Geldgeschichten, wenn ich was nicht kenne, dann...
Also das sind ziemlich zuverlässige Ers Also ich nutze den auch gerne. Also ich hatte da schon einen Account sogar, um Heise-Artikel nachkaufen zu können. Und bei denen kann man auf der Seite dann CT-Artikel nachkaufen und das ist natürlich immer so, wenn einem einfällt, dass man vor drei Jahren mal eine CT hat, in der was Spannendes drin stand, dass man natürlich immer irgendwo ist, wo man die gerade nicht greifbar hat. Nämlich irgendwo. darum kaufe ich dann gerne mal Artikel nach für ein bisschen Geld und darum hatte ich so einen Account schon. Der geht auch super mit iTunes und ich hab bisher nur gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht. Genau, also es geht, der App Store geht mit der gepaunten Software, es geht dieser Zydiainstaller, den es auch schon für die alte Firmware gab, der aber jetzt toller ist als der alte Installer oder was? Das ist ein bisschen anders.
Der ist der Zydiainstaller, ich hab ja jetzt kein Linux-Zeugs, aber der ist immer mit diesem APT Package-System.
Der funktioniert so wie ein Debian-System mit UpGit.
Für mich sind die Leute dahinter ziemlich aktiv.
Die sind ziemlich aktiv, der macht einen sehr robusten Eindruck dieser Installer.
Naja robust, mir ist ja schon mehrmals um die Ohren geflogen. Ja. Aber sonst, wie die das so anbieten und wie das so geht, macht das alles einen sehr gut integrierten Eindruck.
Wie heißt denn nochmal das andere Portsystem, was nicht Mac Ports ist?
Fink?
Ja genau, Fink benutzt auch UpGit.
Und das funktioniert, er kann automatisch Packages nachladen, die er braucht. Wenn irgendwas auf irgendwas anderes angewiesen ist, dann holt er das alles runter. Den Installer wird es aber auch wieder geben. In der Version 4.0 dann glaube ich. Die hatten großartig irgendwo mal angekündigt, ja sobald Pwnage 2.0 draußen ist, sind wir auch da. Sind sie aber offensichtlich nicht. Und den wird es dann auch irgendwann noch mal geben, den Installer in der Theorie.
Und der größte Vorteil von diesem Züdi-Installer ist, wie wir alle wissen, gibt es im App Store Flashlights. Welche für umsonst. Und dann gibt es welche für, der teuerste kostet glaube ich drei Dollar.
Die leuchten dann aber auch heller, oder?
Eben nicht. Eben nicht. Weil, den machst du an und der kommt in der Brightness, wie dein Telefon eingestellt ist. Das heißt, wenn du dein Telefon auf voll dunkel stellst, dann kommt Flashlight auch wirklich das ganze weiß in voll dunkel. Und jetzt kommt es, wenn du den Züdi-Installer hast, weil der Typ muss sich halt nicht an die Apple-Beschränkung halten, sondern er kann halt auf Hidden Frameworks und so weiter zugreifen, dessen Flashlight geht halt in voll Brightness auf. Deswegen...
Was für ein Feature. Also ein echter Grund für ein Jailbreak, oder?
Wenn man echtes Flashlight will, muss man unbedingt... Mann, muss man Jailbreaken.
Okay, das ist jetzt mal echt ein Grund. Wie Schneehaas hat gefragt, warum man das jetzt eigentlich bräuchte. Aber es wird ja wahrscheinlich jetzt eh nicht so viel alter... Okay, es wird sicherlich Software... Gibt es schon Software?
Habt ihr schon was gesehen? Also was ich zum Beispiel...
Die jetzt nicht im Store ist, meine ich.
Ja, also was ich zum Beispiel natürlich drauf gespielt habe...
Der Hauptsache der ganzen Unix-Kram erst mal.
Also ich find's ja immer... Ich hab seit Jahren einen SMS-Sound, den ich sehr gerne mag, der so ein Klick an ist. Und beim iPhone kann man ja nach wie vor den SMS-Sound machen. Man hat zwar mehrere zur Auswahl, aber man kann keine eigenen hochspielen. Also...
Nutzt du dann nicht auch einfach die Ringtones? Ach, aha.
Und darum spiel ich mir immer eine eigene Datei hoch.
Wie ist denn der SMS-Sound vom iPhone?
Das sind ganz verschiedene...
Von den Telefon-Rings, die dabei sind, kannst du deinen aussuchen.
Nee, das sind keine Telefon-Rings, das sind extra SMS-Sounds.
Okay, also man kann ihn konfigurieren, aber man kann nicht aus den Ringtones da, wo man eigene Hochzeilen auswählen soll.
Also hab ich meinen eigenen SMS-Ton hochgespielt und das macht man per SSH und das gibt's natürlich nicht von Apple direkt im App-Store.
Verstehe.
Also alles, was im Hintergrund läuft, gibt's nicht im App-Store.
Stimmt, die SMS-Sounds, die sind ein bisschen anders. Und zwar haben wir hier den, oder den.
Warte mal, kann ich jetzt gleich mal meinen vorspielen?
Kommen die alle durch jetzt?
Ja, ich hör so ein bisschen was. Weil es ist nicht besonders laut.
Achso.
Kannst du einfach mal direkt vor deinem Mikrofon halten. Dreh das Mikrofon ein bisschen weg.
Ich hab auch gerade alles ein bisschen leise.
Das auch noch.
So hier. Genau, der hier nervt einen besonders immer.
Oh, der ist eklig. Machen wir mal die anderen.
Alle?
Ja, mal gucken, welchen ich... Das ist doch der...
Der Standard. Der erste war der Standard gerade.
Dieses Dudellimb, das krieg ich doch irgendwo her.
Ich hatte eine Zeit lang diese Türklingel. Warte mal, da kommt eine Türklingel. Und da hat Joe, der Hund von Tanja und Johnny, immer angefangen rumzubellen, jedes Mal, wenn er SMS kam. Das war ganz unerträglich.
Da musstest du den Ton ändern.
Na Gott sei Dank, dass es überhaupt konfigurierbar ist, sonst wär kein Frieden mit dem Hund möglich gewesen.
Ja, ansonsten hätten wir ihn leider den Hund einschläfern lassen müssen. Das wäre für Tanja sehr traurig gewesen. Alles fürs iPhone.
Sie hat sie jetzt auch noch, der Hund. Gut, es ist sicherlich erwähnenswert, dass für die Leute, die jetzt noch nicht auf den 2.0 Zug aufspringen wollen, auch noch ein 1.1.5 Update verfügbar ist. Zumindest für den Touch, fürs iPhone.
Fürs iPhone nicht. Da wollen sie, dass man upgradet. Bei dem Touch verkaufen sie die Software und die Erklärung, weil ich weiß nicht, ob wir das auch schon hatten. Die Software für den Touch kostet deswegen Geld, weil Apple die Einnahmen des iPod Touch sofort versteuert oder was? Keine Ahnung.
Verbucht.
Und deswegen dürfen sie keine Features nachliefern. Genau.
Das ist amerikanische Gesetzgebung.
Da gibt es irgendwie so einen komischen, genau. Und beim iPhone ist es halt über zwei Jahre oder wie lange auch immer. Und dann können sie halt nachliefern. Aber was heißt das, dass man nach zwei Jahren neue iPhone-Software auch Geld kostet?
Das ist eine gute Frage, was eigentlich nach 24 Monaten dann passiert. Eigentlich würde ich das so interpretieren, dass sozusagen die Laufzeit abgelaufen ist, dass dann eben, aber wahrscheinlich scheißen sie dann eh auf Geräte, die zwei Jahre alt sind.
Wahrscheinlich. Wir hoffen, dass es in zwei Jahren Rock Solid ist.
Ja, also ich meine, ich mach mir vor allem, ich meine Features ist das eine, aber Security-Updates würde Apple gut zu Gesicht stehen, wenn sie sich grundsätzlich da noch bemühen, lange Updates zu liefern. Ich meine, derzeit hat man auf dem Mac die Situation, dass du für 10.3 gibt's keine Updates mehr, ne? Doch. Für 10.3 noch? Ist für 10.3 noch ein Security-Update gekommen?
Security weiß ich nicht, aber zum Beispiel das neueste QuickTime und so liefern sie immer und iTunes und all sowas. Und ich glaube, da sind dann auch, doch, da sind dann auch noch die Security-Updates dabei. 10.2 gibt's glaub ich nichts mehr.
Nee, 10.2 ist definitiv vorbei, 10.3 kann sein, dass es noch dabei ist, wenn wir es gerade nicht für sich haben. Na, wie auch immer. Sie machen schon lange Support, da ist jetzt nicht unbedingt der Grund noch drauf zu hauen. Ja, also kann man das schon empfehlen, ja?
Ja, ich denk mal, da kommt demnächst, das ist ja auch schon, haben die ja bei Boy Genius Report schon gesehen, das ist schon Leute mit einer iPhone 2.0.1-Firmware irgendwie surfen und da wird es wohl demnächst ein Update geben.
Hält euer Akku jetzt länger? Das ist ja die Mutmaßung, dass die neue Software auch energieeffizienter arbeitet.
Es könnte sein, weiß ich nicht, aber das Problem ist immer, wenn man irgendwie sein...
Das fand ich schlecht.
Wenn man eine neue Software hat, spielt man ja so viel damit rum und wenn du viel mit deinem Telefon spielst, ist es halt echt schnell leer.
In den ersten zwei Wochen kann man das wahrscheinlich eh nicht sagen.
Ja, jetzt hält es gerade so einen Tag, als ich mal mein iPhone nicht benutzt hab, hielt es einmal irgendwie knappe 6 Tage am Stück irgendwie. Also ich hab halt nicht telefoniert und nichts gemacht und dann hält es auch.
Hier gibt es ein cooles neues Gadget und zwar für das Dock, zum ranstecken, eine Backup-Batterie.
Ja, da gibt es Tausende von.
Tausende gibt es? Das erste Mal, dass wir es gesehen haben.
Nee, da gibt es irgendwo eine Seite, wo er alle gegeneinander auflistet. Da gibt es welche von, weiß nicht, 30 Dollar bis 100 circa und sogar von APC und so gibt es auch einen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Ich meine, es verlängert natürlich das Phone extrem. Da hast du auf einmal so einen Stab in der Hand, aber dafür hast du Strom.
Ja, also. Aber es gibt so einen Backpack auch, wo man das dann quasi so reinschiebt.
Dann hat man so einen schönen dicken Brick.
Wobei, also mit der Akkulaufzeit bin ich eigentlich relativ tief zufrieden vom iPhone. Ich weiß nicht, wie es beim neuen ist, aber bei dem das ist schon, oder beim neuen ist es wohl...
Die Batterie im iPhone 3G ist ja kleiner als in dem 2G. In dem, hier wir haben 1400 mAh und das 3G hat nur noch 1150 oder so.
Schon deutlich weniger.
Warum auch immer. Im 3G Modus soll es auf jeden Fall nicht so toll sein. Also was ich so gehört habe, ist, dass es schon ganz ordentlich wegfrisst.
Ja, also das auf jeden Fall.
Es kommt auch so an, wenn man schlechten UMTS-Empfang hat, dann soll es ordentlich wegfrissen. Das heißt, hier in der Stadt dürften wir eher weniger Probleme haben.
Klar, weil da mit mehr Sendetleistung rausgehen muss. Das ist ja auch grundsätzlich so. Das ist jetzt nicht auf UMTS beschränkt. Ich bin bei Nokia eigentlich in ganz entspannten Standby-Zeiten. Aber wenn man jetzt die ganze Zeit mit telefoniert, ist natürlich auch irgendwann alle. Und mit Daten geht es irgendwie noch schneller. Und zwar richtig schnell.
Da hast du noch viel an, dann bist du da am rumsurfen, dann bist du im App-Store, guckst dir das Spiel an, oder weiss ich nicht was, das frisst halt weg wie Sau. Dann bist du am Musikhören, am Filme gucken, ist halt nur mal ein kleiner Minicomputer.
Ja gut, aber ich denke, wenn man auch wirklich Heavy-Use macht auf so einem portablen Teil, dann sollte man auch einfach einen Netzteil einstecken haben. Mindestens, dass man es über USB irgendwie legt.
Richtig doll. Ich hab nur ein 3D-Spiel bisher, aber richtig doll sind diese 3D-Spielesaugen. Das muss unglaublich sein.
Super Monkey Ball?
Super Monkey Ball und dieses Crazy-Racer-Dings-Bumms-Spiel, Autofahrspiel, das ist irgendwie...
Dann wird das Silikon voll ausgehobelt.
Aber ich bin, also trotz aller berechtigten Kritik von wegen Abstürzen und so weiter, die wirklich nervig sind, die aber bisher, muss ich auch sagen, nie so in Momenten kamen. Also ich kann ja so Telefonien dann plötzlich nachts um drei abstürzen, wenn man zum einen den Wecker dann nicht mehr hören kann und zum zweiten auch die Person, die einem darauf hinweisen will, dass man, dass das Wecker nicht geklingelt hat, nicht mehr durchkommt. Die hatte ich bisher noch nicht, sondern es kommt immer relativ konsequent immer, zum Beispiel, oder nicht konsequent immer, sondern gelegentlich mal bei einem Programm starten oder das Programme plötzlich nicht mehr starten oder sich dann das Telefon neu starten muss, damit sie wieder starten.
Das hatte ich eigentlich eher noch nicht bisher.
Du hast doch keine App Store-Programme, glaube ich.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt. Aber ich weiß noch eine alte Geschichte. Früher hatte ich halt Nokia, weiß nicht ob das schon das 63C Niva oder der Vorgänger oder der Vorgänger. Aber da habe ich irgendwann mal so ein Monitoring-Mode gestartet und dann war da so ein Watchdog-Counter und da stand irgendwas von 400 Tralala irgendwas und da habe ich mal unseren local Telefonexperten gefragt, was das heißt und meinte, das ist die Anzahl, wie oft das Nokia sich von selbst rebooted hat. 400 Mal. Ich meine, das hatte ich da vielleicht ein Jahr oder so.
400 Mal im Jahr? Also mehr als einmal pro Tag?
Ist in der Tasche so, du merkst es ja nicht, es bootet. Also es stürzt ab. Also vielleicht ist es ja auch, keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es ja intentional, dass die immer mal wieder neu booten, wenn sie gerade merken, guckt keiner aufs Display.
Einmal pro Tag, einfach booten, damit es bei Netflix nicht läuft und manchmal stürzt es noch zusätzlich ab. Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge.
Also ich meine, bei Apple könnte man im Augenblick das Gefühl kriegen, dass sie das gleiche eingebaut haben.
Reboot tut gut. Ja, aber mit dem Upstore ist nicht alles so sauber gelaufen überhaupt. Blicken wir auf zwei Wochen zurück.
Stürmische Wochen.
Stürmische Wochen ist überhaupt gar kein Ausdruck. Also ich finde, sie haben echt verdammt abgelost. Was mich ja persönlich am meisten zickt, auch wenn ich jetzt noch nicht unbedingt davon betroffen bin, aber das stimmt mich bedenklich. Das ist einfach, wie sie ihren Upstore derzeit handeln. Also ich meine, so Bugs im OS und was crasht und so, wir wissen alle, dann kommt die 201 und dann sieht es wieder anders aus. Aber was halt wirklich ein echtes Problem zu sein scheint, ist die Art und Weise, wie ihr einen Upstore handelt. Das heißt, die Developer werfen da jetzt Programme rein, jetzt haben sie da irgendwie knapp 1000 drin. Dann kaufen sich die Leute das, benutzen das ein bisschen, haben 4-5 Bugs. Und da gab es ja diesen Bericht von dem Brent Simmons, der den NetNews-Fire hackt.
Der noch relativ freundlich ist.
Der immer sehr freundlich ist. Oder ein sehr freundlicher Mensch ist. Und der hat dann sehr freundlich geklagt, dass er bereits 5 Updates für seine Software bereitgestellt hätte.
Und die alle noch in einer Pipeline liegen und noch nicht im Store sind.
So sieht es aus. Und 5 finde ich ist ein bisschen hart. Also kann ja sein, dass er sie irgendwie täglich...
Aber ich meine, Apple hat sich auch echt mit diesem Wochenende ein bisschen was auf die Schulter gelegt, oder? Die machen einen Mobile-Me-Umwechsel, die machen den App Store, die machen ihnen neue Software.
Ja gut, aber das hat ja erst mal nichts damit zu tun, was sie noch alles parallel machen.
Liebe Leute macht weniger, wenn ihr es nicht drauf habt.
Ich meine, offensichtlich konnten ja innerhalb der ersten 2 Wochen weitere 400 bis 500 Applikationen neu released werden. Warum konnten dann nicht 200 der existierenden ein Update releasen? Das passt so nicht zusammen mit Überarbeitungen.
Es gibt glaube ich da einen ganzen Haufen kleinerer Probleme. Wie wollen Sie das auch testen? Was ich zum Beispiel gelesen habe, ist, dass irgendein Hersteller e-Wallet oder so etwas, die hatten ihr Programm pünktlich zum 11. Juli eingereicht. Es hätte eigentlich alles da sein können, aber... Warum wäre ich heute schnell angerufen?
Weil du es nicht in den Airplane-Modus gebracht hast.
Genau.
Dann könnte ich auch nicht mehr surfen.
Nein, doch. Du hast iPhone 2.0, da kann man jetzt GSM ausschalten und Wi-Fi anlassen.
Ich muss aber gerade kurz eine SMS schreiben.
Hast du recht, habe ich auch gelesen, habe ich aber noch nicht gefunden. Ihr quatscht mal, ich finde das raus.
SMS schreiben, na toll.
Ich habe gerade eine SMS bekommen, dass einer unseres Server da ist, und weil ich ohne Laptop hier sitze...
Siehst du, einmal ohne Laptop unterwegs und schon erwischt...
Mein Leih-Laptop ist gerade verliehen und der hier ist kaputt.
Ich habe ja einen Ersatz-Laptop. Aber nicht dabei. Der ist noch dabei, die Daten rüberzuholen.
Okay, ich habe die schon wieder unterbrochen. E-Wallet hat das gleichzeitig fertig.
Die haben das irgendwie fertig und sind jetzt irgendwie knapp zwei Wochen nachdem sie es gehofft hatten, im Shop vertreten zu sein, sind sie jetzt tatsächlich online. Und jetzt ist ihre Software verfügbar. Und sie haben nie erfahren, wann. Also es hat ihnen auch niemand vorher Bescheid gesagt. Übrigens, ihr seid morgen dabei. Oder sowas. Sondern das war einfach...
Nö, das ist klassische Apple-Politik. Wir sagen euch gar nichts. Vor allem, die developer wissen noch nicht mal, wie viel sie verkauft haben.
Das ist richtig, da steht jetzt immer noch null Downloads.
Das stimmt.
Es gab erst mal diese ominöse Download-Dingsbums. Am Anfang haben sie so einen Counter mitgemacht, der ganz offensichtlich auch irgendwie erst mal nicht so richtig stimmte, weil der irgendwie auch so fluktuierte. Also er hat offensichtlich nicht richtig funktioniert. Dann gab es halt so Zahlen, da hat, glaube ich, Techcrunch oder so sich das mal geschnappt und dann gleich mal angefangen, hochzurechnen hier, Verkaufspreis, mal Downloads und dann so, jetzt analysieren wir hier mal, wie viel Markt gemacht wurde. Das hat ihnen da wohl nicht gepasst. Und gerade weil das auch irgendwie nicht richtig funktioniert hat, lustigerweise auch nur auf dem iPhone im App Store angezeigt wird, aber nicht in iTunes selber, haben sie es gleich wieder kassiert. Aber nicht so kassiert, dass es dann gar nicht mehr angezeigt werden würde. Da steht ja null Downloads. Und dann kommen so haarsträubende Sachen, das war doch hier bei Bits und so letzte Woche, wo das erwähnt wurde, da hab ich mir echt am Kopf gefasst, dass dann halt so Reviews sind im iTunes Store. Und dann aber Leute ankommen und sagen, null Downloads, und hier gibt's schon Reviews, das ist doch alles fake. Also Apple ist da gerade in einer Situation, wo sie auch ihre Developer vollständig diskreditieren, auch wenn sie die Updates nicht durchlassen. Ich meine, die Leute laden sich jetzt Software runter, die funktioniert nicht. Der hat das innerhalb von einer Stunde gefixt, vielleicht. Grad Brent Simmons ist jemand, der extrem schnell reagiert auf solche Sachen und eine super Kommunikation, die er mit seinen Kunden hat, auch so auf Mailing-Listen und so. Und der einfach jetzt gar nicht in der Lage ist, das ist irgendwas zu machen. Und vor allem, wir auch ganz richtig beklagt, keine Beta-Tests machen.
Also ich meine, dieser App-Store nimmt im Augenblick den Entwicklern komplett jegliche Vertriebsmöglichkeit aus der Hand. Das schmeißt deine Software in eine Blackbox und hofft, dass sie irgendwann mal bei uns auftaucht?
Ja, man kriegt halt nur diese komischen Fehlerreports. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man die kriegt, aber damit können viele Developer auch erst mal nichts anfangen.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch halt das NDA immer noch, dass man auch nicht über iPhone-Development öffentlich diskutieren darf. Also da wird es dann auch irgendwann echt albern. Und da sind wir eigentlich voll im Apple-is-Evil-Programm angekommen. Das ist einfach mal nicht in Ordnung. Also ich meine, wenn man sich eine... Also wenn man den Developern schon so viel auflastet, für die Security und für Apples-Control und so weiter, mit kurz einigen Pipapo und nur Single Store und so weiter, wenn man dann irgendwie sie in diese Zwangsjacke packt, aber dann das NDA noch nicht mal mit dem Release aufhebt. Ich meine, was soll denn das? Ich kann mir das runterladen, dann bin ich auch Developer, dann weiß ich das auch, was da drinsteht. Warum soll man dann nicht öffentlich darüber diskutieren? Ja, und ich meine, alle ihre Competitors, die da irgendwie sind, sind sowieso Developer und wissen das auch. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was das soll. Und das ist wirklich nicht in Ordnung. Und da müssen sie auch wirklich ganz schnell was machen. Und dann halt auch noch solche Flops, wie mit der... Dann kamen sie irgendwie alle an und haben irgendwie so AAA und irgendwie Leerzeichen, Leerzeichen, Underscore, Underscore für ihre Titel geballert.
Ein Trim vor der Teilnahme, bitte.
Das wolltet ihr wissen.
Jetzt haben sie einen drinnen. Aber ich meine, das...
Die werden da so ein bisschen überrannt, glaube ich.
Ist das immer so, wenn man was Erfolgreiches am Start hat?
Na ja, aber ich meine...
Gibt es eigentlich andere Stores für andere Telefone? Und wie laufen diese?
Habe ich neulich erst durch Umwege erfahren über diesen Heiseartikel.
Na für diesen...
Jaaa...
Also für diesen Hip-Top, oder wie heißt das Ding? Hip-Top heißt das Ding, glaube ich.
Ich hab da ewig nur so ein schwarz-weißes Handy.
Hip-Top? Die Hälfte der Applikation ist alles nur Porno-Download, Porno-Download und Porno-Download.
Nee, also es gibt diesen Sidekick und der hat...
Die haben keine Flashlights?
Die sind mit Screenshot.
Die Flashlights sind mit Screenshot. Das ist zwei Screenshots. Das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon, glaube ich. Ja, aber für den Sidekick gibt es ein relativ ähnliches Prinzip. Da gibt es natürlich nicht halb so viel Software für, aber das ist Sidekick. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz hübsches Gerät. Das kann man so zur Seite drehen, da hat man eine Tastatur drauf, also für Instant-Messaging gemacht. Da ist ein relativ abgeschottetes Vertriebsprinzip eigentlich relativ ähnlich bei einem iPhone.
Eigentlich haben sie auch alle so ein ähnliches Modell. Das hat Apple ja auch von Anfang an gesagt, dass sie da auf Nokias Spuren folgen mit Codesigning und Pipapo. Bloß, es gibt halt keine ordentlichen Applikationen dafür. Ich hab mir das angeschaut, was bei diesen komischen, da fällt jetzt nicht der Name ein, von diesen komischen JAR-Teilen, die hatten halt, weiß weiß ich, wie viele Applikationen, aber alles, was ich mir da beklicken kann, lief im Wesentlichen eigentlich immer auf Pono-Download. Also irgendwelche Tools, die da halt automatisch Pornos zusammensuchen. Naja, ich meine, da werden die Leute das benutzen. Ist ja auch mal eine echte Anwendung. Sowas gibt's nicht im iTunes Store.
Dabei gibt's auch genug Schrott. Also man kann bestimmt sagen, von der Software, ist das vielleicht 20% irgendwie brauchbar.
Ja, also mich würde wirklich mal interessieren, auf welcher Basis Apple da eigentlich ein Review macht. Weil sie können unmöglich die Features der Programme testen. Da müssten sie sicher, was weiß ich hier, gerade die ganze Software für Social Networks und Blogs und so weiter, da müssten die sich Blogs für anlegen und sich selber in Social Networks rumtreiben. Wie wollen die das testen?
Das testen die auch nicht.
Ja, aber was bitte tun sie dann, wenn Brent Simmons fünf Updates für seine Software einlädt? Hochlädt.
Keine Ahnung.
Was tun sie dann? Sitzen da nur zwei Leute hier, wie beim Podcast-Verzeichnis in Deutschland, die da ab und zu mal drüberschauen?
Wahrscheinlich haben sie eher irgendeinen automatisierten Prozess und der ist gerade kaputt. Und sie können gar nicht richtig.
Ach, die sollen...
Meinst du das? Aber was soll denn dieser automatische Prozess tun?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Sie müssen das ja irgendwie, die Programme in ihren App Store Server irgendwie reinkriegen. Und da wird wahrscheinlich gerade irgendwas nicht gehen. Oder die müssen ihn irgendwie umrüsten, weil was auch immer. Also ich glaube, das gibt schon noch kompliziertere Probleme, als sie uns vorstellen können.
Ich denke, was auch immer sie da tun, sie müssen aufhören, das zu tun. Sie müssen einfach den Scheiß releasen und sie sollten eher so sehen, dass wenn irgendwas rauskommt, wo sich dann fest... Ich bin ein bisschen zu müde heute schon für den Podcast. Wo dann rauskommt, dass das irgendwie böse ist, ja, dann können sie das Ding immer noch revoken. Wenn sie hier revoking Infrastruktur in place haben, was man auch nicht weiß.
Die sollen solchen Entwicklern, die müssen ihren Entwicklern soweit vertrauen, haben eh keine andere Chance. Also ich meine entweder sie haben automatisierten Prozess, der es durchcheckt, der kann das auch innerhalb von 20 Sekunden machen und dann die Software sofort online stellen. Oder da setzt sich irgendein Azubi hin. Und ich meine, wer soll das machen? Das werden wahrscheinlich irgendwelche billigen Praktikanten sein. Die werden sich mal durch die Software durchklickern, ob die jetzt irgendwie drei Wochen später was Eviles macht oder nicht. Das können die doch eh nicht überprüfen. Also sie sollen den Leuten Zugang geben, damit die dann die Software vernünftig reinstellen können. Weil so ist es glaube ich kein Zustand.
Weißt du, die haben bestimmt irgendwelche Verträge mit ihren Telekom-Freunden, wo drin steht Software, die jetzt über Cell Unmengen an Bandbreite erzeugt, müsst ihr sperren für was auch immer.
Instant Messenger zum Beispiel.
Und ja, also keine Ahnung. Wir werden es nicht feststellen, trotz alledem sieht es ganz so aus, als ob Development ganz gut anläuft. Es gibt hier eine Meldung bei Macworld, wo eine Company, die ich noch nicht kannte, die hier heißt Device Anywhere, berichtet, dass sehr viel mehr Leute sich bei ihnen subscriben für iPhone Development. Das ist so eine Bude, die einfach alle Mobilplattformen bei sich am Laufen hat. Und du kannst halt dann automatisches testen und was weiß ich, Quality of Service, Schnickes machen und verzeichnen. Ja, genau, hier testet mal auf iPhone und dann haben sie da eine Batterie für iPhones rumliegen. Ist natürlich gerade für die Geräte, wo jetzt viel Wildwuchs ist, so was weiß ich, Symbian, hat ja nicht jeder, alle Telefone auf dem Tisch liegen, ist jetzt bei iPhone nicht so das Ding, hat mich von daher gewundert. Trotz alledem auch die stellen fest, dass das so ihre dominante Plattform zu sein scheint in dieser kurzen Zeit, wo einfach die meisten Leute nachfragen.
Ach ist ja auch eine spannende Plattform, macht ja auch Spaß. Wie gesagt, ich hab mit dem neuen Safari, das war der Grund, warum ich so lange rumgebracht habe fürs Pwnish, weil ich dann meinen kleinen Insta... Habe ich das schon... Habe ich das on-Air oder auf wie er erzählt? Was? Diesen Twitter-Client, dass die ihn so umgeschrieben haben.
Da haben wir letztes Mal...
Und es gibt jetzt diese Touch-RP, mit der ich mich unbedingt mal beschäftigen möchte, wenn ich noch nichts erzählt habe. Also dass man auch als Web-Entwickler auf die Touches nachprüfen kann und Multitouch-Gesten auswerten kann.
Ach echt? Das ist neu?
Das ist neu. Da gibt es ein paar niedliche Sachen, wo man dann schon so Fotos nehmen kann, die man aufziehen kann, mit zwei Fingern, einfach in Safari. Das ist sehr, sehr hübsch. Schicko. Also da werden wir bestimmt auch noch eine Menge hübscher Web-Applikationen sehen. Insbesondere, weil der Review-Prozess vom App-Store ja nicht unbedingt der Hammer ist.
Ja, die sind jetzt ihre Updates wahrscheinlich alle als Web-Apps, damit sie sie auch zu den Kunden kriegen. Auweia. Aber wir sollten eigentlich gar kein iPhone kaufen, habe ich gelesen. Bei unseren Freunden...
Was heißt denn wir? Wir haben schon...
Wir alle sind gefangen.
Hier steht ja auch explizit Five Reasons to Avoid iPhone 3G. Das ist nicht der Titel, das ist die erste Zeile des Textes.
Ach so, der Titel.
Ist ja auch egal, ob es nun real ist oder nicht. Ich hab schon lange nicht mehr so einen Quatsch gelesen.
Erzähl mal, ich hab das ja noch nicht gelesen. Das erklär mich mal auf.
Ich find ja den fünften Punkt, den fünften echten Grund, finde ich am besten.
Lass uns mal mit dem ersten anfangen. iPhone Completely, also wir reden jetzt hier über einen Blogpost auf dem Blog der Free Software Foundation, die ja Heereziele hat und viel Gutes getan hat, das wollte ich jetzt alles gar nicht abstreiten, aber die halt, sagen wir mal, ein sehr verspanntes Verhältnis hat zu Apple schon immer. Und zum iPhone natürlich im Besonderen ist auch abgebildet ein iPhone mit diesem alten Anti-DHM-Logo, gefesselte iPod-Tanzmaus mit irgendwie jetzt alles auf iPhone rumgebannert, wie auch immer. Also die fünf Gründe sind und das erste lautet iPhone completely blocks free software. Developers must pay a tax to Apple, who becomes the sole authority over what can and can't be on everyone's phones. Naja.
Das ist der Punkt, den Punkt muss man jetzt mal sagen.
Haben sie auch erstmal recht, weil selbst wenn die Software frei ist, die man in den App Store bringt, muss man ja die 99 Dollar bezahlen für das iPhone S.
Gut, das ist aber ein Service. Keine Tax, weil du musst nicht einen Anteil abdrücken. Du kannst die freie Software kostenlos vertreiben. Abgesehen davon ist es auch nicht verboten, freie Software zu verkaufen. Würde man auch machen. Dann würde Apple natürlich eine Tax nehmen, weil sie auf alles was verkauft wird eine Tax nehmen. Aber wir haben jetzt ausführlich darüber geredet, auch wenn wir nicht genau wissen, was sie da eigentlich tun. Sie haben eine Kontrolle darüber. Und sie sind auch in dem Sinne die einzigen, wenn man jetzt mal von dem Jailbreak absieht. Nur ist die Aussage Completely Blocks Free Software einfach Quatsch. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie es vollständig verhindern. Natürlich kann man freie Software nehmen und als iPhone Application releasen. Insofern ist diese Aussage einfach mal nicht. Vollständig korrekt.
Die zweite Hälfte des Letzten stimmt es aber.
iPhone endorses and supports Digital Restrictions Management, DRM Technology.
Was heißt denn endorses?
Na ja, endorsing ist so, man nimmt das so an für sich. Man unterstützt das.
Sie würden ja gerne weg davon kommen. Dafür gibt es doch iTunes Plus.
Na man muss jetzt mal zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Das eine ist halt DRM für Musik. Drei Sachen muss man unterscheiden. DRM für Musik, DRM für Video und DRM für Applikationen. Genau.
Der Artikel geht unten noch ein bisschen weiter. Da erzählen sie genau auf den Punkt ein.
Aber okay. Okay, können wir gleich machen. Aber das ist das, worum es geht bei DRM. Ich meine, gut, das kann man jetzt generell scheiße finden oder nicht. Das ist eher so eine Meinungsgeschichte. DRM bei Musik ist sicherlich eine schlechte Sache. Wenn Musik mit DRM verkauft wird, das haben wir nun alle in den letzten Jahren häufig genug durchgekaut und ich glaube, da sind wir auch weitgehend aller Meinung. Bei Video sieht es halt ein bisschen anders aus, insofern, dass diese Rentalsysteme eigentlich sehr populär sind. Und ich finde, für Rental ist DRM eigentlich okay.
Darüber kann man ja gespaltener Meinung sein.
Da werde ich jetzt natürlich ganz furchtbar niedergerantet werden.
Da kauf ich ja nichts, sondern da leihe ich ja was.
Genau, man leiht es halt. Es erlaubt halt dieses Modell. Man muss an diesem Modell ja nicht teilnehmen. Bloß wenn man halt was kauft, was man auch häufig nutzt, so wie Musik, dann sieht das schon ganz anders aus. Klar kann man jetzt sagen, aber bei Rental mit DRM, dann kann ich ja auch nicht auswählen, worauf ich mir das anschaue. Okay, dann ist halt der Rentelservice nicht für dich. Das geht ja auch anders. Ja, ich meine, was jetzt DRM auf, also Fairplay heißt ja das System, wovon hier die Rede ist, das DRM von Apple, was auf MPEG-4 aufsetzt, und das verwenden sie ja auch nach eigener Aussage für den Kopierschutz, ja für die Programme, dass du halt nicht das Binary auf ein anderes iPhone rüber schieben kannst.
Fairplay-Demon auf dem iPhone.
Ahja, echt? Fairplay-D? Genau, so. Naja, so. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Grund, das iPhone nicht zu benutzen. Behaupten sie. Kann man so sehen. Man kann auch sagen, ist halt einfach ihr Ansatz, den Softwaremarkt dort zu schützen.
Und man muss sagen, zumindest was den Musikbereich angeht, ist man ja nicht dazu verpflichtet. Man kann ja, es ist ja nicht so, als ob man keine Möglichkeit hätte, keine MP3s oder keine M4As abzuspielen, als ob man nur DRM-Dateien hat.
Genau, man muss ja gar keine Musik bei denen im Shop kaufen. Ich kann ja auch meine eigenen CDs mit iTunes ganz normal in einen MP3 verwandeln und dann da raufschieben.
Das ist richtig. Wie auch immer. Nummer 3. iPhone exposes your whereabouts and provides ways for others to track you without your knowledge. Also, iPhone sagt, wo du bist und gibt anderen die Möglichkeit, dich zu tracken.
Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also erstens, wenn halt der Funkprovider, also die Telekom oder so raus sind, wo ich mit meinem Telefon gerade bin, dann können die das auch sowieso mit jedem Mobiltelefon machen. So, wenn die jetzt noch diesen Location-Service meinen, also mit GPS oder hier über Skyhook, dann ist es so, dass es bei der alten Software ging das wohl einfach so. Bei der neuen jetzt kommt so ein Requestor, dann steht da zum Beispiel das Foto, was heißt das Ding, Photosnap-App hier, will irgendwie die Location rausfinden, willst du das erlauben oder nicht? Und dann sagst du Yes oder No.
Jedes Mal? Dann kann man das auch so einstellen, dass er das nie mehr fragt?
Nein, das nervt er.
Ah, das kommt bestimmt noch. Diesen Dialog nicht noch einmal anzeigen.
Das ist aber auch nicht so schon. Das ist ein so ein...
Gut, ich meine, bei einem GSM- umts Telefon zu beklagen, dass man damit getreckt werden kann, das ist so ein bisschen bigot, weil das ist einfach mal die Grundeigenschaft eines solchen Telefons, dass man getreckt werden kann.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die meinen eher, dass die Programme das können.
Aber das ist...
Exposes your whereabouts. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht genau, wovon Sie reden. Reden Sie von Skyhawk Wireless?
Ich glaube schon, ich rede davon, dass da jemand Programme einspielen kann und dadurch irgendwie dann deine Location so richtig GPS-mäßig abfragen kann. Und das wär ja schon noch was anderes als das, was bei allen Telefonen geht. Und da haben Sie schon recht.
Das geht aber bei jedem GPS-Telefon. Also es geht bei jedem Telefon, das GPS eingebaut hat, kann die Software abfragen, wo du dich gerade aufhältst und kann die im 22 weiter schicken, wenn du irgendeine Sicherheitslücke in der Software findest und diesen Weg umgehst, diesen Dialog abzufragen.
Wenn so ein Dialog da überhaupt kommt, auf der jeweiligen Plattform.
Wenn der Dialog überhaupt kommt, auf der jeweiligen Plattform. Ich vermute auch, also bei Nokia habe ich das auch gesehen.
Aber bei Apple ist es jetzt so, also ich meine, sie tun noch was dagegen, das ist doch okay.
Sie tun wo was gegen.
Und dass das jeder abfragen kann, wenn dieser Request da kommt.
Ja gut, ich meine, bei Skyhook kann man natürlich generell argumentieren, dass in dem Moment, wo man halt das auch, also man kann ja nicht sagen, womit man getrackt werden soll. Man kann nur sagen, tracken ja, nein. Man kann nicht Skyhook ausschalten und GPS anschalten.
Aber track you without your knowledge ist schlicht und ergreifend falsch, weil ich vor jeder Tracking-Anfrage gefragt werde. Willst du jetzt getrackt werden? Und wenn du nein sagst, dann wirst du einfach nicht getrackt. Das heißt, das ist in jedem Fall mit meinem Wissen.
Und das machen die sogar auch bei nicht GPS, sondern bei dem alten iPhone ist es auch so. Kann ich ja mal kurz starten, dann siehst du es.
So, iPhone 1 Play Patent MDRM.
Ja genau, das ist jetzt der wichtigste Punkt. iPhone 1 Play.
Klick mal, drück mal ab.
Jetzt wird es getestet hier, ob wir auch das Richtige sagen.
Also mich hat das Foto-Tool schon mal gefragt, jetzt hat es aber nicht noch mal gefragt.
Hast du das beendet und wieder neu gestartet?
Na ja, ich hab schon tausendmal Reboote seitdem.
Ich meine jetzt zwischen diesen beiden?
Also es scheint, pro Programm wird nur einmal nachgefragt, ob es so bleiben darf oder nicht.
Ich bin schon innerhalb eines Programms mehrfach befragt worden. Ich weiß aber das Prinzip hab ich noch nicht so ganz einmittelt, das stimmt.
Okay, jetzt kommt mein Lieblingspunkt. iPhone won't play patent- and DRM-free formats like Okvorbis und Teora.
Like was?
Na so wie Okvorbis und Teora, ist sehr populär. Also ich meine diese Aussage ist insofern richtig, so wie sie hier formuliert ist, mit dem Like Okvorbis und Teora, aber es ist ansonsten nicht frei, weil also es spielt auf jeden Fall DRM-freie Formate ab, nämlich MP3. Ist nicht patentfrei.
AIFF.
Ich weiß nicht, kann man AIFF wirklich unmodified da draufladen, draufsinden?
Also selbst wenn nicht, kannst du Apple lossless draufschieben.
Da ist aber bestimmt auch ein Patent drauf von Apple. Weiß man ja nicht.
Also AIFF-Dateien werden auf jeden Fall Klingeltöne verwendet.
Diese Diskussion habe ich jetzt auch schon einige Male geführt. Ich verstehe die ja vollständig, dass es da den Wunsch gibt nach freien Formaten, vor allem nach einem patentfreien Format. Und es gibt die These, dass Okvobis und Teora das erfüllen. Bei Teora ist es so, dass da die Patente von dem einlichen Hersteller halt mal der Community quasi übergeben wurde, also das Versprechen, dass diese Patente da nie angezweifelt werden. Aber es gibt bisher noch keinen einzigen Testfall, wo wirklich mal festgestellt wurde, dass keine Formate, keine Methoden von Vorbes oder Teora nicht wirklich irgendein anderes Patent verletzen. Das ist die große Problematik.
Es ist der Versuch.
Es ist der Versuch. Bloß Tatsache ist, niemand traut sich aus diesem Grund daran. Der Industrie wird halt vorgeworfen, dass sie das nicht unterstützen. Deswegen sind sie alle ganz böse. Der Punkt ist nur, keine große Firma, die halbwegs bei Trost ist, würde sich jetzt da hinsetzen. Erstens ist MPEG 4 einfach der Medienstandard. Ich meine, das kann man jetzt beklagen, das kann man scheiße finden, aber es ist einfach die Realität.
Dann sollen sich die Leute doch die detailesenden OpenMoco kaufen.
Ja, das wird ja auch gleich noch empfohlen. Ich wollte noch mal kurz was zu dieser Patentsache sagen. Ich meine, auch das kann man natürlich jetzt scheiße finden. MP3 wird allerdings nicht mehr lange patentbehaftet sein. Ich hab neulich schon mal versucht nachzuschlagen, wann es jetzt eigentlich ist. Es ist in ein paar Jahren soweit.
Das ist aber noch vom Fragerover-Institut oder was?
Genau, ja, aber auch diese Patente laufen auch irgendwann aus. Und das ist jetzt auch bald soweit. Das heißt, in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft wird MP3 diese Patentfreiheit haben und zwar garantiert. Weil einfach alle bekannten Patente, die bisher enforced wurden und wofür bezahlt wurde, auslaufen und dann geht's weiter. Ich bin gespannt, es wird vielleicht irgendjemand jetzt noch einen schönen Hinweis in die Kommentare werfen. Da warte ich eigentlich schon lange drauf, ob da irgendein Patent ist, wo es noch den Hebel gibt, das zu verlängern. Ja, weiß nicht genau. Also ich bin da jetzt auch kein Patentanwalt, ich bin auch kein Experte in dem Bereich. Das ist mein aktueller Kenntnisstand. Andererseits muss ich auch sagen, ist echt ein bisschen paranoia damit im Spiel, weil, mein Gott, dann sind da halt Patente. Man kauft einfach dieses Gerät und man bezahlt damit eben auch diese akademische Leistung. Man muss nicht das Patenzsystem, so wie es ist, grundsätzlich gut finden, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es nicht auch Argumente dafür gibt. Und am Ende ist man natürlich auch froh, wenn man was ordentlich gepflegt ist und funktioniert, das auch bekommt. So, jetzt kommen wir zu meinem Lieblingspunkt. Den fünften. iPhone ist not the only option. There are better alternatives on the horizon that respect your freedom, don't spy on you, play free media formats and let you use free software. On the horizon sei angeblich der Freerunner, sagen sie.
Das finde ich super. Es spricht, man soll das iPhone vermeiden, weil man möglicherweise in der Zukunft am Horizont schon erkennen kann, ein Telefon.
Ein Glimm.
Es gibt Konkurrenz, es gibt nicht nur das iPhone.
Genau, es ist nicht im Laden, es ist im Horizont, muss man dazu sagen.
Aber Horizont ist auch was für eine.
Der Horizont hat diese besondere Eigenschaft, wenn du zum Laden gehst, bist du in der Regel nach 10 bis 15 Minuten da. Wenn du versuchst, zum Horizont zu gehen, bist du sehr, sehr, sehr lange unterwegs und kommst nicht an.
Vor allem der Horizont rennt manchmal weg.
Die ganze Zeit eigentlich. Den kriegste nicht. Wie auch immer, was wir feststellen dürfen, ist Open Moko, das Projekt, auch ein sehr lobenswertes Projekt, will ich gleich dazu sagen. Das ist ein Telefon. Das ist das zweite Telefon, was aus diesem Open Moko-Projekt heraus entstanden ist. Das erste war das NEO 1973.
Warum das so heißt?
Das hieß so, weil 1973 das erste Mobiltelefon in Betrieb genommen wurde. Dazu kann ich auch empfehlen. Sehr interessant, Open Moko Podcast mit Harald Welte, den ich gemacht habe, bei Carsradie Express.
Der da mal gearbeitet hat?
Der da mal gearbeitet hat, der aber mittlerweile dem Laden leicht angenervt den Rücken gekehrt hat, weil ihm das irgendwie zu viel Energie seines Lebens gekostet hat. Da jetzt nicht mehr dran mitarbeitet, sondern sich wieder den anderen Projekten zuwendet. Aber da wird sozusagen ganze Problematik und Technik usw. nochmal erläutert. Jetzt haben die halt weiter entwickelt. Jetzt gibt es eben das erste Telefon, was nicht nur für Entwickler ist, sondern was eben wirklich für Endkunden ist. Und das ist dieser Free Runner. Der sieht noch so ähnlich aus, das hat auch dieses komische Loch, hat immer noch keinen Halter für diesen Stift, den man eigentlich braucht. Wir haben hier vorhin nochmal schön dieses Video gesehen, wo jemand den Free Runner mal getestet hat.
Verlenken war halt alles.
Also User Interface ist was anderes, muss ich sagen. Also das ist das, was mich am Anfang wirklich schon sehr bedenklich gestimmt hat bei dem Open MoCo Projekt, dass da einfach viele, viele Wege gegangen wurden von Anfang an, wo ich mir sicher war, das ist der totale Holzweg. Eigentlich haben sie auch die ganze Software, mit der sie gestartet haben, komplett weggeschmissen und jetzt sind sie irgendwie bei Version 2 oder 3. Also am Anfang ging das halt los mit, es gibt halt Software, die soll mit dem Finger benutzt werden und Software, die für den Stylus ist. Dann kamen halt so mega komplexe User Interfaces hoch auf diesem kleinen Bildschirm mit scrollbar.
So unglaublich, ja.
Wie auf dem, denkst du, war alles basiert auf GTK. Davon haben sie halt viel weggeworfen, neu geschrieben und so weiter. Und jetzt ist der neueste Hype der, dass sie halt auch auf Qt gehen. Was an sich eine gute Idee ist, wie ich finde. Qt, also Trolltech, die Basis von KDE, die ja auch mit Qtopia speziell für Telefone...
Ist das mittlerweile auch frei?
Ja, ja, das ist mittlerweile das GPL. Und das, was soll ich sagen? Na ja, Qtopia ist deren Projekt für Handy-Software, wo sie eben auch Applications und so weiter bereitstellen und eben so ein User-Interface dafür machen. Das läuft wohl mittlerweile auch auf dem Open Boko, ist aber auch unbenutzbar. Was auch daran liegt, dass dieses freerunner Teil halt nicht so einen schönen Touchscreen hat, wie das iPhone zum Beispiel, sondern halt noch so eine drucksensitive Oberfläche und eben nicht jetzt so mit, nicht auf dem Finger realisiert.
Also, so toll wie ich das ja prinzipiell finde, dass da jemand ein wirklich Open Source-Telefon baut, was ja eine grandiose Idee ist eigentlich, wenn es funktioniert, aber das mit dem iPhone zu vergleichen, ist wie ein Mercedes zu vergleichen, mit einem selbstgebauten Bastelkit-Auto. Das ist eine schöne Sache für Hobbyisten. Aber wenn ich ein Telefon haben will, was funktioniert, dann...
Es kann auf jeden Fall nicht mithalten. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe auch echte Zweifel, dass sie jemals mithalten... Es kann OX abspielen, aber drauf geschissen...
Hast du auch MP3s?
OX benutzt niemand.
Es kann nur OX abspielen.
Das ist einfach die Wahrheit. OX benutzt niemand. Ich hab mir irgendwann mal... Mit Teore ist es noch schlimmer. Ich hab einfach mal auf dem Internet, das ist jetzt schon ein Jahr her, dachte mir so, okay, alles klar, Teora, teste ich doch mal ein bisschen. Ich hab Stunden verbracht von dem Internet in der Suchmaschine, um nach Teora-Content zu suchen. Und außer ein paar Sample-Movies habe ich eigentlich nichts gefunden.
Aber diese MKV-Datei, das ist doch Teora oder ein Matroska-Ding?
Nee, das ist Matroska, das ist nochmal was anderes.
Also, du nicht ständig auch die ganzen Chaos-Radio-Express-Sendungen machst du hier auch nicht in tausenden von Formaten, unter anderem auch so diversen Freien?
Nee, mach ich nicht. Ich mach das in MP3. Da hab ich mir auch schon diverse Kriege geleistet, mit meinen Hörern im Blog. Da steh ich auch nach wie vor dazu. Es gibt da einen Beitrag, wo ich ja, es heißt Chaos-Radio-Daten-Formate, wenn das interessiert, oder Medien-Formate, wenn das interessiert, kannste gerne mal die Diskussion danach lesen. Da hab ich auch nochmal ganz klar gesagt, warum ich das mache. Ich meine, vor allem ist es einfach eine Frage des Aufwandes. Und ich halte auch, wie das eben auch in der Industrie jeder tut, den Nutzen dagegen. Und meine Kerntese ist einfach, mit MP3 erreiche ich alle. Ja, es gibt nichts außer vielleicht diesen Frihrerner, was kein MP3 abspielen kann. Das ist jetzt glaube ich das erste Gerät, was ich kenne, was kein MP3 abspielen kann.
Das ist der Hightlix-Neuer Gerät. Ich hatte auch schon Mobiltelefonik keine MP3 abspielen konnten.
Ja, aber die konnten dann auch nichts anderes abspielen. Also wenn irgendein Gerät sich als Medienplayer bezeichnet, dann kann es MP3 abspielen. Das ist halt einfach so. Und im Videobereich ist es genauso. Großes Problem ist eben auch, und auch technisch ein echtes Hauptgrund, warum kein Telefon Ock, Vorbis und Teora macht, es gibt es einfach nicht. In Hardware, in gängigen Chips, die die Leute auch tatsächlich in ihre Telefone einbauen. Weil Apple macht das nicht mit Software, das abspielen, sondern das machen die in Hardware.
Wobei, man muss auch ein bisschen, das ist auch ein Henne-Eye-Problem. Wenn es mehr Angebote geben würde, würde es vielleicht auch von einigen dann genutzt werden.
Aber wo ist der Vorteil? Das Ding ist, das Problem ist auch bei Vorbis, im Vergleich zu MPEG-4, ich vergleiche es gar nicht mal mit MPEG-3, weil das ist irgendwie alt, MPEG-4, Audio, hat einfach viele Features. Gerade auf dem iPod mit Chaptermarks und solchen Sachen, das sind einfach so Dinge, die sind bei Vorbis einfach nicht gelöst. Und es geht da eben auch in der Entwicklung nicht wirklich weiter. Ock ist ein sehr alter Container, der auch in der Szene nicht gerade aktiv vorangetrieben wird. Da gibt es diverse Spaltungen, es gibt Ock, dann gibt es OGM. Und im Videobereich haben sie mittlerweile eingesehen, dass Ock eben nicht genug Features hat, um Filme wirklich korrekt zu containen, also als Container-Format. Also Ock ist das Container-Format, Vorbis ist ja der Codec und Tehora ist der Video-Codec. Und da setzt sich halt jetzt Matroska durch. Ich weiß nicht genau, ne, Matroska sind diese Puppen, die ja sich containen. Puppe in Puppe in Puppe. Und das war glaube ich so das Bild, was sie genommen haben als Container-Format für eben Media-Codecs, für Spuren. Und Matroska, da gibt es auch in der Wikipedia eine schöne Übersichtsseite, irgendwie Comparison of Media-Container-Formats. Und Matroska ist das einzige Format, was jetzt Feature gleich ist mit QuickTime.
Das können wir jetzt mal üben. Ich hab ja ein paar Jahre in der Nähe von Moskau gewohnt. Matryoshka heißt das.
Hier unser Quoten Sony weiß es wieder besser. Du bist aus dem Osten, das heißt du hast in der Nähe von Moskau gewohnt.
Ich hab ja in der Nähe von Moskau gewohnt.
Sag es nochmal.
Matryoshka.
Okay, also Matryoshka ist an sich ganz okay. Also Matryoshka kann ordentlich content sein.
Das ist jetzt schon der Übergang, weil wir kommen jetzt gerade vom iPhone weg. Jetzt haben wir ja ein bisschen Audioformate gemacht, weil wir sollen ja nicht so viel über das iPhone quatschen, weil es ja gerade nichts was zu tun ist.
Wir sind jetzt bei diesem Open-Moco. Bevor ich jetzt wieder zugeflamet bin, sag ich nochmal ganz klar, mir geht es da einfach um eine ausgewogene Diskussion, die nicht so religiös überbelastet ist, weil das ist wirklich das echt Schwierige an der ganzen Geschichte, wenn man da diskutiert. Es ist immer so dieses, man muss Vorbis oder Theora benutzen, weil es halt ein paar Leute gibt, die der Meinung sind, das wäre jetzt die Verpflichtung. Das kann ich aber leider weder aus den Features, noch aus den Bedingungen ableiten. Weder gibt es gute Tools dafür. Es gibt zwar ein halbwegs brauchbares Plagen, um das jetzt auf den Mac zum Beispiel ins QuickTime reinzuwerfen. Ich kann das irgendwie aufmachen, exportieren, alles super. Geht aber auch mit Matroska mittlerweile. Nur, wo sind die Vorteile? Where is the beef? Und ich kann vor allem viele Sachen damit nicht machen. Und deswegen ist es jetzt als Podcast-Format Quatsch. Ja, haben wir das? Okay, gut. We got it. Aber ich werde trotzdem in Grund und Boden geplantet werden. Natürlich. Soll ich anfangen?
Blogpost ist doof. Da fällt nichts dazu ein. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass der nur darum entstanden ist, auf diesen Hype ein bisschen aufzustreigen. Das ist ein bisschen anders.
Egal, weiter skippen wir jetzt.
Skippen wir. Also, iPhone haben wir durch, App Store haben wir durch. Kommen wir auf das nächste Disaster, was sich Apple geleistet hat, was auch immer noch ongoing ist.
Zu dem kannst du ein bisschen was erzählen, oder?
Ja, es geht so. Also ich hatte leider nicht sehr viel Zeit. Ich habe ja auch so einen.mac-Account gehabt. Erstmal hat es ewig gedauert bis...
Mobile Me sind wir übrigens jetzt.
Ja genau, Mobile Me ist das Thema. Der Push, Tralala, was auch immer dient. Das war ein einziges Elend. Erstmal haben alle Leute herausgefunden, dass der Push-Dienst so keiner ist. Zumindest nicht so wie er beworben wurde. Zumindest nicht auf dem Mac. Genau, er pusht auf den Devices, aber er pusht nicht auf dem Mac, was ich so recht nicht verstehe. Da gibt es halt das Syncing-Framework und das hat einfach eine fest eingestellte Zeit, so der es irgendwie synkt, wenn man nicht manuell sagt, jetzt synkt mal. Und mit diesem Synken ist halt auch das Weiterreichen von Kalendereinträgen und so weiter verbunden. Nachvollziehbar. Ich persönlich muss auch sagen, ich hätte jetzt mit so 15 Minuten, das ist für mich kein kritischer Bereich.
Ja, wobei, wenn man in Demos großartig ankönnt, die haben Push, Push, Push und das ist Push for everybody und ihnen zeigen sie, wie das innerhalb von Sekunden ist.
Klar, das haben sie ja auch geändert. So, allerdings im Business-Bereich, so jetzt Exchange, wo du wirklich Außendienstmitarbeiter hast, die du dynamisch durch die Gegend schickst, dann willst du halt auch diese 15 Minuten, die unter Umständen schon für die Anfahrt gebraucht werden, nicht verlieren.
Wobei dann hast du, bei Exchange geht's ja glaube ich auch.
Wenn du so ein Kurierdienst auf Basis von sowas, da ist also 15 Minuten Gold wert. Also von daher muss man schon sagen, wenn sie mit Push werben, sollten sie es auch tun.
Aber ich glaube, das machen sie jetzt auch. Aber wie gesagt, bei Exchange funktioniert es auch, oder? Es ist nur Mobile-Memos nicht.
Das Problem ist grundsätzlich Mobile-Memos. Ich meine, die Server waren dann ewig down. Dann waren sie wieder ab, dann waren sie wieder down, dann waren sie wieder ab, dann waren sie wieder down. Diese Software, dieses Update für den Mac, was noch hinterhergeschmissen wurde, was die Preference-Pane aktualisiert und dann noch so ein bisschen paar Libraries, das Syncing-Framework und auch Mail-Up aktualisiert, weil wir ja auch diese ganzen Auto-Configuration-Schnittgister drin haben und so. Das kam halt irgendwie auch erstmal nicht an. Das hat also einfach Tage gedauert, bis sie diese Software-Distribution überhaupt im Griff hatten, was man ja nicht so kennt für Software-Update.
Warte mal, du hast ein neues Mail-Programm, weil du Mobile-Me hast und der Rest nicht?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wer alles dieses Mobile-Me-Update bekommen hat.
Also bei mir ist das gekommen mit...
Haben die normalen Users das auch gekriegt?
Ich hab das, als ich irgendwann mal auf.mec in den Systemeinstellungen geklickt hatte, mir gesagt, es gibt was Neues.
Genau. Über diese Preference-Pain wird das nämlich ausgelöst. Bei manchen Leuten soll es ungeblich auch im Software-Update aufgetaucht sein. Das war auf jeden Fall eine totale Konfusion.
Wo es auf jeden Fall jetzt überall jedem untergeschoben worden ist, ist es unter Windows. Weil die sind ja ein bisschen stinkig, weil ihnen mit Safari das untergeschoben wird.
Wobei Mobile-Me hat sich jetzt keiner beschwert. Dass denen das jetzt auch untergeschoben wurde.
Das wäre jetzt auf Mac. Das ist gerade ongoing, die Diskussion. Ja, das ist halt so eine Sache. Wir haben ja neulich schon eins auf die Nase bekommen, als sie Safari automatisch so angeboten haben. Es wurde nicht automatisch installiert, sondern es wurde nur bei Default angezeigt.
Und wenn du sagst, na ja, und es wurde als Software-Update für deine bisherige Software angezeigt.
Genau, aber jetzt ist es ja noch haariger. Jetzt ist es so, du sagst, hier ist dein iTunes 7.7 für XP und Vista. Und wenn du das installierst, kriegst du die Mobile-Mac-Preference-Pane einfach dazu. Mit dem iTunes.
Ach so, automatisch.
Ja, das ist noch nicht mal so, dass sie anzeigen, hier jetzt auch Mobile-Mac-Preference-Pane, sondern mit dem iTunes ist das sozusagen...
Und auch da muss man sagen, in das System einzugreifen, ohne Feuer anzugucken.
Jetzt sind sie evil. Das ist ein bisschen evil.
Nee, ist nicht so schlimm.
Na, es ist ein Bezahl-Dienst. Das ist nicht freie, Entschuldigung, kostenlose Software.
Ja, das ist ein großer Unterschied.
Sondern sie installieren sozusagen schonmal die Software, die du nur brauchst, um einen Dienst in Anspruch zu nehmen, der Geld kostet.
Und den 90% der iTunes-Anländer auch gar nicht brauchen.
Das ist wie mit so irgendwie Kreditkarte oder Click-and-Buy, wenn ich eigentlich App-Store-Sachen runterladen will, die nichts kosten.
Naja, noch mal ein bisschen andere. Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also ich find's extrem problematisch. Jetzt kann man nicht auf Windows wechseln, weil da passiert's ja. Aber ich find's haarig, wenn irgendjemand mir ein System eingreift, bloß weil ich ein kleines Software-Programm aktualisieren will.
Auf jeden Fall Mobile Me ist ganz schön creepy und auch im IT, also im Enterprise-Bereich, ganz schön umstritten, weil natürlich auch so Sachen drin sind. Was auch schon für.Mac galt, im Übrigen, nicht nur für Mobile Me. Es ist mir jetzt auch erst klar geworden, nachdem ich mal angefangen habe, das zu benutzen. Das ist auch ein Dienst, den ich sehr gerne mag. Das ist dieses Back to my Mac. Kennt ihr das eigentlich? Ist euch eigentlich klar, was das macht? Also wenn ich in.Mac respektive jetzt Mobile Me Account habe und dann trage ich den ein, so, dann bin ich ja irgendwie so... Dann verkaufe ich ja meine Seele an Apple. Ich hab zwar noch ein paar Checkboxen, wo ich sagen kann, was nicht mit übertragen wird, aber die Seele ist definitiv schon mal auf dem Server.
Wird das bei denen verschlüsselt drüber geschoben? Das würde ja gehen eigentlich, machen die nicht.
Was jetzt?
Dass es lokal verschlüsselt wird, dort bei Apple gespeichert wird auf deren Mobile-Me-Servern und du es verschlüsselt wieder bekommst.
Was meinst du mit S jetzt genau?
Na die Daten, die auch immer darüber geschickt werden, keine Ahnung.
Ich kann dir das jetzt im Einzelnen...
Weil das könnte ja funktionieren.
Na ja, also Syncing heißt immer, dass das eine mit dem anderen verglichen wird. Und wenn es komplett verschlüsselt ist, dann können sie es nicht vergleichen. Das könnten sie nur machen, wenn eine End-zu-End-Verbindung hergestellt wird. Zum Beispiel zwischen meinem Mac und dem iPhone, in dem Moment, wo gesündet wird. Und das ist ja nicht der Fall. Sondern du änderst was auf deinem iPhone, dann kannst du dein Gerät ausschalten, dann liegt diese Information vor. Und wenn das nächste Mal der Macintosh vorbeikommt und sagt, ich synke mal, synkt er. Und Synken heißt, er muss Klartext vergleichen. Also kann das nicht verschlüsselt sein. Das ist generell datensensitiv. Und ich muss auch sagen, Kontakte und solche Sachen also das synke ich nicht.
Schiebst du dann aber darüber? Kontakte nicht?
Wofür ich das derzeit benutze, fragst du mich?
Deine Mails aber oder wie?
Nee, also me.com ist ja nochmal ein anderes Problem. Also das benutze ich eigentlich nicht, benutze nach wie vor meine Sachen. Nein, ich hab eigentlich das größte, also was ich nicht ganz so schlimm finde, sind Kalender, das synke ich. Dann kannst du auch so deine Dashboard-Widgets synken zwischen deinen Rechnern. Das heißt, du hast immer dasselbe Dashboard überall. Ist sicherlich jetzt nichts, wofür man 99 Dollar kaufen will, aber das ist so. Und so meine Mail-Account-Konfiguration. Bookmarks auch? Bookmarks derzeit nicht, nee. Kann ich aber nur einschalten, das ist nicht so das Problem.
Achso, aber es geht.
Wobei, Mail-Accounts fällt mir an, das ist ja auch ganz evil, weil im Prinzip auch wieder die Passwörter übertragen sind. Ja, genau, so kannst du genauso gut reden. Ja, Nodes hab ich noch gemacht, benutze ich derzeit noch nicht so richtig.
Max, jetzt ist dein Zeitpunkt, weil nämlich für Firefox gibt es nämlich so einen Plug-In, der kann irgendwie auch so Kalenderevents verschlüsselt irgendwie auf dem Server ablegen und verschlüsselt wiederum, das heißt wie bei, hatten die da von Google Kalenderevents geredet? Weiß ich gar nicht, jedenfalls kann der, der die Sachen dann speichert, das gar nicht auspacken, weil es verschlüsselt ist und alle Teilnehmer des Kalenders, mit denen du da Meetings machst und so weiter, müssen dann halt deinen Key haben, um dann das auch auspacken zu können. Also da gibt es auf jeden Fall so Plugins, die einem das einfach machen, dass es halt verschlüsselt bleibt.
Also was es da gibt und was offensichtlich relativ gut verschlüsselt ist, ist sowas Neues, das heißt VEAVE, ich weiß nicht wie es ausgesprochen wird, V-E-A-V-E, ist zur Zeit in der Version 02, die noch exorbitant instabil ist. Und das ist sowas, dass Firefox eben auch alle offenen Tabs und alle Bookmarks und alle Daten synchronisiert mit dem Netz und dass die dann andere Services abfragen können.
Wo ist das denn gespeichert?
Das ist gespeichert bei Mozilla und ich glaube, das ist komplett verschlüsselt, nach dem was ich bisher verstanden habe.
Weil sozusagen, weil es eigentlich nur ein File Storage ist? Genau, du kriegst einen Check-Datei quasi. Das wäre eigentlich auch für iSync, blödsinn, für Mobile-Media, das müsste eigentlich auch so funktionieren. Das Problem ist, man weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert. Deswegen ist es schon mal generell ein bisschen evil. So, wofür ich es wirklich benutze? Ich benutze die iDisc. Insbesondere mit diesem Syncing-Feature ist das eigentlich extrem cool. Weil ich habe hier einfach einen Ordner, der immer lokal gemirroert ist. Also auch wenn ich kein Internet habe, ich habe die Contents. Wenn ich aber Internet habe, wird es eben auch automatisch gesynced. Und ich kann anderen Leuten ein Passwort geben, sodass sie auch auf diesen Public-Bereich meiner iDisc zugreifen können. Das heißt, Dokumente, die ich mit anderen Leuten share.
Es gibt ja auch manche Developer, die das benutzen. Das sieht man ja immer.
Ja, das ist wirklich praktisch, weil ich halt so 2-3 Dokumente habe, wo jetzt noch ein paar andere Leute mitarbeiten. Und die haben halt einfach das Passwort. Man kann leider nicht verschiedene Bereiche einrichten mit verschiedenen Passworten für verschiedene Leute usw. Das ist alles noch so ein bisschen haarig.
Also es könnte besser sein.
Aber iDisc Syncing ist für mich auf jeden Fall praktisch. Und dann halt Back to my Mac. Und was das ist, das habe ich am Anfang auch nicht begriffen. Da geht es im Prinzip um den Zugriff auf deinen Rechner über Screensharing, File Sharing usw. Und das funktioniert so, dass jeder Rechner, wo du deinen Mobile-Me-Account in das Preference-Pane eingetragen hast und wo du dann noch sagst, Back to my Mac on Button anzuholen. Registriert sich der Rechner über Wide Area Bonjour, wie Apple das so schön nennt. Also quasi sowas wie dünn DNS-Org plus auf offizieller DNS-Standards-Basis. Ist das? Muss man nochmal genauer erforschen. Wie auch immer. Also er registriert unter... Gott, was war denn die Domain? Zeigt auch glaube ich irgendwo an. Hätte ich jetzt vergessen. Irgendwas mit bla. Den Rechner. Effekt ist jetzt folgender. Wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Laptop irgendwie unterwegs bin und ich habe meinen Mac Mini zum Beispiel hier so eingetragen, ich klappe einfach auf und wenn der Mac Mini online ist und sich da eben registriert und sagt, ich bin online, dann taucht der bei mir auf, als wäre das so ein Bonjour-Rechner. Das heißt, ich habe den einfach in meinem Sharing gesagt, ah dein Rechner läuft, dann klicke ich da drauf, sag Screensharing, dann macht er über Kerberos eine Authentifizierung und macht eine verschlüsselte Session zu meinem Rechner nach Hause. Also das ist definitiv so. Und kann den dann einfach genauso benutzen, wie hier im lokalen Netz. Natürlich langsamer, aber das funktioniert. Genau, weil da ist halt so alles mit drin. Das ist Kerberos-Server und so weiter. Und diese DNS-Registrierung, das steckt da halt alles mit drin in dem Paket. Und klar, jetzt kommen wir wieder, alles evil und so weiter. Es ist aber ein saugeiles Feature, weil ich einfach mal dieses Problem mit Screensharing-Zugriff auf Rechner zu Hause oder Falschsharing-Zugriff auf Rechner zu Hause im Prinzip ist das auch noch offen für weitere Dienste. Das ist immer so eine Sache. Man muss an den Routern und die Ports vorworten. Ihr kennt diesen ganzen Elend so und dann registriert sich das nicht richtig. Und dann DynDNS, was weiß ich, hast du deinen DynDNS nicht mehr, seit 30 Tagen nicht mehr aktualisiert. Dann wirft DynDNS dann irgendwie deinen Account weg. Und diesen ganzen Kack hast du einfach nicht mehr, sondern du sagst halt einfach nur, hier, das ist einer von meinen fünf Computern. Und dann sehe ich von allen Rechnern alle anderen.
Also erstens, ich glaube, da gibt es auch, dass man das irgendwie hinkriegen kann ohne MobileMedia. Da gibt es einen Hack oder irgendwie so. Da gibt es Leute, die sich darum kümmern.
Das finde ich wirklich spannend.
Weil dieses Wide Area-Bonjour gibt es ja für Leute, die es interessiert. Da gibt es ein Preferences-Payn zum Runterladen. Das heißt Wide Area-Bonjour.
Genau, das habe ich auch mal versucht zum Laufen zu kriegen, aber ich habe nicht richtig verstanden, was man da so anfahren muss.
Ich auch nicht, aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall dieses Tool. Das kann man sich mal besorgen und dann damit rumspielen. Und dann gab es doch irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen den Bericht, dass jemandem wurde der Rechner geklaut und der hat über Back to my Mac den wohl wiedergefunden.
Klar, weil der hat ihn halt einfach aufgeklappt. Der hat sich gleich im Internet registriert. Hallo hier. Und dann sieht er auf seinem anderen Computer, hat er den halt gesehen, Screen Shaving gemacht, eine Kamera angeworfen und den Typen fotografiert.
Er hat ihm aber glaube ich nichts genutzt. Nee, also vielleicht war es auch eine Angeschichte, aber der Police Officer konnte wohl noch verstehen, was eine E-Mail-Adresse ist, aber was eine IP-Adresse ist und so hat er nicht verstanden und deswegen ging es nicht.
Aber wäre da jemand von der Musikindustrie gekommen, dann hätte er es bestimmt verstanden.
Verdammt, aber der kommt ja auch im Nadelstreifenanzug.
Aber ganz kurz mal zu diesem, bevor ich es vergesse, zu diesem iDisc, da gibt es eine schöne Alternative, Dropbox heißt das, das läuft für, geht auf dem Mac und auf unter Windows und da kriegt man glaube ich Invitations relativ einfach mittlerweile. Das ist komplett kostenlos, zwei Gigabyte hat man da glaube ich und ist eine ganz ähnliche Funktion, wie du gerade beschreibst. Also man hat einen neuen Ordner, das ist in dem Fall keine Festplatte, sondern eben einen neuen Ordner, kann auf diesen Ordner beliebig...
Aber du meinst jetzt nicht Back to my Mac, sondern das iDisc was?
Genau, dieses iDisc Feature. Und kann da schöne Dateien draufspeichern, die werden dann transparent im Hintergrund hochgeladen. Man kann einzelne Ordner mit verschiedenen Leuten sharen, die dann auch Accounts haben, also man braucht das nicht mit allen zu machen. Also wir haben das zum Beispiel, wir haben so ein paar Dokumente, also ein paar Dokumente teile ich mit Freunden. Man kann Public-Ordner definieren, auf die man dann, also du nimmst einen Ordner mit Bildern, spielst den hoch, wartest bis er oben synchronisiert ist, dann klickst du mit der rechten Maustaste drauf, sagst Copy Link dazu. Und dann kannst du den Link in eine Mail packen und kannst den Leuten deine Fotos zeigen. Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr hübsche... Dropbox, getdropbox.com getdropbox.com, das macht echt Laune. Das ist mit Flash-Interface, ne? Das ist kein Flash-Interface, es gibt ein Web-Interface und es gibt eine relativ hübsche, native Lösung dafür. Man hat so ein kleines Menü oben in der Menüleiste.
Ich hab's nicht ganz verstanden. Heißt das, ich kann meinen Disk auf dem Desktop mounten und über Netzwerke-Produkte zugreifen?
Nein, es ist ein Ordner. Alles, was du in den Ordner hochspielst, wird bei denen zwischengelagert auf dem Server und alle Leute, die darauf Zugriff haben, den du vorher drauf Zugriff gegeben hast, bei denen wird das dann automatisch synchronisiert.
Okay, also nur ein Programm, was auf meinem Rechner läuft, was diesen Ordner immer in Sync hält.
Genau, das ist dann quasi so wie eine Festplatte. Ja, hübsch gemacht.
Okay, werde ich mal ausprobieren.
Wir brauchen keinen MobileMe für kaufen.
Bei der iDisk war ja auch ein neues Fallsharing-Feature versprochen worden bei MobileMe, aber das haben sie wohl wieder ausgeschaltet. Das kommt dann wohl später. Hoffe ich zumindest. Das wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Welches neues Feature? Na ja, um ehrlich zu sein, ich hab das mit einem Auge wahrgenommen und hab mir dann gesagt, das gucke ich mir dann an, wenn es kommt.
Du weißt nicht, auf welches Feature das geht?
Doch, es soll halt online die Möglichkeit geben, es besser zu verwalten, aber das ist wohl so noch nicht implementiert worden. Aber ich hab jetzt nicht so viel drüber gewesen, dass ich jetzt schon sagen würde, wie es eigentlich funktionieren sollte, weil ich mir dachte, das gucke ich mir dann diese Woche an, aber das Feature ist noch nicht da. Vielleicht auch nicht. Was ein bisschen enttäuschend ist, das war auch eine der Hörerfragen, die wir hier noch ausführlich behandeln möchten. Abonnierte Kalender, also wenn ich in meinem iCal einen Kalender subscribe, wird der nicht gesüngt. Was natürlich ein bisschen blöd ist, weil das natürlich schon so eine Quelle ist, ich hab halt, was weiß ich, Events von, hm, ich hab eine Menge Kalender subscribt, aber die sind halt nicht im Sync drin. Es war auch so die Frage, wie kann man das machen? Man kann sich natürlich das Syncing sozusagen selber machen, indem man da einfach einen Skript hat, was regelmäßig diese ICS-Datei direkt in Library, Kalenders, was weiß ich, wo iCal das alles ablegt, immer wieder reinballert. Dann ist das für iCal ein lokaler Kalender. Und dann wird es halt auch gesyncht, aber an sich ist halt Subscription irgendwie nicht mit drin. Was das soll, weiß ich nicht. Man könnte argumentieren, naja, dann wird es bei dem einen regelmäßig aktualisiert, aber das ist ja eigentlich egal, ob es aus dem Web aktualisiert wird oder ob ich da selber was dran ändere. Er könnte es ja einfach synken. Ich schätze mal, das werden sie noch nachreichen, weil das macht eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Das, was ich ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, das taucht auch in den Kommentaren auf. Und das sage ich, dass man jetzt zwar wunderbar alles mit, also um nochmal ganz kurz auf das Thema iPhone zurückzukommen, muss ich in dem Zusammenhang erwähnen, dass man alles wunderbar mit Exchange synchronisieren kann, aber dass es mit diesem neuen Calda-Format, was mit Leopard Server noch so unglaublich beworben wurde, dass das damit alles überhaupt nicht zusammenarbeitet. Das iPhone funktioniert, arbeitet nicht super mit Leopard Server zusammen. Was soll das denn?
Hast du das ausprobiert oder hast du da Berichte gelesen?
Ich hab was dazu gelesen, dass es wohl noch nicht geht, schlicht und ergreifend.
Was soll denn da genau gehen?
Na ich meine, es wäre doch großartig, wenn ich Overseer meinen Kalender synchronisieren könnte mit CalDAF.
Ja?
Dass ich auf meinem iPhone meinen Kalender habe, den ich mit CalDAF auf meinem Mac fliege.
Achso, du meinst, der Kalender auf dem iPhone macht noch keinen CalDAF.
Genau.
Aber das iCal auf dem Mac tut das wohl.
Das iCal auf dem Mac tut das wohl.
Okay, alles klar. Das kommt dann wahrscheinlich, wenn Schnee-Leo rauskommt, gibt es dann das entsprechende Update auf dem Telefon.
Also ich bin mal, also das ist so ein bisschen, sie schannt sich da ein bisschen zu sehr auf den Enterprise-Markt. Konzentriert hab ich im Augenblick das Gefühl und haben so diesen eigenen Standard, den sie da noch in der Hinterheit haben, ein bisschen vergessen.
Und sie haben ja das Problem, in dem Moment, wo sie ihren eigenen Dienst machen, verkrüppeln sie halt andere Sachen, die besser funktionieren sein könnten, um ihren eigenen Geschäft keine Konkurrenz zu machen.
Aber im September muss ja noch ein größeres iPhone-Update kommen, weil dann kommt ja auch für Developer der Background-Application-Supporter dieser Datenproxy. Kannst du dafür nochmal an die Software ranmüssen?
Der Teil könnte doch stehen, dass einfach bloß die Infrastruktur noch nicht geschaffen haben.
Das hätten wir schon gelesen, das hätten die gesehen in den Frameworks, dass das schon dabei ist.
Also ich bin mir da noch nicht sicher. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob deswegen ein neuer Software-Update kommt.
Ich glaub schon. Und vorher sowieso, weil 201 und so weiter.
201 wäre natürlich mal angesagt, ja.
So, jetzt wieder iPhone weg, wollen wir nicht so viel machen, ne?
Ja. Ja, dann, was ist noch passiert? Also mir fällt jetzt noch, wo wir jetzt eh nochmal iPhone, la la la, Skyhook haben wir ja schon angesprochen. Da gibt es demnächst eine Verbesserung. Skyhook hat angekündigt, dass sie ihren ganzen Dienst nochmal verbessern wollen, insbesondere...
Muss man nochmal kurz sagen, was Skyhook ist?
Skyhook ist der Dienst, der Lokalisierung ermöglicht auf Basis von WLAN-Scanning. Da ja auch diese Google-Cars irgendwie rumfahren, haben wir letztes Mal schon erwähnt. Und wie das alles einsammeln, sind das wohl relativ solide Daten auch und die aktualisieren das auch am laufenden Meter. Und das klappt ja an sich auch schon mal ganz gut. Aber was sie jetzt noch machen, ist, dass sie das eben auch mit GPS kombinieren. Sodass ein Telefon, wie zum Beispiel das iPhone, was sowohl GPS hat, als auch dieses WLAN-Scanning, also dieses Backend Skyhook, sich so viel Daten herausholen kann aus diesem Skyhook-Service auf Basis der gescannten WLANs, dass es auch die Information von GPS-Satelliten mitnutzen kann, auch wenn es nicht genug Satelliten sind für einen korrekten GPS-Fix. Also man muss ja schon so vier, fünf Satelliten sehen, bis man was macht. Aber wenn man nur einen oder zwei sieht, dann ist das sozusagen für das Skyhook wie ein weiteres WLAN-Netz.
Da gibt es bei TomTom auch sowas. Quick-Fix-Dateien bei TomTom, die irgendwie eine Woche lang halten oder so, wo sie irgendwie schon die Satelliten beschreiben.
Das ist aber eher das, was AGPS macht. Also Assisted GPS kannst du halt direkt runterladen für diese Zone, die aktuelle Konfiguration, quasi gestützt durch deine Cell-Information. Und dann kannst du halt schneller Fix machen. Und beim TomTom dürfte das wahrscheinlich so eine Art, ich schätze mal jetzt, weil die ja offline sind, so eine Art Vorberechnung der zu erwartenden Konstellationen in deinem Bereich.
Das sind nur so ein paar Hundert Kilobyte, also das ist echt nicht viel.
Man muss da nicht so viel wissen.
Aber taucht das nicht auch auf? Also der Dienst, über den das, also die Frage, welcher Dienst ist das denn überhaupt, weil er dazu nichts lesen konnte, ist besagt das Skyhawk Wireless, mit dem diese WLAN-Positionierung funktioniert, die übrigens auch wohl sehr gut im Emulator funktionieren soll, würde ich mir sagen lassen. Also ich kenne jemand, der mit der AP mal rumgespielt hat. Ach. Und...
In dem iPhone-Simulator?
In dem iPhone-Simulator funktioniert natürlich dann eben nur wie beim iPod Touch über die WLAN-Lokalisierung. Aber es funktioniert wohl. Da gibt es keine Maps-Applikation. Du müsstest jetzt erstmal ein Programm dafür schreiben.
Ach so, in dem Moment, wo man Lokalisierung benutzt, ist das natürlich da. Und dann benutzt er tatsächlich die WLAN-Daten von meinem Laptop.
Da gibt es ja das Locate Me Framework, wenn man für das iPhone programmiert.
Das war ein ziemlich erschreckender Moment, als man bei seinem MacBook rechnet man hier nicht damit. Mal ausprobieren, mal gucken, wo man mich positioniert. Mit anderen Worten, es funktioniert definitiv auch auf dem Mac eigentlich.
Was ich mich wundere, ist, warum die mit Apple und SkyQuile, warum die nicht so einen Deal gemacht haben, oder vielleicht haben sie den sogar gemacht, dass jetzt, wo die iPhones alle GPS haben, könnten sie auch, da sie ja die exakte Position haben, dann gleich an Skyhawk Wireless melden, welche Basis-Stationen sie gerade alle sehen, und die hätten bei Skyhawk Wireless in 0, nichts.
Ob sie das tun, ist unklar.
Das wäre ja immer voll der Deal.
Ja, da hätte ja auch die FSF gleich wieder richtig recht. Sagt es auch noch, was für WLANs du dich rumtreibst.
Wir hatten ja schon in einer früheren Sendung drüber geredet, dass ich da auch schon im Club mit ein paar Jungs, dass wir dieses Skull-Guy-Less-Protokoll ein bisschen aufgehakt haben, um mal ein bisschen genauer reinzugucken. Ich glaube, wir müssen das mal nochmal machen.
Was ich ja wirklich furchtbar finde an diesem FSF-Ding, warum ich mich eigentlich so aufgeregt habe, warum ich mich eigentlich so aufgeregt habe, das ist diese, dieser gnadenlose Schwarz-Weiß-Blick. Also es gibt nur so dieses entweder es ist frei bis zum Erbrechen oder es ist scheiße. Du sollst lieber etwas Minderwertigeres kaufen und das benutzen und dich auf Jahre hinter allen anderen befinden, anstatt das zu nehmen, was cool ist. Und meine, die ganzen Ups, die jetzt so reinträufeln, heute hab ich wieder so gesehen, so ein Art-Framework, was kommt irgendwie, was super geil ist, erhält sein iPhone mit der Kamera irgendwo hin und dann macht er so Live-Tracking, mit VR-Objekte und so weiter, mit 3D und so. Ja, so Augmented Reality-Plattform sozusagen. Das ist einfach Hack-Value. Also wir werden, meine Prognose von Tag 1, so coole Sachen sehen jetzt auf dem iPhone und das ist einfach das, wo Hacker sich rumtreiben müssen.
Das ist, ja, also es ist, jetzt krieg ich bestimmt was schön auf den Deckel, das muss man sagen, was zumindest was die Usability angeht, aber auch sonst viele innovative Sachen sind. Open-Source-Software aus Gründen, die mir mittlerweile gar nicht mehr so verständlich sind, gerne nachzügler und nicht vorne weggehe. Also es mag im Server-Bereich, mag es da Ausnahmen geben, aber was die User-Interfaces angeht, da geht Apple vorne weg und dann rennen die anderen hinterher. Und da wären nicht wirklich die großen neuen Standards gesetzt im Open-Source-Bereich. Und es ist beim iPhone wird das kein bisschen anders sein. Da wird der Freerunner jetzt eine Weile dahinter herrennen und irgendwann wird sicherlich ein schönes Open-Source-Telefon geben, aber bis dahin sehen wir noch eine Menge Wasser, die spräherunter fließen.
Tja, wie siehst du denn das, Dennis? Damit du auch gleich, dass du auch ein paar Flames kriegst.
Genau, damit wir nicht die Einzigen sind.
Ich halte mich da raus.
Feige Sau.
Nee, ich glaube nicht an Open-Source- und gute User-Interfaces.
Du glaubst nicht an Open-Source- und gute User-Interfaces? Also das, da kann ich jetzt sogar dagegen anhaken.
Ja, das sehe ich aber ähnlich. Und zwar einfach empirisch. Ich lasse mich da gerne mal vom Gegenteil überzeugen, aber bisher ist diese Mentalität einfach noch nicht beim User angekommen. Das hat auch was mit der Motivation zu tun. Weil Leute, die Open-Source-Software machen, oder sagen wir mal jetzt Free-Software, weil wir eigentlich in dem Bereich her sind, sind so getragen von einerseits diesem Freiheitsaspekt, aber andererseits auch von diesem Wunsch, Total Control zu haben und alle möglichen Optionen zu haben und alle möglichen Features zu haben, dass sich natürlich das auch in die Benutzung der Software mit reinschleicht. Und alle möglichen Features zu haben, ist einfach das Gegenteil von guten User Interfaces. Das ist der Mut, guter User Interface ist der Mut des Weglassens und wirklich auch selber, die Entscheidungen zu fällen für den User, was man weglässt oder nicht.
Da kann man scheitern, da kann man aber auch gut gehen. Da stimme ich dir voll zu.
Das ist da nicht drin in der Mentalität, derzeit nicht.
Das steckt bei vielen Hackern definitiv nicht drin. Dieser prinzipielle Wunsch, wenn man einmal angefangen hat, Software zu entwickeln, dann kennt man ja dieses Gefühl, dieses Feature noch rein und dieses Feature noch rein und die wirklich auch wegzulassen. Vor allem, teilweise sind das ja so, man sitzt fünf Minuten dran, Feature zu implementieren und oh, eine neue Funktion, die keine Sau braucht. Aber es gibt da doch ein paar, mittlerweile eine Handvoll Gegenbeispiele. Also, Firefox auf jeden Fall hat zwar unglaublich viele Features, ohne jede Frage, aber ist jetzt, glaube ich, würde ich mal sagen, noch nicht überfrachtet, hat es zumindest klug in die Plugins ausgelagert. Ja, und das finde ich ist ja eine Option. Oder das finde ich sogar eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, dass ich erstmal eine relativ abgespeckte Software habe, die jeder bedienen kann, und dass ich mich aber dann gezielt in den Bereichen, die mich interessieren, für mich Erweiterungen und da vielleicht sogar noch Alternativen zur Auswahl habe, finde ich ziemlich großartig. Und Ubuntu, so eine Standardinstallation, wenn sie dann einmal läuft, man hat einen Haufen Probleme. Wahrscheinlich mit irgendwelchen WLAN-Treibern, vielleicht mit irgendwelchen Audio-Karten-Treibern, aber wenn es dann einmal läuft, hat man eigentlich einen relativ aufgeräumten Desktop, den man schön einfach bedienen kann. Absolutes Gegenbeispiel sicherlich The Gimp und OpenOffice, die, glaube ich, beide komplett überfrachtet sind mit Features.
Ja, also Gimp ist natürlich auch bekennendes Power-User-Tool, von daher finde ich das an der Stelle nicht so. Ja, aber da kann ich dir auch einen Chaos-Rider-Express-Podcaster dazu empfehlen, den ich mit Sven gemacht habe. Einen der Entwickler von Gimp, wo wir das auch alles mal durchgegangen sind. Das ist so eine Mentalitätssache, die im Printbereich, wollen sie zwar CMYK haben, weil sie solche Workflows gewohnt sind, aber technisch brauchen tut man es nicht.
CMYK ist der Farbraum des Druckens. Die Drucker drucken und darum wollen Grafiker immer alles in CMYK machen. Darum unterstützen Photoshop und Illustrator CMYK.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, also ich will da jetzt nicht zu tief reingehen, aber kurz gesagt, Farbraum, also der mögliche Farbraum mit CMYK ist ja ein anderer als mit RGB.
Genau, also man kann andere Farben mit CMYK...
Aber mittlerweile leben wir in der Zeit der Farbprofile und wir leben vor allem in der Zeit des sRGB-Standards, der das halt alles ganz gut abdeckt. Und Standard ist halt sRGB, mit sRGB kann man alles tun, was man tun muss, was die Farben sozusagen als solche betrifft. Es ist nur eine Frage des Workflows, auf was für Farbauszüge blicke ich halt jetzt tatsächlich. Aber bitte lass es uns bei der Stelle jetzt belassen, weil das ist jetzt weder unsere Expertise noch unser Thema. Wie gesagt, da gibt es den passenden Express-Podcast, wo es Sven alles ausführlich erklärt, warum das so ist, wie es so ist. Außerdem sehen die sich ja auch nicht gegenüber Photoshop und so weiter. Letztes Thema, was ich auf meiner Liste habe, dann können wir uns auf die Hörerfragen stürzen. Kasse gemacht hat Apfel mal wieder. Dickes Quarter. Kohle ohne Ende verdient und bestes Quarter, also innerhalb des Jahres war es das beste Quarter. Nein, welches Quarter ist das? Das beste Quarter 3 heißt das, genau. Das zweite Kalender-Quarter ist das dritte Financial-Quarter und das war noch nie so gut. Und die bemerkenswerte Zahl ist, abgesehen davon, dass sie wieder ordentlich Kohle verdient haben, dass sie jetzt fast 2,5 Millionen Max verkauft haben. 2,5 Millionen, das ist noch nicht so lange her. Da hat man sich gefreut darüber, dass sie 1 Million verkauft haben.
Das ist Zuwachs in Europa um 40% oder wie viel waren das im Web-Top-Bereich?
Overall waren es 41% und im Desktop war es noch ein bisschen mehr. Im Desktop haben sie jetzt vor allem zugelegt durch den iMac, den neuen.
Genau und gerade auch in Europa doch sehr stark zugelegt, wenn ich nicht alles zustehe.
Sie haben in allen Ländern zugelegt, sie haben sogar in Japan zugelegt, wo sie lange Probleme hatten und sie haben eigentlich generell zugelegt. Das kann man einfach mal so festhalten. Vor allem sogar auch iPod noch gesteigert, wo wir alle schon gedacht haben, 11 Millionen Stück. 12 Prozent mehr verkauft.
Da muss man mal sagen.
Rund eine Milliarde Dollar Gewinn gemacht. Jetzt müssten sie wie viel Barcash haben. Apple ist ja eine der Firmen, die total viele Barreserven haben.
Die können sich alles kaufen.
Ich glaube, beim letzten Mal waren es 18 Milliarden, dann müssten es jetzt nur 19 sein. 19 Milliarden Dollar an Barcash.
Ein Teil müssen sie auch noch ausschütten, oder? Das Gewinn.
Wie ausschütten?
Apple schützt keine Dividende aus. Dividende ist eine freie Entscheidung einer Firma, ob die das machen oder nicht.
Sie haben einen Dollar Gewinn pro Aktie gemacht, aber nicht einen Dollar.
Mit Apple-Aktien kannst du nur Gewinn machen, wenn du sie verkaufst. Das macht Microsoft anders.
Microsoft hat es aber jahrelang genauso gemacht. Die haben vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit das erste Mal überhaupt Dividende ausgeschüttet.
Das ist ja egal, weil die Aktie steigt ja dementsprechend. Also wenn du keine Dividende ausgeschützt bleibst, das Geld hat die Firma einen größeren Wert, dadurch steigt die Aktie. Also wie du es machst, ist eigentlich total wurscht. Aber...
Ich glaube, Apple mag es, eine gute Kriegskasse zu haben.
Aber langsam ist es schon echt wie 19 Milliarden Dollar.
Da weiß ja Gaia, was sie sich mal kaufen.
Langsam müssen sie, glaube ich, angeben, wie viel Zinsen sie verdienen von diesen 19 Milliarden. Weil ein Teil des Quartals-Gewinns ist ja Zinsgewinn von dieser Geldsumme. Kannst ja mal ausrechnen, was sie da kriegen.
Ich kenne mich nicht gut aus mit Zinsrechnungen. Auf jeden Fall haben sie derzeit keine Probleme, viel Geld zu verdienen. Vor allem unter dem Gesichtspunkt, dass sie ja bei diesen ganzen iPhones den Gewinn, wie wir vorhin ja schon angedeutet haben, über zwei Jahre verstrecken. Das heißt, diese ganzen iPhones, die jetzt verkauft werden, was ja so wenig auch nicht sind, sicherlich noch sehr viel mehr werden. Eine Million irgendwie sind sie losgewonnen von dem 3G jetzt am ersten Wochenende.
Wobei es da auch Unkenrufe gäbe.
Ja, Unkenrufe gibt es aber immer. Ich glaube, die haben es schon, weil sie normalerweise nie Shipments. Das ist die Microsoft-Methode, alles mit Shipments zu rechnen. Dann stehen die ganzen Geräte da irgendwie im Lager bei Walmart und keiner will sie haben.
Außerdem, das gibt es ja keine mehr. Es scheinen die Shipments und Verkaufsgeräte fast dahinter zu sein.
Ich bin mir da sicher, dass sie die verkauft haben. Und die Kohle wird jetzt in den nächsten Quartalen überhaupt erst noch eingepflegt. Also auch das allererste iPhone, was alle gekauft haben, generiert immer noch Einnahmen für die nächsten Quartale.
Ein ganzes Jahr lang, ja. Ich hab grad ausgerechnet, also ich hab mal mit 5% ausgerechnet. Wenn sie 5% im Zinsgewinn machen, dann sind das 900 Millionen Dollar im Jahr. Also 225 Millionen pro Quartal. Die sind nur an Gewinn machen durch diese 18 Milliarden.
Ich glaub auch, dass mehr drin ist als 5% Das kriegst du ja heute schon fast ein Tagesgeldkonto. Oder mal zu Steve sitzt zu Hause und hat das alles auf Quartal Consens online.
Der hat sein Sparbuch.
Wissen wir es. Wissen wir nicht.
Das ist eine Privatsache.
An Privatsachen von Steve hat man nie ranzugehen. Das ist auch egal, wie gesund der ist.
Hat man weder Krebs noch Konzentration.
Sollen wir nicht drüber reden? Stimmt auch. Dann gab es noch zwei schöne Statements bei diesen Quartalorie-Sals. Erst wird ja die Zahl ausgekippt. Dann gibt es noch diese schöne Fragestunde. Ist nicht alles aufgeschrieben. Ich fand zwei Sachen interessant. Sie bezeichnen Apple TV immer noch als Hobby und sagen keine Zahlen. Also so toll scheint es noch nicht zu laufen damit. Oder sie sind da noch nicht angekommen. Haben jetzt viele Filme und so. Aber das ist alles noch kein Ding. Und dann sprachen sie davon, dass ihr bereits gesunkener ihre Gewinnmarge, ihre durchschnittliche über alles liegt jetzt irgendwie in 1-2% gesunken. Und sie haben jetzt angekündigt, dass sie noch weiter sinken werden im nächsten Quartal und zwar gleich um 3% auf 30%.
Wobei man ja erst mal dazu sagen muss, dass Apple immer eine sehr hohe Marge hatte. Also andere Hersteller wären froh, wenn sie, wie viel hatten sie diesmal, 34%, die wären froh, wenn die 34% Gewinnmarge hätten.
Klar, weil Apple halt in das High- und Midpreissegment verkauft. Hatten wir doch neulich hier so mit irgendwie alles, was teurer als 1000 Dollar ist, hat Apple einen Marktanteil, also bei Rechnern.
Aber nun kommen wir endlich mal zur Begründung.
Product Transition Ahead, sagen sie.
Weil sie den Markt so fertig machen wollen.
Weil sie etwas billiger verkaufen wollen, als sie es eigentlich müssten, um ihre Gewinnmarge, ihre durchschnittliche zu halten. Aber lieber billiger verkaufen wollen, um den Kompetitoren nicht da eine Einstiegsmöglichkeit gibt.
Das haben sie ein bisschen anders formuliert, oder? Ich dachte, das hätten sie so formuliert, um ihn wegzurennen, um ihn weiterhin vorne gar keine Chance zu haben.
Ja, wie auch immer. Der Grund ist, sie wollen etwas billiger verkaufen, als sie es normalerweise verkaufen würden, gegeben an den Herstellungskosten. Jetzt gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, was das sein kann. Entweder kann es sich auf die Laptops beziehen oder auf die iPods, weil das ist das, was im nächsten Quartal unter Garantie aktualisiert wird.
Aber bei Laptops kann denen doch keiner billiger kommen. Also klar, das ist halt dann aber ein PC.
Ich denke auch nicht, dass es die Laptops sind. Ich denke, es ist die iPod-Linie. Und sie werden den Touch extrem billig machen. Allein schon um gegen diese gefühlten 200 Dollar, die das iPhone jetzt angeblich kostet, was natürlich so wahrnicht ist, das war ja alle. Aber diese gefühlten 200 Dollar steht irgendwie im Raum. Und sie wollen auch die Plattform vergrößern und verstärken. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie entweder das Ding sehr viel billiger machen, vielleicht sogar den Classic komplett ächzen. Dass sie einfach, weißte geier, ich meine gut, sie haben viele iPods verkauft. Ich weiß aber nicht, sie sagen ja nicht, von welchen sie viele verkauft haben und was nicht mehr so gut läuft. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass, was weiß ich, der große 5G-iPod mit 160 Gigabyte, könnte ich mir vorstellen, der läuft nicht gut. Könnte ich mir vorstellen, ich weiß es nicht. Ich könnte mir das deshalb vorstellen, weil die Leute sagen, 80 Gigabyte kriege ich nie voll. Ja, boah, ich nicht. Es gibt so ein paar Leute, die wollen halt immer alles haben. Wie kauft sich sowas? Aber eigentlich, wenn die meisten Leute, schätze ich mal, die so ein Ding haben, dann könnten sie sich sagen, okay, wir lassen den Classic jetzt sterben. Weg mit dem Rad. Wir machen jetzt nur noch den Nano mit dem Rad. Lassen aber den Classic irgendwie weg und ersetzen das durch eine größere Bandbreite an Touches. Zum Beispiel einen 64 Gigabyte Touch. Der Sie aber eigentlich noch viel Geld kostet, wegen Gramm ist teuer. Wo Sie aber sagen, da gehen wir mit unserer Marge runter, damit wir den noch in den Markt kriegen, damit wir den 80 Gigabyte iPod fallen lassen können. Dann brauchen wir keine Festplatten mehr verbauen und so weiter. Das sind Flash-Only und vor allem viele Leute, die sich sonst für den Classic entschieden haben, werden dann wahrscheinlich auf den Touch gehen, weil der halt preislich 100 Dollar billiger ist als jetzt oder 150.
Aber stand da nicht, dass die Konkurrenz nicht mithalten kann an Teachers?
Ja klar, sie sagen halt, gegen den Touch kann keiner ankommen, weil wir sowieso die Besten sind.
Die haben es doch so formuliert, dass das dabei rauskam, dass sie unbedingt der Konkurrenz weiterhin, die erst mal still ist. Lass uns mal das raus suchen. Macht das mal jemand, der ein Laptop hat. Habe ich noch gar nicht erwähnt, oder? Ich bin nämlich hier so Laptop-los.
Der Max ist nur mit seinem iPhone.
Das haben wir schon mehrfach erwähnt.
Ja, aber warum? Weil mein MacBook Pro, das muss ich jetzt...
Ich weiß nicht, wo das jetzt auf die Schnelle...
Das muss ich jetzt auf Apple Insiders...
Darum auf Apple Insiders war das? Und darum ist mein MacBook Pro gerade dabei, einen Backup zu machen, auf einen MacBook, das ich jetzt für die Zeit habe, in der ich hoffentlich nicht allzu lange auf die Reparatur warten werde und ich werde dann berichten über den verschriebenen Apple Support. Die holen das nicht mehr ab, wenn man ein kaputtes Gerät hat, wusstet ihr das? Man muss das selber vorbeibringen. Da schwand mir Böses.
So, also hier die Zitate auf Apple Insider... Das ist aber schön gelösegefüllt. Gut, oder?
La la la la la.
Apple doesn't want to leave a margin so high that it creates an umbrella for competitors to rest under in terms of price. It often releases at high price, but lowers their cost later. Also das heißt...
Das ist aber jetzt eine Apple Insider Aussage.
Das ist ein Zitat von dem Oppenheimer. Das ist jetzt nicht komplett zitiert, aber das ist sozusagen die Aussage von Apple.
Product Transition hat er explizit gesagt. Und das heißt...
Das wäre aber eine Transition, wenn sie den iPod Classic einstellen. Das heißt, dass sie sozusagen komplett auf Touch transitieren.
Okay, das wäre...
Dass sie von der alten iPod-Plattform auf die neue iPod-Plattform übergehen. Das Einzige, was noch läuft, ist der Nano, weil der läuft gut und der Shuffle hat sowieso kein User-Interface. Und dann würden sie sozusagen... Also, das ist nur meine These.
Ja klar, natürlich.
Wenn ich recht hab, krieg ich eine Mate und so weiter. Du kriegst noch eine ganze Kiste.
Ich krieg noch eine ganze Kiste.
Und ich hab unsere andere...
Weil die schon fast eine Kiste versoffen hat bei unseren Podcasts.
Ich hab die andere Wette gewonnen, weil ich gesagt hab, dass mehr als oder 500 Applications noch im Juli kommen.
Ich hab vergessen, was ich gesagt hab.
Haben wir beim letzten Mal schon drüber gequatscht.
Guck doch einfach mal nach, liebe Leute.
Ach, nachgucken. Ist doch alles Schnee von gestern.
Hört nach.
Tja, wenn wir mal so Kapitelmarken hätten. Die Diskussion macht nicht auf. Auf jeden Fall hast du jetzt verstanden, was meine These ist? Meine These ist, ich sage, sie gehen auf Touch. Jetzt, wo sie den Upstore haben, wollen sie einfach noch mehr iPods haben, damit die Leute auch da die Scheiße kaufen. Und deswegen lassen sie den Classic fallen und deswegen müssen sie damit zwischen dem Nano und dem Touch, dem kleinsten Touch, dem 8GB Touch oder was auch immer dann der kleinste sein wird, vielleicht gehen sie da auf 16, 32, 64. So, den 8er lassen sie fallen. Und damit sie den 16er noch so günstig verkaufen können, dass er an den Nano anschließt, dass da nicht so ein großes Loch entsteht, wo dann, was weiß ich, Microsoft mit seinen Missionen oder Sand ist oder wie. Ja, aber viele Leute gehen auch über den Preis. Das ist so, ja. Die wollen halt ein Deco Playa haben.
Ich habe eine andere These. Und zwar kommt das iPhone unlocked weltweit. Doch, AT&T sagt auch, das kommt unlocked in Amerika in the near future. Und wir reden ja hier bei diesem Statement von einem Bereich von Juli bis September, also schon demnächst oder jetzt oder heute. Und das macht für Apple schon Sinn, weil eigentlich, sie verdienen ja jetzt über den App Store die Kohle. Die brauchen ja die Provider gar nicht mehr.
Warum sollten sie das jetzt drei Monate nachdem sie so gestartet sind, machen?
Reicht doch.
Ja, aber dann haben sie alle Verträge ausgehandelt, so dass das nur für drei Monate gilt. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Diesen ganzen Aufwand mit irgendwie Provider-Bindungen und was nicht alles weltweit. Weil sie ja jetzt in den nächsten Monaten überhaupt erst neue Länder starten.
Es würde Sinn machen, das iPhone noch billiger anzubieten, weil sie sich die Kohle über den App Store wieder reinholen kann ein bisschen.
Also ich würde es für wünschenswert halten, aber ich halte für relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Wenn sie die Kohle anbieten, über den App Store sagen sie auch, bei dem Conference Call haben sie gesagt, das sei für sie kein Profit Cow.
Das haben sie beim iTunes Store früher auch gesagt. Inzwischen machen sie 100 Millionen pro Quartal.
Ja, aber das ist nicht viel.
100 Millionen, das ist ein Zehntel vom Gewinn.
Das ist nicht viel und sie haben mit Verlusten gerechnet. Das ist nicht viel.
Das ist ein Zehntel vom Gewinn.
Was, sie machen 100 Millionen Gewinn?
Eine Milliarde geht über den iTunes Store, haben sie gesagt, war das so? Sie machen ja 10 Cent pro Song.
Oh, jetzt lassen sie hier anfangen, das komplett aufzudrösen. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Tatsache ist, dass sie das da auch von Anfang an gesagt haben. Das heißt, sie haben den Music Store aufgesetzt, um die Apples zu verkaufen. Das hat ja auch wunderbar funktioniert. Und genauso ist es jetzt mit dem App Store. 30 Prozent mag erstmal viel klingen und 25 Millionen Downloads, die sie jetzt haben, mag auch viel klingen. Keine Ahnung, da war wahrscheinlich 15 oder 20 Millionen waren kostenlose Downloads, so bleiben noch 5 Millionen über. So dann nochmal 30 Prozent, dann bist du auch eher so im 6-stelligen Bereich.
Ich glaube, die Verdiener beim App Store kommen die noch viel schneller ins Plus als beim iTunes-Store.
Irgendwann werden sie das auf jeden Fall tun. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es derzeit ihre Strategie sein kann, jetzt auf die Provider-Bindung zu verzichten, weil das würde ja ihre ganze Subventionsmodelle durcheinander werfen.
Aber es ist ja auch, ich meine, es geht ja darum. Sie warnen ja davor, dass weniger Gewinn kommen wird, weil wir das umstellen werden. Also, ich kann es nicht...
Eine Product Transition, Sie sprachen. Nicht vom iPhone. Es würde ja schon heißen, dass Sie auch neue Produkte bringen müssten.
Ich glaube das nicht. Ich glaube, dass es wirklich mit neuer Hardware was zu tun hat.
Es kann nichts anderes sein, weil dann wäre es keine Transition.
Ich schätze mal, dass es auch mit neuer Hardware zu tun hat. Und zwar hoffe ich einfach mal ein bisschen auf den Mac-Bereich. Endlich mal wieder was, wo ja lang nicht wirklich mal was Neues gekommen ist. Damit wir hier mal über ein Mac reden und nicht über das iPhone. Nein, weil da auch mal was fälliges ist. Also Apple war ja doch immer relativ gut darin, auch mal so mit dem iMac, dieses berühmte USB, so knallhart auf irgendwas zu setzen. Ich hoffe, oder das MacBook Air, was jetzt einfach mal auf alles verzichtet, was nicht über die Luft geht, ich hoffe ja mal, dass da im Mac-Bereich noch was kommt. Also entweder...
Hoffen ist jetzt keine Aussage.
Da komm, du hoffst aber auch.
Ich?
Mit dem iPod Touch.
Nö, ich hab nur gesagt, das ist das, was ich... Ja, das ist das, was ich denke, was passieren wird, keine Hoffnung.
Also was ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass Apple endlich mal anfängt, den Flash-Bereich ein bisschen zu forcieren.
Den Flash-Bereich?
Genau.
Welchen Flash meinst du jetzt? Flash RAM.
Flash RAM. Festplatte rausschmeißen.
Na, das machen sie doch am laufenden Meter.
Das machen sie. Sie haben die Preise für das MacBook Air gesehen. Vielleicht tatsächlich zu sagen, entweder das MacBook Air gibt es gar nicht mehr mit Festplatte, sondern es wird so billig sein mit SSD.
Ich glaube auf diese Themen kommen wir jetzt sowieso, wenn ich überschlage, was an Fragen kam. Ich habe hier vor der Sendung wieder mal hier Fragen für den nächsten Podcast gepostet. Und bin erstaunt. Also hier kamen in 8 Stunden doch mal locker 47 Kommentare zusammen. Und wisst ihr was? Die gehen wir jetzt durch.
Jede einzelne?
Jede einzelne, weil ich glaube, manche lassen sich auch schnell beantworten, weil wir da schon drüber geredet haben. Zum Beispiel die erste. Wie sieht es denn aus mit euren Erfahrungen im Application Store? Gibt es schon brauchbare Anwendungen? Bla, bla, bla. Gibt es noch was, was wir empfehlen können? Außer der Taschenlampe? Habt ihr noch irgendwas entdeckt? Ich hatte jetzt keine Zeit da zu schauen.
Also NetNews war ja, mag ich doch relativ gerne. Gibt, ist ein RSS-Reader, kennen wir alle von Mac. Lieben wir auf dem Mac, kann man sehr schön synchronisieren. Wer den Google-Reader hat, da gibt es wohl noch einen hübscheren, noch einen schöneren RSS-Reader, mit dem man mit dem Google-Reader synchronisieren kann, was jetzt nicht wieder heißt. Der kostet ein bisschen was. NetNews war erst kostenlos. Ich hab mir ein so Doku-Spiel gekauft, Teil zu Doku heißt das.
Hast du dir eigentlich den Fahrplan geholt?
Den Fahrplan hab ich auch, ja.
Funktioniert der gut?
Der Fahrplan, der GPS sagt dir, wo du bist.
Wir reden von Berliner WVG-Plan.
Es gibt zwei, Moment, es gibt mehrere Fahrpläne. Ich geh hier einfach mal der Reihe nach durch.
Das will ich auch wissen.
IAM, es funktioniert wie IAM funktioniert, außer, dass es nicht im Hintergrund läuft. Aber es ist ohne Java. Klar war es IAM. Dieses Remote-Programm von Apple sieht genauso aus wie der iPod auf dem iPhone. Aber es ist halt eine Fernbedienung für iTunes.
Ich kann dir jetzt mal ein iTunes Fernsteuer.
Ich könnte jetzt gleich dein iTunes Fernsteuer. Dann haben wir Twitterrific und Twinkle, zwei Twitter-Clients, die ich beide doch relativ enttäuscht finde. Aber vielleicht nur, weil ich ein Konkurrenzprodukt habe. Dann gibt es diverse Fahrplan-Entwindungen. Und zwar eine für Berlin. Das ist echt ganz niedlich. Womit man... Ich kann jetzt hier tippen.
Wie heißt denn die eine, wie heißt denn die andere?
Also das eine heißt Trip Planner. Das ist für Berlin, hat so einen Brandenburger Tor als Eigen. Da kann ich Berliner Fahrpläne abfragen. Und zwar kann ich unter anderem sagen, ich hätte gerne jetzt hier Haltestellen bei mir in der Gegend. Wo ich jetzt gerade bin.
Also der nutzt halt den Locate Me Service.
Genau, der nutzt den Locate Me Service. In dem Fall zum Beispiel sagt er mir jetzt alles klar, du bist in der Winzstraße und wo möchtest du denn hin? Ich sag mal zum S-Bahnhof Warschauer Straße.
Dann hast du so deine Favorites sozusagen.
Und das ist jetzt die, die ich vorher schon mal eingegeben habe. Und dann sagt er mir das hier um. Und da fängt es nämlich an, er hat hier so schöne Balkendiagramme. Aber mich interessiert überhaupt nicht so ein blödes Balkendiagramm, sondern ich möchte auf die Minute exakt wissen, wann fährt meine blöde Bahn im theoretischen Fall. Und das kann ich hier nur so erahnen. Grob geschätzt erahnen. Ich glaube 2038 würde ich mal vermuten.
Einen anderen View gibts nicht oder was?
Einen anderen View gibts im Augenblick noch nicht.
Aber warte, die Windstraße hat er jetzt gefunden, weil du dich lokal...
Die Windstraße hat er jetzt lokalisiert.
Genau. Hast du nicht schon als Favorite gehabt? Hat ich noch nicht gehabt.
Das habe ich jetzt wirklich hier live gemacht. Das ist echt eine ganz hübsche Sache. Ist definitiv noch ausbaufähig, aber da kommt noch was. Fahrplan ist ein Programm, da kann ich einfach nur bei der Deutschen Bundesbahn eingeben, wo bin ich gerade, und kriegt dann den Fahrplan zu sehen. Kann ich leider kein Stil angeben. Und das hat mir gesagt so, wann fährt er denn jetzt mal hinzu?
Und der macht auch nicht Location, oder was?
Der macht das auch nicht Location-basiert.
Aber der ist dafür deutschlandweit.
Ich hätte ja gerne die Software so, dass wenn man das Programm laufen lässt, dass er permanent guckt, wo bin ich, wie laufen lässt, dass es im Vordergrund ist. Und dass man sozusagen, dass er regelmäßig checkt, was ist die beste Verbindung für meine Orte, wo ich normalerweise immer hin will, dass man mir immer anzeigt, wenn du da hin willst, dann müsstest du jetzt sozusagen, die nächste Gelegenheit da hinzufahren, wäre um... Und dass man aber auch sagen kann, heute muss ich spätestens um 22 Uhr zu Hause sein, dass er mir dann einen automatischen Alarm generiert, wenn ich sozusagen relativ da, wo ich gerade bin, verstehst du, immer weiß, wann ich sozusagen spätestens losfahren muss, um dann und dann da zu sein, dass er mir dann auch vorher 10 Minuten Bescheid sagt, wenn du jetzt nicht einsteigst, dann ist deine letzte Gelegenheit weg.
So was. Da ist noch viel zu holen. Man kriegt so mit, da ist noch eine ganze Menge zu holen. Also es gibt so einen Haufen Location-Aware-Applications, die dann wissen, wo ich bin und probieren mir dann irgendwelche Hotels einzublenden oder wo sind meine Kumpels und sowas alles. Da gibt es massenhaft Zeug natürlich. Funktioniert alles nur so mittelprächtig.
Das muss ich auch erstmal legen jetzt in dem Store.
Jetzt sag mal, ob noch irgendwas dabei ist, was du wirklich empfehlen kannst.
Ein VNC-Client, ein hübscher.
Also Screensharing sozusagen.
Genau, mit dem ich auf meinen Mac zugreifen kann. Das geht auch? Das geht erstaunlich gut. Ich kann sogar mit Fingertilten rein und rauszoomen und sowas.
Und dann kannst du echt mit dem Finger, so mit dem Maus und so?
Du kannst mit dem Finger die Maus bewegen, kannst Fenster hin und her ziehen. Das ist extrem praktisch.
Zumal ja das Screensharing auch VNC-kompatibel ist.
Genau. Dann, was hab ich hier noch, was man noch so empfehlen kann? Was ich nicht empfehlen kann, ist diese WordPress-Applikation. Die hat bei mir einen Haufen Probleme. Ach, Evernote. Das ist eigentlich auch eine hübsche Sache. Evernote ist ein Programm, das gibt es auch für einen Mac. Da legt man sich ihren Account an und da kann man zum Beispiel Dokumente einscannen. Man kann Texte eingeben, man kann alles Mögliche machen. Und dann werden die Daten auf den Server hochgeladen. Das heißt, man kann die synchronisieren. Ich kann mir jetzt hier also auf meinem iPhone angucken, welche Notizen habe ich dann eigentlich da oben auf dem Mac angelegt. Und die haben oben auf dem Server noch gleich eine OCR-Software drin. Das heißt, ich könnte jetzt, leider taugt die Kamera vom iPhone dafür nicht so wirklich was, ich könnte jetzt von einem Zeitungsartikel ein Foto machen. Und hochladen. Und könnte hochladen.
Als Text wieder.
Und ich kriege das dann, ich kann es dann durchsuchen, oben auf dem Mac. Oder auch hier vom iPhone aus, kann man also nach Begriffen, die darin auftauchen, suchen. Also ich kann das mal kurz demonstrieren. Ich hab hier irgendwann mal, wir haben ja...
Soll Solala funktionieren, habe ich gelesen.
Das funktioniert Solala. Also es könnte besser sein. Sperrblick wollte ich jetzt nicht, ich wollte jetzt Spreeblick machen, weil ich habe hier irgendwann mal... Ich habe hier irgendwann mal von dem einzigen Printmagazin, was wir jemals gemacht haben, genau, habe ich mal so ein Foto gemacht und habe das hochgeladen. Und schon findet er, wenn ich nach diesem Begriff suche, findet er, weil die Überschrift groß genug ist, finde ich, alles klar, da habe ich mal von irgendwas ein Foto gemacht, wo Spreeblick drauf stand. Das ist eigentlich so eine ganz schöne Sache.
Dann gibt es noch ein Tool, das heißt Shazam. Da hältst du irgendwie die Luft, das lauscht der Musik und dann findet es irgendwie raus, was es ist. Das ist auch für und umsonst.
Funktioniert überhaupt nicht, habe ich ausprobiert. Also ich habe es nicht zum Laufen gekriegt.
Kommt drauf an, dass du so für eine Musik hörst.
Gesundheit. Ich habe mehrere Mainstream-Sachen ausprobiert. Ich habe nicht so Mainstream-Sachen ausprobiert.
Jetzt haben bestimmt schon zwei Hörer vom Fahrrad gefallen. Hat die das jetzt nicht mehr hören?
Beziehungsweise unser Autobahnfahrer ist jetzt wahrscheinlich in der Leitplacke gerade gelandet.
Vorsicht, Mobile Macs nicht zur Real-Time-Steuerung im Auto benutzen.
Ich habe extra schon das Mikro gedreht.
Okay, wir müssen weiterkommen. Das war jetzt der erste von 47. Jetzt haben wir ja noch etwas ganz Kniffliges. Jetzt gibt es eine Möglichkeit, meinen Mac Mini ohne Tastatur und Maus zu starten. Mir war ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so richtig bekannt, dass es nicht geht. Das liegt daran, dass ich die Bluetooth-Tastatur und Maus dran habe. Aber du hast gesagt, das ist jetzt ein Problem, oder was?
Ich habe ja keinen Mac Mini. Ich weiß nur, dass wenn ich bei meinem Desktop den Rechner starte und die Maus ist nicht drin, dann kommt nach dem Booten, so noch bevor wir log in, kommt so ein Request, dass ich jetzt meine Bluetooth-Maus irgendwie sünden könnte, damit man dann halt weiterarbeiten kann.
Du hast auch so jetzt einen Bluetooth-Dongel da explizit dran, weil er keinen Bluetooth hat.
Ich glaube schon, ja. Bin mir nicht so sicher.
Also wenn Bluetooth nicht da ist oder vielleicht abgeschaltet ist, dass es dann nicht macht.
Ja, aber Booten muss er erstmal. Der stellt ja später fest, dass die Tastatur oder Maus fehlt.
Vielleicht merkt er sich diesen Zustand mit irgendwie Bluetooth...
Aber starten muss das Ding ja erstmal, weil du musst ja irgendwie einschalten können.
Was einschalten können?
Na jeden Rechner. Der weiß doch am Anfang noch gar nicht, dass da nichts dran ist.
Ja, starten kannst du ihn, aber wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe, bleibt er dann irgendwie da hängen.
Genau.
Auf den nervigen Warnmeldungen verzichten.
Genau, mit irgendwie ist nicht da. Wie bei DOS damals.
Er hat einfach auch das Problem, dass er nicht durchbootet.
Genau, no keyboard.
Ich nehme an, der wird schon durchbooten, aber er wird wahrscheinlich in der dämlichen Fehlermeldung dastehen.
Das heißt ja nicht durchbooten, aber bleibt er da hängen.
Können wir es eigentlich kurz machen? Wir haben keinen blassen Schimmer.
So sieht es aus. Ich habe zwar ein Mac Mini, aber ich muss das mal ausprobieren.
Und der soll sich eine Bluetooth-Mouse kaufen.
Zum Wecklicken dieses Dialogs.
Okay, können wir jetzt so schnell nicht helfen. So, was haltet ihr von den neuen Gerüchten bei ein neues und revolutionäres Touchbook? Blablabla, ich habe da was gelesen und so weiter. Oh, da hat sich einer ein MacBook Air gekauft wegen meiner Kommentare. Haha, er ist zufrieden.
Auch das noch?
Gibt einen Ausblick, wie man das Gerät upgraden kann. Also zum Upgrade kann ich sagen, bestimmt irgendwann. Noch habe ich nichts gehört, dass es Platten gibt, die nicht größer sind. Platte tauschen halt.
Ja, wenn man es aufkriegt, wird man sehen. Was bei MacBook Air nicht so einfach ist.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die 160 GB Version früher oder später ansteht. Das ist aber jetzt eher so eine generelle Einschätzung. Dass immer sicher ist, dass die Platte größer werden.
Aber selber upgraden würde ich mich nicht trauen.
Zum Touchbook, zum Revolutionieren kann ich nur sagen, das wird nicht passieren.
Bei Apple weiß man nie irgendwas.
Natürlich weiß man nichts, aber ich glaube noch nicht, dass ein Markt wirklich da ist für so ein Laptop-großes iPod-Teil. Battery Life, sage ich nur.
Ich sehe es auch nicht so wirklich. Auf dem iPhone gibt es noch nicht die Software, die richtig große Bildschirme wirklich anspruchsvoll macht. Und das Mac-User-Interface jetzt mal eben so touchable zu machen, das hätte man auch schon irgendwie.
Nicht das Mac-User-Interface. Ich denke, wenn Sie so etwas machen, dann ist es ein großer iPod. Stell dir mal vor, du würdest den iPod jetzt auf hier so 13 Zoll größer, also nur das Display von meinem MacBook. Das wäre schon so das, was man sich hier so hinlegt, und da hätte man so den Web-Browser zum auf den Tisch legen. Das ist ja die alte Vision, dass man das so drauf rumtippt. Vom User-Interface her würde ich sagen... Genau, ein großer iPod. Natürlich, klar, das ist die Touch.
Der muss ja nicht so viel größer sein. Mehr als so sollte er ja nicht sein, eigentlich finde ich.
Der 5 wäre auch schon ganz interessant. Ich meine, es wäre cooler zum Webseiten lesen als das Ding. Das geht zwar irgendwie, aber größer ist besser. Es wäre cooler, sich darauf Filme anzugucken, weil es größer ist. Es wäre cooler, sich auch Kalendern... Es wäre cooler für alles, es ist halt nur so, dann passt es nicht mehr in die Hosentasche.
Eben, das ist für das große Problem.
Das ist glaube ich die Frage, die sich Apple auch immer wieder stellt. Wenn wir so ein Produkt bauen können, also wenn es a. bezahlbar ist, b. überhaupt Komponenten gibt, die so ein Battery-Life erlauben, was ich derzeit nicht sehe. Weil wenn so ein iPhone oder ein Touch nur ein, zwei Tage halten und wenn du das Ding dann irgendwie achtmal so groß baust vom Display, irgendwo muss der Strom auch herkommen für die ganzen Pixel. Das hat dann auch mehr Pixel. Also ist glaube ich alles noch nicht so richtig erfunden. Kannst du eine Batterie machen, keine Ahnung. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auf jeden Fall ein Problem ist. Wenn es möglich wäre, müssen sie immer noch Käufer dafür finden. Das schleppst du halt mal nicht so eben rum. Und wenn du eh schon so ein großes Teil mit rum schleppst, warum dann nicht gleich ein Mac?
Also wir wissen da auch nicht mehr als der Rest.
Ich glaube nicht.
Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass es kommen wird so bald.
Nächste Sache. Was vermutet ihr an Hardware im September?
Na ja hatten wir ja gerade schon so ein bisschen. Das Macbook Pro wird eigentlich langsamer Zeit.
Das wird es schon seit zwei Jahren mindestens.
Hatten wir ja schon darüber geredet, über diese Spyshots. Ich halte das für glaubwürdig, dass Akku leichter sich tauschen, umso größer ist, aber dass vor allem die Platte sich leichter tauscht.
Das ist ja jetzt auch die Zentrino 2-Plattform.
Das ist ja so ongoing. Also revolutionär wird da nicht viel sein, denke ich mal. Das wird wahrscheinlich immer noch genauso aussehen. Ja, aber nur um diese beiden Bugs zu fixen.
Das reicht ja schon.
Und damit man...
Sonst ist ja alles schick.
Weil was ist auch alles, was wir schon gewünscht haben?
GPS einbauen und UMTS einbauen. E-Sata? Ach so, externen Sata-Platten. Und jetzt ist es schon so weit?
Das sollten sie erstmal an Mac Pro anschließen oder sowas.
Na, aber Apple ist doch mit solchen Sachen immer eigentlich relativ weit vorne. Wir müssen ja nicht warten, bis es alle anderen haben, sondern irgendeiner muss ja...
Aber sie werden Firewire 800 auf jeden Fall noch behalten und irgendwo muss das ja auch hinpassen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob E-Sata...
Ist das wirklich so viel schneller?
Nein, schneller, aber so die ganzen E-Sata Platten, warum willst du extra jetzt noch irgendwie einen Firewire-Controller mitkaufen, willst du die Platte direkt, zack.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es kommen wird. Ich glaube, wenn das kommt, dann kommt es an XServe oder Mac Pro.
Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass es kommt, weil die Chipsets, die können auch sowieso alle E-Sata oder der Stein, die brauchen das Ding nur nach außen legen, das kostet dir nichts extra oder so.
Ja, aber Schildplatz kostet sie.
Wenn Apple alles nach außen legen würde, was die Dinger könnten, dann würdest du...
Ich hab diesen externen Festplattenmark nicht so beobachtet, aber das kann da alles sehr schnell gehen. Und ich glaube, wie ist das im PC-Bereich? Gibt es da Laptops schon mit E-Sata-Port?
Ich kann es dann draufsetzen.
Sollte man auf eine MacBook Pro-Generation die alte Antwort...
Man soll nie warten.
Also man soll immer dann kaufen, wenn man es braucht. Nicht vorher, aber auch nicht später.
Genau, wenn es die Features hat, die du haben willst und dir jetzt nichts einfällt, was du so sehr vielleicht auch haben wollen würdest, dann kauf einfach. Ist eh Wurst. Kauf lieber früher als später. Ja, ach, diese leidige Geschichte. Wir sind keine Ärzte. Was ist mit Steve los? Er war bei der Telefonkonferenz nicht dabei. Tatsache ist, der ist bei diesem Financial Conference Call nur dann dabei, wenn gerade irgendein Major Fuck-Up passiert ist, wo er die Gemüter besänftigen muss. Sonst ist er da nicht dabei. Das macht halt einfach die Finanzabteilung und dieser Cook und so weiter. Die sind dann immer da.
Oppenheimer ist ja gar nicht mehr, ne?
Doch, das ist der. Nee, Rubinstein war dieser.
Gibt es Anzeichen für einen Nachfolger vom Mac Mini? Nein, oder?
Anzeichen? Also da ist immer...
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das, weil der Mac Mini ist ja so ein bisschen das Bastard-Shirt.
Was könnte das neue Produkt im vierten Quartal sein, haben wir schon gesagt. Meiner Meinung nach der Touch. Also nicht wirklich neu. Ich rechne nicht mit neuen Produkten, um ehrlich zu sein. Oder sie haben auch gesagt, sie hätten wieder tolle new products.
Vor Weihnachten sind nochmal ein paar neue tolle Produkte fällig, oder?
Also ich sehe ein neues MacBook Pro, ich sehe ein komplettes Refresh des iPod-Line-Up, aber das findet jeden hier das erste, das muss man nicht voraussagen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass sie ein bisschen was eingebaut haben, also wie gesagt, Flash-Speicher oder irgendwie sowas.
GPS ins MacBook Pro und ich würde sagen, das Ding ist heiß.
Ich brauche da kein GPS drunter.
Neuer Verschluss, Festplattenproblem lösen und dann wäre das Ding für mich echt, doch ich will GPS haben. Wofür?
Ja, natürlich.
Na guck mal, die ganzen kleinen Tools, die kommen, die mit deinen Friends finden und so, die brauchen ja alle GPS.
Ja, mein Kalender, der mir sagt, wenn ich zuhause bin, hab ich die to do's, wenn ich im Büro bin, hab ich die to do's.
Aber das kriegst du viel besser über WLAN raus.
Ey, GPS, dieser kleine Stein, kostet nix. Er kostet nix. Antenne einfach einbauen, einfach machen und den Entwicklern überlegen, wie man das benutzen kann.
Also ich glaube, hier drinnen funktioniert GPS doch eh nicht.
Lieber die Skyhawk, Wireless, Tra-la-la, genau das. Ja, das ist genau das selbe, einfach dasselbe einbauen.
Beides nehmen, also kombinieren.
Also ich brauch keinen GPS. Ich will, ich will, also ich brauch's nicht. UMTS ist schon wesentlich eher.
Das MacBook Pro 3G.
Also ich hätte gern beides.
Dann wär mir lieber eine, da würde ich doch eher auf eine Lösung hoffen, iPhone 3G, das, wo man das Netz dann auch vom MacBook aus nutzen kann.
Und haben. Sie machen Multisim und das ist an die auch ganz gut so. Und warum nicht hier einbauen?
Und wo das, die sollen mal eine Software machen, wo sich der Rechner die GPS-Koordination vom iPhone holen kann.
Die GPS-Koordinate?
Also die, wo man gerade ist halt.
Vom iPhone holen?
Per Bluetooth.
Ach, zu kompliziert.
Ist auch Quatsch.
Mich würde interessieren, ob es eine Applikation für den Mac gibt, mit der man sich ähnlich wie beim iPhone anhand der Wi-Fi-Netzwerke in der Umgebung digitalisieren lassen kann.
Der heißt ja Dennis, das bin aber nicht ich, aber ich antworte trotzdem. Und zwar brauche er nur zu skyhawkwireless gehen. Weiß nicht, wie der heißt, skyhawkwireless.com. Und dort gibt es ja einen Example-Code oder API. Das heißt irgendwie WPS halt. Und das kann man auch auf dem Mac irgendwie starten. Und dann geht das. Man muss sich aber einen Developer-Account holen. Und dann kann man da so den benutzen. Man darf halt den nicht millionenmal benutzen, dann schalten sie es wieder ab. Aber so zum Testen kann man den probieren.
Dann schicken wir mal eine URL dazu, bitte. Was es da natürlich auch noch gibt, ist good old places, oder? Die haben leider keine schöne APIs noch außen hin, aber die bieten sowieso...
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht wirklich jetzt so ein Dienst für Programme, die wirklich eine Koordinate liefern. Also Places liefert in dem Sinne keine Koordinate, oder?
Na, die können auch eine Koordinate liefern, wenn du sie hinterlegt hast.
Ja, aber das basiert ja nicht wirklich auf einer Lokalisierung, sondern das basiert da drauf auf der Mac-Adresse von deinem Router.
Es lokalisiert dich nicht örtlich, also es gibt keine Koordinaten quasi zurück, aber genau dieses Feature, was du eben gerade meintest, so ich möchte wissen, welche du tust für zu Hause und welche du tust für unterwegs, ist das eine absolut gute Lösung. Und zwar funktioniert das, um es mal kurz zu erklären, die nehmen einfach nur die Mac-Adresse vom Router, also vom ersten Router, den sie finden, und speichern den Datenbank ab, und du hinterlegst da einen Namen dazu, und im Zweifelsfall noch eine Location, und schon haben die dich lokalisiert quasi, wenn du dich wieder am selben Netzberg einlädst.
Auf dem Mobiltelefon benutzen die auch die Cell-Information.
Auf dem Mobiltelefon benutzen sie auch die Cell-Information, aber für einen Laptop halte ich das für eine sogar ziemlich gute Lösung, fast in vielen Fällen besser als GPS.
Ich hätte lieber das einfach alles drin. Ich meine, wenn sie jetzt beim iPhone auf 3G setzen, dann können sie bitte auch bei den Macs draufsetzen. Einfach Slot, SIM-Karte rein, ab geht die Post.
Wie?
Na, ich will hier einen SIM-Karten-Slot haben.
Ach so, SIM, ja, für Uramt, ja. Ich dachte, ihr seid immer noch bei GPS.
Wie kann man...
Für GPS braucht ihr ja keine Karte. Das solltet ihr einfach können. So, weiter. Mobile Me mit Schimpfworten beschreiben sollen wir. Haben wir das schon getan? Noch nicht so richtig, ne?
Ich hab ja kein Mobile Me. Du darfst jetzt ein Schimpfwort hier aussuchen.
Ich bin jetzt gerade nicht so richtig in Rage.
Kommt noch Lieferung nach.
Ich bin von Anfang an nicht davon ausgegangen, dass es mir große Dienste leisten wird und das, was ich benutze, funktioniert. Von daher...
Aber wir können uns alle schön vorstellen, wie Steve Jobs bei den entsprechenden Entwicklern reingekommen ist.
Welche Farbe seien Sie?
Vielleicht ist das der Grund, warum er krank ist.
Und die Schimpfworte, die er benutzt, die können wir nur erahnen.
Ihr könnt ja gar nicht, Sie seid ja noch schlechter.
Ich glaube, bei den Schimpfwörtern ist er noch kreativer als bei den Produkten, die er anbietet.
Ok, ein spezielles Thema für zwischendurch. Wir wechseln hier in schneller Fahrt, weil wir das nicht vorher sortieren können. Wie kann man eine Time Capsule, iTunes, ein iPhone und ein MacBook Air so konfigurieren, dass man seine Medienbibliothek extern, zentral ablegt und einen Teil auf den MacBook Air und dann auch auf dem iPhone belässt? Oh Mann.
Das ist nicht so ein Satz.
Linux installieren. Also, keine Ahnung. Ich vermute mal, das wird schwierig, aber wenn du eine Lösung hast, lass sie uns wissen, weil das ist jetzt Time Capsule, iTunes, iPhone. Also es ist sowieso schwierig, mit iTunes und mehreren Mediendatenbanken zu arbeiten. Es gibt so Tools hier, dass wir unsere Fly auswechseln lassen, ob man dann auch auf Time Capsule zugreifen kann.
Time Capsule kann man ja als externe Festplatte einbinden, oder?
Da kennst du dich besser aus als ich.
Dann könnte man seine MacBook Air, füge ich einfach von der Remote Share ein, in meinen iTunes, Patrick und ich einholen. Das geht relativ problemlos. Es ist bloß das Problem, wenn die gerade nicht gemontet ist oder nicht in der Nähe ist und man hauschen Scheißen.
Und ich sehe schon Hänge des iTunes, das macht alles keinen Spaß.
Übrigens gibt es ja einen iTunes-Tipp, man kann mit der Alt-Taste starten und dann kann man seine, wie nennt er das, Medienbibliothek aussuchen und dann kann man zwischen Zweiten hin und her wechseln. Muss man einfach mal Alt festhalten beim Starten von iTunes.
Das stimmt, aber man kann nicht beides benutzen, was ich wirklich bekloppt finde, das müssten sie eigentlich mal einbauen. Ich will sowieso ein iTunes Pro, das habe ich auch schon mal gesagt. Aber die nächste Frage kommt hier eh später noch, dann können wir jetzt auch gleich drauf eingehen. Was ja auch eine Option ist? Ist was, genau?
Multithreaded, oh Gott, und das DAAP. Das ist das, was iTunes mal mit der Version 4.0 eingeführt hat, dass man Musik vom iTunes sharen kann, dass ein anderes iTunes das share sieht und dann drauf zugreifen kann. Das habe ich ja auch damals, jetzt kann ich wieder tolle Storys erzählen, mit so einem Tool, das ich als Isaac hieß, ausgenutzt, indem ich irgendwie ein Perl-Script hatte, was irgendwie aus dem iTunes die Musik rausgepopelt hat und browserfähige Links angeboten hat, damit man im Browser wiederum die MP3s aus einem anderen iTunes raussauen kann und dann abspielen kann mit schöner Datenbank und Suche und einem Schnickschnack. Und dann kam iTunes 4.0.1. und da haben sie es gleich wieder zugemacht. Und davon gibt es halt, ja, das Protokoll ist ja offen. Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Standard ist, aber es ist offen.
Offen dokumentiert oder offen re-ingeniert?
Beides. Also es ist offen dokumentiert.
Echt, ich glaube, das ist dokumentiert?
Ja, da gibt es irgendwas. Oder es ist auch gar nicht direkt von Apple, ich weiß es gar nicht genau. Aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall diesen Multisratted...
Firefly heißt das ja auch, glaube ich, oder?
Der nennt sich auch Firefly, genau. Und da schiebt man halt, also das kann man unter FreeBSD oder auf Mac oder auf Linux starten, schiebt man seine Musik rein. Der geht da mit einer EskoLite 3 ja, Scanner drüber, packt alles in die DB rein und bietet dann das auch so kompatibel an, dass das iTunes diese Share dann sehen kann und man dann vom iTunes aus seine Bibliothek abspielen kann. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Das ist ziemlich cool. Ich hab das auch zu Hause am Laufen. Die Frage, die dazu kam, war, wie kann man denn darüber Metadaten, glaube ich, bearbeiten und Daten zufügen?
Kann man nicht.
Und die Antwort ist schlicht und ergreifend, geht gar nicht. Ist glaube ich auch ein Protokoll nicht vorgesehen.
Gibt gar nicht. Ist übrigens laut Wikipedia immer noch ein Proprietary-Protokoll. Und wurde zwar reverse-ingeniert, wird aber von Apple mittlerweile für kommerzielle Implementierungen lizenziert. Das heißt, wenn du so...
Das ist diese Roku Sound System oder wie es heißt. Und da machen die... Roku Sound System. Das ist also ein Radiowecker oder so, der irgendwie auf so einen Share, so einen iTunes-Share oder MTDAP, da irgendwie zugreifen kann. Und deswegen meinte der Typ von MTDAPD auch, dass sie dieses Protokoll ja nicht ändern können, da das Roku das halt benutzt. Und deswegen können sie es nicht mehr ändern, wenn diese Roku-Teile nicht mehr funktionieren.
Also noch mal zu der ursprünglichen Frage, kann man das mit iTunes verdingsen?
Man kann sich die Musik davon anhören von diesen Teilen?
Time Capsule ist ja nicht in der Lage... Ach, jetzt klingelt hier wieder alles, weil ich nicht die Nachtschaltung angemacht habe. Hoffentlich nimmt das jetzt gerade mal einer ab hier irgendwie. Sonst muss ich das einfach mal kurz ausschalten hier, tut mir leid. Und jetzt gibt es hier Nachtschaltung und dann ist Ruhe im Karton. So einfach geht das.
Ist ja auch schon spät.
So, wo haben wir jetzt Time Capsule?
Genau, was ich sagen wollte ist, Time Capsule selber bietet dieses Sharing nicht an. Das wäre vielleicht mal so ein Feature für das Teil, dass man da wirklich auch eine Medienbibliothek ablegen kann.
Das wäre mal eine richtig coole Idee, die Musik auf so ein Time Capsule drauflegen und der tut so, als wenn er halt ein iTunes ist und bietet das an.
Genau, dass das auch richtig unterstützt wird. Dass man so ein iTunes starten kann. Oh, da ist ja ein Time Capsule. Möchtest du deine Musik vielleicht ab heute zentral absprechen? Ja, Waiting 20 Stunden.
Das geht ja noch besser. Und zwar das Time Capsule kriegt die Musik drauf. Das Time Capsule ist ja eine Hardware, kriegt also auch den Musikausgang. Und dann kann man es momentsteuern natürlich mit dem iPhone, mit diesem, ähm, wie heißt es? Remote. Wie heißt das eigentlich? Air Remote, Apple Remote? Einfach Remote. Genau, da brauchen wir gar kein iTunes mehr.
Apple TV macht das. Kann man damit ja steuern. Also Apple TV ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen dieser Home-Server.
Eigentlich schon, ja stimmt.
Eigentlich will man Apple TV in Time Capsule so...
Das ist das, was mich an diesem Apple TV immer schon genervt hat. Das Apple TV ist irgendwie ein Scheiß, weil es ist, da müsste eine Basisstation mit rein, und da müsste halt irgendwie ein Einfach-So-Storage mit rein. Das kann einfach zu wenig, dieses Teil.
Mit der Basisstation ist es insofern ein bisschen problematisch, da die Telefonanlage bzw. das, wo das DSL aus meiner Wand rauskommt, ist im Allgemeinen nicht in der Nähe zu dem, wo habe ich meinen Fernseher rumstehen.
Und das ist auch nicht unbedingt der Ort da, wo du deine Base Station haben willst. Wobei das Problem hast du auch mit dem DSDL-Anschluss, das ist auch nicht unbedingt der optimale Ort dafür.
Aber ja, das könnten sie ja mit ran machen, das kostet die doch auch nichts. Es ist doch nur eine Software, dass wir da noch ein bisschen Basis-Stationen-Zeugs machen. Und dann hätte ich mir eins geholt.
Ich denke, gut, aber ich denke, das ist eine evolutionäre Geschichte. Sie entwickeln da einfach verschiedene Sachen. Ich meine, Time Capsule kommt jetzt so von diesem, ich war erstmal in der Airport-Base Station, konnte auch Internet-Access machen, jetzt habe ich auch eine Festplatte, jetzt mache ich auch Backup. Das ist so das eine gewachsene. Apple TV hat grundsätzlich schon mal mehr mit Medien zu tun, aber ist nicht so sehr Server, sondern eigentlich mehr so universeller Client. Das zu verschmelzen, das muss schon klug gemacht sein, weil am Ende hast du ein teures Produkt, wo du versuchst alles zu können, und dann ist es für niemanden geeignet, weil es den einen zu teuer ist, dem anderen nicht.
Ich bin auch sehr gespannt, ob das so genau so kommen wird, weil doch die Ansprüche ein bisschen unterschiedlich sind.
Irgendwas müssen sie sich auf jeden Fall einfallen lassen, weil dieses iTunes jetzt als Server, auch wenn es nicht fernbedienbar ist, das ist einfach hakelig, weil so ein Rechner, da ist er nämlich nicht immer eingeloggt und das ist irgendwie auch alles so...
Wobei, das ist eine hübsche Sache. Also ich meine, den Rechner hat jeder und wenn ich jetzt ein iPhone habe, dann kann ich darüber meinen Rechner schön fernsteuern. Das haben ja auch viele Leute, die so rumstehen, den Rechner, gerade auf Partys und dann... Ich meine, es will ja nicht jeder die Lösung gleich für immer haben, sondern wenn ich hin und wieder mal auf einer Party meinen Rechner dann irgendwo hinstelle...
Ja, aber Medien-Server im Heim ist ein echtes Thema. Ich meine, das ist das, was alle haben wollen. Alle wollen... Du willst in so einem Familienkontext vor allem... da will Papa in den Store gehen und sagen, ich kaufe jetzt den Film. So, oder ich kaufe die Musik. So, und dann soll die Familie das benutzen können. Und zwar nicht, indem sie Zugriff auf seinen Laptop kriegen, sondern...
Wenn er gerade um Arbeit ist, geht ja gar nichts.
Ja, er ist mit dem Laptop irgendwie unterwegs. Gut kann man sagen, da kannste ja ein iMac hinstellen, la la la, so, aber dann brauchste halt irgendwie, dann ist der iMac sozusagen wiederum der Familien-Server.
Man will was Dediziertes haben.
Und das ist halt dann auch wieder, dann bist du so eingeloggt, du kannst nicht sicherstellen, dass da wirklich immer ein iTunes-Grad drauf läuft oder laufen darf, weil nimmt ja auch Speicher weg und Security und Zugriff und Ports offen und Firewall und das sind einfach so viele Fragen.
Für die meisten Anwendungen würde es wahrscheinlich komplett reichen, wenn, also das Ganze einfacher machen, wenn man einfach die Musik und die Videos, die man sich gekauft hat, mehrfach runterladen darf, dann richte ich auf all diesen Rechner einen eigenen neuen Account ein und dass mir die dann einfach noch mal runtergeladen werden auf das entsprechende Gerät, sobald ich es anfordere. Weil ich habe so dieses Zentral, wir stellen irgendwo einen Server hin, der einfach so erstmal da steht und sich erstmal nur Strom frisst. Ich glaube darin, das hat Apple bisher noch nie so richtig forciert. Und man muss ja auch mal sagen, diese Home-Media-Server, die es so für Windows gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob die wirklich großen Erfolg haben außer unter einer Hand voll absoluten Hyper-Nerds.
Aber die haben ja auch kein Store und kein Nix. Bei denen ist ja alles nicht cool.
Die haben auch dieses Media-Server-Zeug und so was.
Xbox und so, die kommen jetzt auch alle auf PlayStation. Das wollen die jetzt alle machen. Eigentlich ist das halt wirklich der Markt. Die Konsolen und Apple TV, die gehen alle so in die gleiche Richtung.
Xbox kriegt sogar eine sehr hübsche Lösung mit Netflix. In Amerika ist das so ein Online-Ausladen.
Die arbeiten jetzt mit Microsoft zusammen.
Richtig gehört, dass Amazon seinen DVD-Verleih wieder einstellt?
Weiß ich nicht, aber jetzt erkläre es mal, das mit Netflix und Microsoft interessiert mich.
So richtig viel ist da noch nicht bekannt. Die Xbox 360 wird komplett überarbeitet werden. Jetzt, ich glaube auch September, Oktober, so was in dem Dreh.
Software-mäßig oder Hardware-mäßig?
Software-mäßig. Erst mal wird es noch keine neue Hardware. Erst das sehe ich auch irgendwann mal fertig. Und zwar so V-artiger, also weg von den Hardcore-Gamer hin zu diesem ganzen Xbox Live-Zeug. Und man kriegt so kleine lustige Avataren, die man drum spielen kann. Und so, und man kann so Sachen machen, die man dann, wo man in großen Gruppen zusammen spielen kann live und so Quiz-Spiele.
Das ist aber noch nicht bestätigt, dass es kommt, oder?
Das ist, das haben sie angekündigt auf der...
Microsoft kündigt doch immer alles schon Jahre vorher an.
Auf irgendeiner Konferenz haben sie das jetzt großartig angekündigt.
E3 wahrscheinlich.
Auf der E3, genau. Und da haben sie auch angekündigt, dass es eine Kooperation mit Netflix geben wird, dass man sich über die Xbox Videos ausleihen können wird.
Netflix ist doomed. Wieso? Weil, Kooperation mit Microsoft heißt, dass sie demnächst ihren Business einstellen können, weil Microsoft das selber machen will.
Ja, vielleicht kaufen sie das auch.
Hat bisher noch keiner überlebt, eine Kooperation mit Microsoft.
Wir werden sehen, auf jeden Fall ist das, auf jeden Fall Video auf der Xbox wird es geben. Und Apple muss sich auch warm ansehen in dem Bereich, glaube ich.
FH fragt, Firestorage im Netz im Terabyte-Bereich, die möglichst gut mit Time Machine und Comments spielt. Keine Ahnung. Ein FH. Tja, er sagt jetzt hier im Netz, wir wissen nicht, ob Netzwerk lokal oder Netzwerk Internet gemeint ist. Ich tipp mal, Terabyte-Bereich kann eigentlich nur im lokalen Netz wirklich interessant sein. Da fällt mir halt dieses Drobo ein, was ja in Podcastland ganz gut bekannt ist.
Da hast du mir jetzt voll einen Link rumgeschickt und ich hab ziemlich angefangen zu sabbern, um ehrlich zu sein.
Das ist cool, ich hab das Ding noch nicht in der Hand gehabt, aber ich hab ganz interessante Berichte darüber gelesen. Was das ist? Das ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als so ein Festplattenregal. Ohne jetzt tausendmal Gehäuse aufschreiben, sondern du steckst da einfach deine SATA-Platten direkt rein.
Drobo ist das Kürzelauf für Dropbox?
Das hat mit Dropbox nichts zu tun.
Bist du sicher, weil Drobo... Da bin ich mir total sicher.
Auf jeden Fall, man kann im laufenden Betrieb die Festplatten auswechseln.
Genau, es handelt sich nämlich dabei um ein RAID-System. Das ist so ein schwarzer Würfel, wo einfach Festplatten-Slots drin sind, vier oder so, und man kann einfach SATA-Platten einfach reinschieben. Die haben ja diesen schönen stabilen Stecker. Schreibst du rein, im laufenden Betrieb, dann formatiert er dir die Platte automatisch. Also du hast hier kein User-Interface, nichts, kein Kontrollprogramm, gar nichts.
Das gibt es auch, aber musst du nicht benutzen.
Brauchst du nicht, sondern du brauchst eigentlich nur die Lampen daneben, das heißt, du machst die Platte da rein, dann wird das irgendwie gelb oder rot, weiß nicht genau, dann rüttelt er da irgendwie rum, macht die Platte rein und bindet das dann sozusagen ins RAID ein. Das heißt, du schiebst 400 GB dazu, und eine halbe Stunde später hast du einfach 400 GB plus auf einem einzigen Volume. Das heißt, dieses Teil, im laufenden Betrieb geht das.
Nutzt ZFS unten drunter?
Keine Ahnung, das ist eine gute Frage, was sie da machen.
Ich denke, sie haben ein Linux mit LVM-Zeug.
Was auf jeden Fall ganz grandios ist, ist im Gegensatz zu sonstigen RAID-Lösungen, die man öfters mal so erlebt, oder eigentlich allen RAID-Lösungen, die ich kenne, die Platten dürfen beliebig groß sein. Also die müssen nicht alle gleich groß sein. Das hört sich verdammt nach ZFS an. Also wenn man sich jetzt eine 750 GB Platte, weil sie gerade irgendwo günstig rumliegt hat, dann ist man nicht für den Rest aller Tage auf 750 GB festgelegt, sondern dann holt man sich eben in vier Monaten eine 1,5 TB Platte dazu, wenn man dann mehr Speicherplatz haben möchte.
Also wirklich easy peasy.
Sieht zumindest so aus. Also wenn das so funktioniert, wie es da gemeint ist, dann ist es groß.
Sie haben jetzt Firewire 800, auch in der neuesten Version. Vorher war das nur USB. Ach na ja, mittlerweile geht auch USB.
Und es gibt irgendwie eine Netzwerkoption, die habe ich aber leider nicht gefunden auf der Seite.
Genau, es gibt eine Netzwerkversion, da ist dann irgendwie Ethernet dran und dann hat man eben auch einen Share. Das mag jetzt vielleicht diese Frage auch schon beantworten, das macht meines Wissens HFS.
Aber kann man denn mittlerweile zu irgendwas anderen als nach Time Capsule überhaupt einen Time Machine Backup machen über Luft?
Einen anderen Mac OS 10.5 Leopard.
Okay, aber auf die Kiste wahrscheinlich dann immer noch nicht.
Ich habe da nicht viel Zeit drauf verbracht, aber Time Machine und Drobo ist wohl über Netz noch nicht möglich, aber selbstverständlich kannst du es natürlich lokal benutzen. Das heißt, du kannst das Ding auch an deine Time Capsule anschließen. Also du kannst es auch an deine normale Express anschließen.
Und schon ist man bei knapp 5.000 Euro dabei?
Hab ich Express gesagt?
Extreme.
Also auch wenn du eine normale Airport Extreme hast, die hat ja hinten USB. Und da kannst du im Prinzip auch so ein Drobo anschließen. Und dann kannst du das, das ist zwar jetzt offiziell nicht supported, wie wir ja gelernt haben bei Apple, aber das funktioniert. Und dann hätte man im Prinzip denselben Effekt.
Klingt nach einer relativ lustigen Lösung.
Keine Ahnung, wie das hier mit Distributoren aussieht, aber dieses Drobo Zeug ist auf jeden Fall interessant.
Und Terabytes kannst du auf jeden Fall auch.
Und es ist kein ZFS, wie ich hier lese, es ist so was anderes.
So, dann sollen wir hier irgendwie auf die Freiheitskampagne in der Schweiz hinweisen. Wegen Biometrie passt das natürlich in unser Thema. Wir weisen jetzt mal drauf hin. Und der Link ist in den Kommentaren. So, dann hier Subscription, iCal, Mobile Me, Sinken, blablabla. Gibt es eine App fürs iPhone, die an Geburtstage erinnert?
Ja, der Kalender.
Macht das sehr in Messe. Kann man auch einschalten, dass man den auch, dass man die Geburtstage aus dem Adressbuch auch als Kalender haben möchte.
Genau. Und zu den anderen Problemen haben wir ja schon was gesagt hier mit Subscriptions, da muss man auch was hintenrum finden. iPhone-Problem hier, US4000. Ach, das war diese lange Geschichte, die wir nicht so richtig verstanden haben.
Ich glaube, ich hab das verstanden.
Okay, dann erklär doch gleich mal. Sein Problem ist, Doppelpunkt.
Sein Problem ist, ach so, was ist denn sein Problem?
Der Problem ist, neues iPhone gekauft, aber eine alte Nummer portiert, Telefon aktiviert mit der wohl temporär...
Mit der neuen Telefonnummer quasi?
Der Telefonnummer, die eigentlich dazu gehört, aber dann wurde die Portierung freigeschaltet, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Wollte dann dem iPhone beibringen, auf diese neue Telefonnummer zu lauschen, und das ist gescheitert.
Und dadurch kann er zum Beispiel kein Voice-Mail machen.
Genau.
Klingt eher doof.
So, und die Sache ist die, dass es... Ich weiß nicht, ob er einen anlockt oder nicht anlockt hat, aber es gibt so eine Datei auf dem iPhone, und zwar pro, wie sagt man, pro Telefonanbieter, oder wie heißen die? Provider? Nee, weiß nicht. Provider sind doch die mit dem Internet. Die Telcos, genau so nennt man die ja. Und in dieser Datei steht drin zum Beispiel, was die Voice-Mail-Rufnummer ist, und halt eventuell dann auch seine eigene. Weil bei mir zum Beispiel wird nicht oben angezeigt, welches meine eigene Nummer ist, aber ich hab nämlich jemanden gesehen, der... Telekom-Vertrag, und da steht ganz oben im Adressbuch, meine Nummer ist, und das ist bei mir nicht der Fall. Die taucht halt nirgends auf.
Genau, das ist wahrscheinlich genau der Prozess, der bei der Aktivierung passiert.
Genau, und da hat er wahrscheinlich halt, ist das eingetragen worden, wenn er dann seine Karte wechselt oder was auch immer, dann stehen halt noch die alten Daten da drin. Das könnte eine Möglichkeit sein. Das zweite ist, dass er auch sein Telefon auch neue Software eingespielt hat oder was auch immer. Und dann mit iTunes irgendwie seine alten Daten hat zurückspielen lassen.
Nee, nee, das steht da explizit rein, dass das nicht gemacht hat.
Wiederherstellen?
Er hat es mit Wiederherstellen probiert und bringt nichts.
Okay, okay. Warte, warte, aber Wiederherstellen ist ja Restore und dann kann man halt irgendwie seine Daten wieder einspielen lassen. Da gibt es einmal Setup as New oder Neue.
Da steht aber, nützt mich auch nicht komplett neu aufsetzen.
Nee, aber neu aufsetzen ist Restore. Das ist die Software drauf. Danach fragt aber das iTunes so, ich könnte jetzt deine Daten wieder einspielen?
Nein, nein, da steht das Telefon mit iTunes wiederherstellen nützt nicht, auch nicht komplett neu aufsetzen. Das heißt also...
Achso, ok. Du hast recht, du hast recht.
Das ist einfach offensichtlich...
Das heißt...
Was ist mit dieser Datei?
Kommt man an die ran, wenn man das Telefon gejailbrägt hat? Kann man die irgendwie löschen?
Da kommt man ran, aber fragt mich jetzt nicht mehr, wie das ging. Und wo die...
Ich würde mal sagen, klingt auf jeden Fall auch erst mal...
Wie die Pfeife in Support des...
Aber wenn er es ja komplett neu eingerichtet hat, dann kann es mit der Datei eigentlich auch nicht sein.
Also er scheint sich ziemlich weit umgehört zu haben und scheint nicht zu lösen zu sein.
Gut, also wer da eine gute Antwort hat, wir haben leider keine wirklich gute. Ab in die Kommentare nach der Sendung schalte ich ja auch nochmal frei. Die Kommentare habe ich so immer gebremst.
Wann kommt EA mit Tetris in den deutschen App Store? Tetris ist ziemlich gebashed worden, die EA-Version. Die ist, dass die ziemlich scheiße sei und langsam und blä, und weiß ja toff was.
Es ist ganz interessant, dass halt manche Programme wirklich nur in bestimmten Stores zu finden sind.
Zum Beispiel Programme von Google, weiß ja toff, warum.
Warum auch immer. Ja, haben wir da Erfahrung? Haben wir glaube ich nicht.
Nee, braucht man eine amerikanische Visa-Karte für?
10, 5, Franz, tra la la, was war nix von A2DP, auf Leopard, er hätte gerne. Ja, du zählst auf uns, ist schön, aber wir haben da nicht so richtig gute Antworten. Also A2DP wird generell irgendwie noch nicht so richtig unterstützt von Mac.
Also das war das Audio-Kopfhörer. Und zwar Stereo-Audio.
Stereo-Audio oder Kopfhörer.
Ich glaub das geht, ja.
Seit wann?
Seit 114 oder so, gab's noch nicht. Ich hab da im Club mal getestet, war das schon Stereo?
Nee, nee, Leopard.
Ach so.
Wie halte ich meinen Bruder ab, jetzt einen Mac Mini zu kaufen? Auch wenn er ihm reicht, soll er ihn gleich kaufen. Ich meine, warum nicht? Ich hab mir auch einen gekauft. Dieses Warten, das ist alles Quatsch.
Na ja, manchmal ist es, also wenn man weiß, dass in zwei Wochen was kommt, wissen wir aber nicht. Aber wir wissen es nicht.
Gerade beim Mac Mini ist es einfach so, da wurde schon so viel gewartet. Das ist einfach das einzige Produkt. Der Mac Mini wird meiner Meinung nach nur dann aktualisiert, wenn sie müssen, weil nämlich der Prozessor nicht mehr gebaut wird.
Mac Mini ist das Bastard-Schalt.
Das ist wirklich, ja ja.
Das ist Max, das ist Apple ganz unten.
It's good enough.
Ich glaube, ich hab mir irgendwann mal gehört, dass der Mac Mini nur eingeführt worden ist, weil die Aktionäre es unbedingt alle wollten, um in diesem Bereich überhaupt irgendwas zu haben. Und das Steve, die mögen den eigentlich gar nicht.
Eine 30% Marge, dass man auf diese 500 Dollar abzüglich der Händlermarge noch irgendwie draufrechnet. Die vielleicht so bei 10, 15% maximal liegt. Da bleibt nicht so viel übrig, um so einen Computer zu bauen.
Aber der Mac Mini ist eigentlich ein schönes Gerät, muss man wirklich sagen.
Ich glaube bei Apple, bei den Preisen, da geht schon noch ein bisschen was auch beim Mac Mini. Also guck dir mal an, was die PC-Hersteller da für völlig Zeugs verkloppen.
Gut, hier gibt es auch noch Antworten. Unter Umständen wird hier in den Kommentaren schon so einiges besser beantwortet, als wir das hier jetzt sagen können.
Ist euch was bekannt, dass nach dem Gebrauch des neuen Pwnage-Tools mit dem alten iPhone unter Firmware 2.0 zu Problemen mit dem Edge-Zugangsdaten kommen kann?
Naja, die Zugangsdaten sind nicht mehr eingetragen, er muss die neu eintragen.
Genau, aber es ging mir auch so.
Es ging erstmal Edge nicht und ich dachte doch, shit, jetzt geht ja der Scheiß nicht, aber...
Welche Zugangsdaten?
Diese APN.
Achso.
Aber man kann die problemlos noch eingeben. Ich dachte nämlich unter Umständen, oh Gott, oh Gott, es gibt das Feld überhaupt.
Dass man das wieder reinhacken muss, weil früher muss man es ja reinhacken. Und es ist da, man trägt es einfach ein und...
Ich hab's gesehen. Ich kenn auch jemand, der Edge erstmal nicht hatte. Zugangsdaten eingetragen, alles super. Insofern, nein, keine Probleme.
So, kann man das iPhone jetzt als Navigationsgerät einsetzen? Tja, statt einem TomTom. Also die TomTom-Sofia ist bisher noch nicht da.
Also man sieht wo man ist, aber man wird ja nicht navigiert. Das ist ja ein Unterschied.
Ja, und ich hab auch über die GPS-Qualitätsgeschichte noch nicht so viel Gutes gehört. Also keine Ahnung, ob das alles nur jetzt 2.0 hat, oder ob es wirklich die Antenne zu kurz ist. Das ist ja ein geiler Aussage. Das könnte natürlich auch sein. Ja, iPhone Auto integrieren, keine Ahnung. Also grundsätzlich jede iPod-Integration neurer Bauart könnte auch fürs iPhone funktionieren, aber Apple hat schon wieder das eine oder andere geändert.
Ein iPod mit Inkretion im Autoradio.
Der fragt nach Navigationsgeräten für Mac-User. Ich hab ja so ein TomTom und da gibt es halt dieses TomTom Home gibt es auch für Mac. Auch die neue Version, diese 2.0 glaube ich.
Super.
Echt, du hast ein TomTom, welches hast du denn?
TomTom Rider natürlich.
Ich will mir ein TomTom kaufen, aber ich kann mich nicht entscheiden, was. Falls jemand von euch TomTom benutzt, irgendwie im High-End-Bereich, empfehlt mir doch mal eins. Muss ich mir das High-End-Teil kaufen? Muss man immer rechts unten kaufen?
Nee, muss man nicht.
Aber es sind coole Features drin. Ich möchte halt gern GPS, also wenn schon GPS, dann richtig. Dann will ich auch so alle Möglichkeiten mit über OKW, aktuelle Staumeldungen, Pipapo, hier darfst du nicht langfahren. Das ist hier in Berlin aber echt wichtig.
Du musst da subscriben für so ein Zeug.
Über OKW empfangen?
Ach so eine Staumeldung, das geht? Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt so Verkehrsdaten digital über OKW.
Nee, aber das TomTom, der kann halt per Bluetooth über dein Telefon irgendwie da hochklingeln und kann sich immer die Daten holen. Und auch zum Beispiel diesen GPS-Hotfix kann er sich da drüber holen und so weiter.
Aber es ist vollkommen unklar von der TomTom-Webseite, was da was ist, weil es immer so Marketing, Wischiwaschi, Weichzeichner, Formulierungen ist.
Na die wollen halt auch möglich, dass du viel Zeug subscribst.
Ist alles irgendwie aktueller und so? Ja, da wollen sie das halt.
Das ist bei uns im Fallgerät oder so was. Ich glaube, den Stau gab es schon lange nicht mehr, den ich da umfahren bin. Ich bin ihn umfahren, vielleicht war er auch noch da.
Ja gut, aber ich will das Ding ja nicht einmal die Woche docken, um mir irgendwie meine Staumeldungen zu holen. Du meinst richtig übers Telefon mit Bluetooth und Datenconnect und teuer?
Der Datenconnect nicht, wenn du eine Flatrate hast, aber die wollen natürlich bei TomTom dafür Kohle haben.
Na gut.
Kostet dann irgendwie 10 Euro für nur Staumeldungen im Jahr oder mehr oder...
Ja, aber wie gesagt, es gibt auch die kostenlosen Staumeldungen über OKW, die kann man sich da einpflegen lassen. Das funktioniert prinzipiell, glaube ich, auch auf diversen Geräten.
Aber 10 Euro im Jahr, würde ich sagen, kann man darüber reden.
Das sind mehr.
Das bleibt ja nicht bei 10 Euro. Dann würde es ja auch die Baustellen oder den Map-Share, das gibt es für sonst bei TomTom.
Blitzer will man haben.
Blitzer zum Beispiel, da gibt es aber...
Der Map-Share ist so dieses User-Sagen, wo...
Du gibst die Baustelle ein und dann kriegt die jeder.
Ach so.
Wobei den traue ich ja nicht.
Dass es nicht kostenlos wird.
Den traue ich aber nicht, diesen Feature.
Den Map-Share?
Wer sagt mir denn, dass das richtig ist?
Da wir jetzt zehn Leute eingegeben haben, das ist genauso wie mit Skyhawk Wireless.
Das ist ja quasi...
Ach, zehn Leute müssten gesagt haben, da ist Stau?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, wie die es genau machen, aber die werden natürlich auch irgendein...
Ja, keine Ahnung, das behaupten sie vielleicht....
Regelwerk haben, mit dem sie das...
Das ist ja geil, vielleicht läuft da irgendein Penner rum und fängt die ganze Zeit überall, die Brücke ist gesprengt, irgendwie hier ist eine Baustelle und da ist da gar nichts.
Dann würde ich mir zehn Geräte kaufen, um alleine die Autobahn für mich zu haben.
Genau, Autobahn gesperrt. Kurz bevor du los wärst du alles gesperrt.
Ich sehe schon, Tim-Tim muss ich einen Tom-Tom kaufen.
Ja, ja, ich hätte gerne das Tim-Tim.
So, warum kann ich auf keine Ahnung, warum ich Tim-Tim auf dem iPhone keinen neuen Ordner im E-Mail-Klient anlegen kann, wissen wir nicht.
Wissen wir nicht.
Mit dem iPhone will er die Ordner anlegen?
Na, warum legt er sie nicht mit seinem Mail-App an und dann ist es gut?
Weil er es auf dem iPhone machen möchte. Also, ich meine, ist doch verständlich.
Ja, aber man muss nicht wirklich jede Funktionalität auf so ein kleines Device raufpacken. Das ist schon…
Also, wäre jetzt auch nicht so schwer.
Aber es ist wie beim iPod und im iTunes managst du deine Bibliothek, auf dem iPod hörst du es an. Auf dem iPhone benutzt du deine Folder, auf dem Mac riechst du sie ein, und dann steckst du sie hin und her.
Ja, aber die Menge der Symphonienfunktionen wird schon wachsen. Also, ich meine, das Verschieben von mir geht ja mittlerweile auch.
Was sinnvoll ist, ist so eine Sache.
Copy and Paste, warum es keinen Copy and Paste gibt, also dass es wirklich eine Unverschämtheit hat.
Hat ja noch nie gebraucht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es braucht, aber ich hab eine These, warum sie sich Zeit lassen.
Ich hab schon ungefähr 840.000 Mal. Ich meine, sobald man da ein Textfeld hat, wo Information drinsteht, die man in dieses Textfeld reinhaben möchte, Ja, aber wie würdest du es tun? Wie ich es tun würde? Ich bin nicht Apple.
Genau, das ist nämlich der Punkt. Dass das alle haben wollen, das kann ich ja verstehen. Die Frage ist, die lassen sich bestimmt die Köppe heiß laufen bei Apple gerade. Weil wenn sie die Entscheidung nämlich einmal fällen, dann werden sie auf zehn Jahre nicht los.
Da war doch letztens das. Sie arbeiten dran, aber es liegt auf der Prioritätenliste nicht ganz oben. Irgendso ein Spruchkarten.
Es gibt so viele andere sichtliche Sachen und so. Die werden es bringen.
Es gibt auch andere Sachen, die wichtig sind und die werden es hoffentlich bringen und sie werden hoffentlich eine ziemlich grandiose Lösung dafür haben.
Dann machen sie es wieder so cool, dass alle Fanboys bei der Keynote schreien. Er wird einfach Copy und Paste auf dem iPhone und alle werden so jauchts.
Und jeder, nicht Apple Fanboy, wird sagen, aha.
Aber wir sind ja eigentlich die Fanboys.
Nein, also ich werde wie ein kleines Mädchen kreischen, wenn ich Copy und Paste auf meinem iPhone habe.
Echt?
Ja.
Aber dann bitte live auf Mobile Max. Genau, da steuern wir nochmal richtig aus. Ja, bla, das ist mir jetzt zu viel Detail hier. Ich spule mal vor. Kurze Fragen haben große Chancen. Aber so lange Textblöcke, Leute, das geht echt gar nicht. Ja, wir sind schon wieder weit über allem, was auch immer, aber ihr wollt es ja immer länger haben. Und für die anderen, es kommt jetzt von uns nur noch Antworten.
Wenn euch das zu lang ist, bestellt man das mit deutscher oder amerikanischer Tastatur? Macht du, wie es willst. Du kannst das auch umschalten im Nachhinein.
Man kann jetzt im Apple Store, im Deutschen auch, irgendwie mit amerikanischer oder englischer. Ist das englische Tastatur oder amerikanisch eigentlich?
Englisch international.
Weil es ist ein Unterschied, ne?
Ich sag euch, warum man eine deutsche haben will. Weißt du, wie die Return-Taste auf einer amerikanischen Tastatur aussieht?
Die ist ein bisschen schmaler. Ne, breiter sogar, ne?
Ja, die geht nicht über zwei Wein.
Sondern die ist hier so.
Ja, aber ich glaub, das ist eine international English Keyboard. Und das hat die genauso wie... Ja?
Habt ihr von den L-Tastaturen? Ich muss mal kurz einkippen.
Er redet aber von der amerikanischen Tastatur. Und den will man nicht benutzen.
Na ja, wenn er programmiert ist und eckige Klammern braucht, kann schon sein.
Außerdem gibt er hier noch seinen Twitter-Account-Preis.
Wenn Objective-C programmiert ist, brauchst du die eckige Klammer andauernd. Ich kann das schon nachvollziehen.
Auch nochmal für unsere Twitter-Runde.
Nee, aber ich will kurz über den Dell-Tastature-Fuck-Up erzählen. Die haben irgendwie Laptops rausgebracht in Europa. Weil bei denen ist ja die linke Schifftaste ein bisschen breiter bei den Amis. Und in Europa ist da ja noch das größere und kleinere Zeichen. Und irgendwie haben sie sich da verkackt und haben die gesamte untere Tastatur-Reihe, also von Y bis M und alles, was daneben liegt, um eins nach rechts verschoben eingebaut.
Das habe ich auch gesehen. Wobei da hat die Erklärung mit der extra Taste und so, das macht Sinn. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wie es dazu kommen konnte, aber das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund.
Also ich habe es auch nur gemutmaßt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr witzig. So ein richtiger Hardware-Fuck-Up. Aber sie tauschen doch alles aus und waren auch nicht alle Modelle, sondern nur so ein paar bestimmte sind da durchgeflutscht.
Asus hat auf dem IEE-PC was ähnlich Schlimmes geschafft. Und zwar haben die oben die oberste Tastenreihe, also mit der Zahlenreihe, da fehlt diese Häuschen-Taste, sodass die 1-Taste um 1 nach links verschoben ist.
Häuschen-Taste?
Also die Taste, die zu links neben der 1 ist, die fehlt bei IEE.
Carrot heißt das.
Das heißt Häuschen? Das heißt Häuschen und Carrot. Das ist ein Carré.
Das ist Französisch. Ein Carré, ein Akzent, ein Graf.
Ich hab in der Nähe von Moskau gewohnt.
Was heißt dann Carré auf Russisch?
Matryoshka. Dorm, weil das heißt Haus.
Hier gibt's Lob. Es gibt auch Lob. So ist es ja nicht. Die Länge passt, das Halbwissen, das Apple-Fanboy-Sein, immer weiter so.
Okay, und irgendwann statt mit dem Ersteiner, der ein Prozent den Mac-Nutzer, die...
Er hat Probleme.
Ich glaube, das sind mehr als ein Prozent.
Ob wir eine Stelle kennen, wo wir die Probleme eskalieren kann, haben wir schon vorher darüber gesprochen, kennen wir nicht.
Wie wäre es mit einem Streifzug durch die Rumors-Sites? Das wäre wirklich mal was.
Machen Blog auf und Apple-Haters-Blog. Es gibt jetzt einen Linux-Haters-Blog. Ist nicht neu, gab's wahrscheinlich schon länger. Ganz amüsant.
Basiert das dann aber hoffentlich nicht auf Open-Source-Software?
Na ja, ich geh da jetzt nicht drauf ein.
Ein bisschen was über Netzwerke, ein bisschen Liebe.
Streifzug durch die Rumors-Sites. Ach ja, genau.
Meint er jetzt die Rumors-Sites an sich oder die Daten, die gerade dort berichtet werden?
Na er schreibt die besseren, die schlechten und die richtig guten. Von daher denke ich, mal geht es eher um die Sites.
Verstehe. Also ich lese ja immer, wie heißt die? Muss ich jetzt mal kurz mein Dings klicken. Genau macsurfer.com. Das ist diese riesen, elendig lange Liste ohne Grafik, ohne Schnickschnack. Also die haben Werbung.
Den gibt es auch schon ewig.
Den gibt es auch schon ewig. Sieht richtig scheiße aus eigentlich. Aber die sind so ein Sammelsurium an allen möglichen Links.
Also wenn man wirklich keine News verpassen will, aber auch wirklich gar keine, dann gibt es echt nichts besseres als Mac Surfer. Das kann ich wirklich bestätigen. Also wie die das machen, ist mir auch vollkommen unklar. Also wie deren Aggregator funktioniert, das muss ein Wahnsinniger sein.
Ich glaube, der hat irgendwie so...
Daily alles sortiert nach Themen.
Er hat bestimmt so eine Google-Suche, wo er macht Apple, Steve, OST, Leopard und er nimmt immer die Dinge und sortiert die ein bisschen durch.
Du guckst gerade so, Max, als ob du das nicht kennst. Darf ich dir das mal kurz zeigen?
Ich kenne das tatsächlich nicht.
Mac Surfer's Headline News. Das ist sozusagen hier nach Kategorien. Das geht hier mit Apple Macintosh.
Ich glaube, ich weiß warum ich das nicht kenne.
US 10 und so. Das ist so richtig Space durchgehend und so weiter. Aber es ist manchmal, gerade wenn so, was weiß ich, Apple stellt irgendwie eine generelle Strategie vor und du hast mal echt ein Interesse, hier so zum Beispiel, als sie diese Hardware-Bude gekauft haben, PL Semi und so. Da habe ich über Mac Surfer die wirklich interessanten Artikel gefunden.
Weil er hat auch eine bunte Mischung. Also ich glaube schon, er geht über die Suchmaschinen daran an die Artikel oder?
Genau, er schaut sie schon mal an und sortiert sie gleich ein. Und vielleicht sind es auch mehrere Leute. Pressreleases, dann auch Computerindustrie allgemein und Finanzen und so weiter. Also es ist extrem viel drin. Und dann gibt es auch noch eine lange, lange, lange Liste, was sie eigentlich alles tracken. Und dann sozusagen für jede Site auch noch die aktuellen Headlines. Also das ist wirklich der Knaller.
Wenn man überhaupt nicht wissen will, was gerade aktuell passiert ist, dann kann ich nur Crazy Apple Rumors Sites empfehlen. Die einzige Rumors Site, die ich kenne, die jemals direkt bei Apple erwähnt worden ist, im Newsbereich, mit einem frei erfundenen Zitat. Ach genau, da ging es darum, dass als Elgor jetzt ins Board von Apple gewählt wurde, jetzt ist auch schon eine Weile her, dass da Bush auf dem Recount bestanden hätte. crazyapplerumors.com crazyapplerumors.com Was ist eigentlich dieses Vimeo?
Ist das jetzt neu?
Das ist ein Videodienst, der im Gegensatz zu YouTube relativ hohe Videoqualität liefert. Den gibt es schon ein bisschen länger.
Stimmt. Na, ich sehe den, also kommt gerade so richtig durch, seit so ein paar Wochen.
Der bietet teilweise auch HD-Qualität.
Ja, okay, kann ich noch gar nicht, lese ich nicht. Ich bin da auch noch ganz klassisch. Meiner Meinung nach, die beste Coverage, appleinsider.com ist eigentlich...
Für Rumors jetzt, ja...
.ist so für Rumors eigentlich die beste Site.
Ja, sonst lese ich gerne Ars Technica. Die haben alles, aber die haben...
Ars Technica hat viel Inside, immer so, Inside-Artikel.
Aber die haben nachgelassen, finde ich ganz schön.
Und, also weiß ich, so die ganzen Rumors-Sites lese ich mittlerweile gar nicht mehr. Das ist mir alles zu aufgeregt mittlerweile. Ich verlasse mich da dann auf die relativ klassischen Quellen. Also Leo vom FSCK-Log, der Wahnsinnige, der ja auch jedes Thema hat. Ungefähr drei Sekunden bevor Steve Jobs ist, weiß er, steht es schon bei FSCK-Log.
Wobei man ihn wirklich nicht als Rumors-Site...
Nee, also das ist...
Sondern eher ganz im Gegenteil. Also gerade den Gerüchten gegenüber ist er dann immer ein schöner Filter.
Genau, aber langsam werde ich selber da auch eher konservativ und sage, ich möchte Apple-Produkte sehen, die da stehen und die ich im Laden kaufen kann. Und vorher glaube ich nicht, dass das nicht geht.
Weil wir auch schon wissen, dass die ganzen Rumors immer in die Hose gehen. Also oft. Und wenn, dann ist es so kurz vor, dann ist es zwei Tage ewig.
Ja, aber es gibt Zals, die haben einen extrem guten Track-Rock-Hot und da glaube ich, Apple Insider trifft es ganz gut.
9to5 Mac war früher auch... Die haben irgendwann mal in Lied richtig gelegen. Also irgendwann hat jeder mal einen Treffer gehabt. Aber es geht doch relativ viel unter im Wasser.
Ja, aber dann werden die Rumors ja auch so schwammig, da kannst du dann nur noch einen Hit haben. Demnächst wird es ein neues MacBook Pro geben. Ach so, jetzt wissen wir mehr. Ist ja oft so, ne?
Aber wo wir jetzt eh gerade bei Mac-Sites sind, vielleicht mal weg von den Rumors. Macintosh-Sites, die jetzt mehr so Review, Non-Rumor, Quality-Content, was sind da so eure Tipps?
Und dann die Links, die da kommen.
tuaf.com, so unofficial Apple Weblog, finde ich ganz nett. Dann natürlich die üblichen Gadgets-Sites, Gizmodo und sowas, die ja auch alle bekannte Apple-Fanboys sind. Nicht nur Mac haben. Klar, AskTechnica, gerne mal.
AskTechnica ist immer gut für tiefe Reviews, wobei es auch echt viel Zeug ist.
Das ist viel Zeug, aber die dann eben auch den neuen iPod, irgendwann haben die mal einen iPod-Sensor mit dem Auto drüber gefahren, um ihn zu testen und alles so eine Späße. Also die testen dann auch relativ ausführlich, das lohnt sich schon. Was gibt es noch? mcnotes.de? Auch ziemlich gut?
Ja, im deutschen Bereich. McNotes muss man auf jeden Fall mal lobend erwähnen. Sind ja echt fleißig, die Jungs. Haupt mich echt um, wie die das machen. Vor allem haben die auch echt viel Zeit für Reviews und Pipapo. Also sehr vergleichbar mit FSC-Klog.
Ah, FSC-Klog mag ich, finde ich noch ein bisschen, den finde ich noch ein bisschen knackiger, ein bisschen mehr auf den Punkt. Also die von den Notes gehen auch gerne manchmal ins Schwammige.
Ja gut, aber sie decken so im Wesentlichen eigentlich denselben News-Bereich ab.
Was sind eigentlich aus Mac-News geworden? Das war ja früher so vor 5, 6 Jahren der Standard-Anlaufpunkt überhaupt. Ich glaube, die haben auch immer noch eine große Community, aber irgendwie lesen tut die, glaube ich. Also ich kenne niemanden, der die noch liest.
Tja, weiß ich nicht. Da wird viel... Da wird viel Press-Release verarbeitet. Also das ist halt so eine klassische News-Site, die ist natürlich jetzt bei uns so, in diesen ganzen rumorgeilen Fanboy-Szene kommt sowas ja schon wieder langweilig.
Das letzte Mal, dass ich die gelesen habe, waren die noch rot.
Ja, ich glaube, die sind sehr umtriebig, die haben auch viel. Ich habe mal eine Weile den Feed verfolgt. Das ist dann wegen irgendwas bei mir rausgeflogen. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr ganz genau. Allerdings linken sie gerade auf diese großartige Fond-Konferenz. Habt ihr die heute schon gehört? Ich habe die schon gestern gesehen. Du bist so Internet.
Ich bin so weit vorne.
Die tolle Fond-Konferenz College Humor. Eine großartige Zeit. Die Jungs sind ja so dermaßen cool. Kann man echt nur empfehlen. Um jetzt mal ganz vom Thema abzukommen. Einfach supergeile, wirklich, wirklich...
Da muss ich wieder sprechen, Tim.
Doch, da sind wirklich gute Sachen drin.
Sehr gute Sachen dabei, aber nicht alles.
Es ist nicht alles gut, aber es sind hervorragende Sachen drin.
Du bist doch ein Fanboy.
Von denen auf jeden Fall. Fond-Konferenz, College Humor, das gibt du mal ins Internet ein. Dann habt ihr was zu lachen.
Du kannst auch so einen Link da machen.
Ich werde einen Link machen, aber für die Leute, die nicht immer links klicken oder wenn ich es vergesse. Wie auch immer. Ich wollte jetzt auch noch mal meine Lieblingswebseiten-Tipps sagen. Erstmal die älteste und meiner Meinung nach auch nach wie vor mit allerbeste Macintosh-Publikation überhaupt im Internet ist titbits.com. Die gab es schon vor dem Web. Also Titbits habe ich schon gelesen. Da gab es das Web nicht und da gab es das alles. Also da gab es zumindest nicht News im Web, sondern da gab es erst mal so ein bisschen Web. Weiß man ja, early days. Titbits war am Anfang ein Newsletter. Gibt es auch immer noch als Newsletter, gibt es aber vor allem auch im Web und ist sagenhafter Stil. Also diese ganze Titbits-Community von eingeschworenen, alteingesessenen Mechanos, die machen auch eine große Zahl von Podcasts, Mac-Notables, Mac-Voices. Da stecken so einige Leute drin. Und vor allem berichten sie immer mit einer geschichtlichen Tiefe, weil sie einfach von Anfang an bei Mac dabei waren. Also die haben schon in den 80ern Macintosh-Berichtung gemacht, die du jetzt auf anderen Sites so nicht findest.
Also mit Titbits muss ich aber auf der anderen Seite sagen, bin ich leider nie so richtig warm geworden.
Ich kann das nur empfehlen. Das mag jetzt nicht jedem gefallen. Aber bei Titbits gibt es immer mal wieder so schöne, völlig ausführliche Sachen, was auch noch sehr interessant ist, was wenige wissen. Titbits ist auch E-Book-Publisher geworden. Das heißt, sie haben so eine Serie, die heißt Take Control, und berichten immer wieder zu so kleinen Sachen. Haben sie solche Microbooks? Das heißt dann so, was weiß ich, Take Control auf.Mac oder Take Control auf iPhoto und so eine Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, ob iPhoto wirklich dabei war, aber jetzt mal als Beispiel. Die haben eine ganze Reihe einzelner Technologien herausgenommen, wo dann halt einer ein E-Book zuschreibt. Das verkaufen sie als PDF. Das ist dann so wie ein Buch, aber eben sehr beschränkt auf einen bestimmten Aspekt. Das heißt, wenn man irgendein bestimmtes Programm, ein Protokoll, einen Teil des Betriebssystems, irgendein Interesse hat, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit recht groß, dass man da fündig wird. Das machen halt die anderen gar nicht. Ansonsten, Dennis hat es gerade erwähnt, der andere Klassiker ist halt Macintosh. Seit Anfang an, also es gab mal eine Zeit, da gab es eigentlich nur Tidbits und Macintosh. Und die News über Apple, also das, was wir heute von diesen ganzen anderen Sites runter zitieren und was sich auch so im New-Romo-Bereich bewegt, kam alles auf Macintosh. Macintosh gibt es immer noch. Macintosh hat eine bemerkenswerte redaktionelle Arbeit. Also sie verarbeiten vor allem unglaublich viel Feedback. Sagen wir mal, jetzt kommt ein neues Produkt raus. Macbook, neuste Generation. Dann hast du da erstmal natürlich Berichterstattung, Dokumentation, was ist das alles. Dann kaufen die Leute das, haben die ersten Probleme. Dann sammeln sie das ganze E-Mail-Feedback zusammen. Und du hast dann wirklich zu jedem einzelnen Produkt eine mehrseitige Feedback-Sammlung von Leuten, die halt Macintosh geschrieben haben über ihre Erfahrungen, wie sie was gefixt haben. Viel, viel, viel wertvoller als irgendwelche Foren oder so, weil es halt wirklich von dem Macintosh-Redaktionsteam immer wieder eingeplägt wird. Eine riesige Ressource, auch gerade, wenn man so Sachen hat, die so älter sind.
Hat schon ein bisschen Support-Ähnlichkeit eher.
Dann gibt es ja auch noch so MacFixit, das ist auch noch so ein ganz altes Ding, die sich ganz explizit auf eben, wie der Name schon sagt, so auf Fehlerbehebung konzentrieren. Ja, und dann würde mir jetzt noch hier Mac OS 10 Hints, ist auch eine super Ressource, wo am laufenden Meter echt praktische Sachen, nicht immer alles neu, aber das meiste ist wirklich hilfreich rausfallen.
Aber die haben ihre Datenbank irgendwann dicht gemacht. Man kann nicht mehr alten Tipps suchen.
Man muss dafür zahlen, wenn man alte Sachen zahlt. Man kann die nur noch neu lesen, wenn sie eine gewisse Zeit lang sind. Schon von einer ganzen Weile.
Ja, na gut, ich denke das reicht jetzt erstmal, oder?
Wenn man bedenkt, dass wir es mit Rumors anfangen.
Vor allem haben wir ja noch ein paar Punkte.
Genau, haben wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Die werden wahrscheinlich hinten schneller mehr, als wir abarbeiten können vorne.
Wir nähern uns übrigens den drei Stunden.
Ach, der Scheiß.
Ja, es war, aber heute ist auch wirklich mal eine Menge los. Können ja mal gucken. Ihr sagt uns dann, Leute, wie das angekommen ist, wenn wir jetzt hier so viel Feedback abarbeiten. Bla, bla, bla. So, was haben wir denn jetzt hier noch? Ich bin zu doof für Programm-Sinken. Ist mir zu kompliziert. Weiter.
Der Programm-Sync beim iPhone, der ist aber wirklich ein bisschen merkwürdig. Er schreibt, dass er es nicht schafft, die vom iPhone zurück in iTunes zu bekommen. Ich habe genau das umgekehrte Problem. Ich fragte jedes Mal, willst du die Programme vom iPhone zurück in iTunes überspielen? Die Programme, die ich auf meinem iPhone habe. Dann sag ich entweder Ja oder Nein. Was er auf jeden Fall macht, ist in die andere Richtung. Was ich in iTunes habe, spielt er zurück aufs iPhone. Das heißt, ich hab zum Beispiel in iTunes ein Programm runtergeladen, spielts dann rüber aufs iPhone, probierts dann aus, sage alles klar, ist ein scheiß Programm, löscht das wieder, schließt das wieder an, synchronisiere das nächste Mal, spielt mir iTunes wieder das Programm rüber. Statt sich einfach mal gemerkt zu haben, der wird schon seine Gründe haben, das gelöscht zu haben.
Verstehe, Next Version will fixet, oder?
Und die Datensicherung dauert auch ewig. Mit 5Vault, das ist, ich hatte mal, ja?
Mich würde mal interessieren, ob ihr 5Vault benutzt.
Ich benutze es, aber auch alle meine größeren Daten, wie Musik, Movies, Zeugs, Beton, Kram, landen nicht in meinem 5Vault, sondern ich hab eine getrennte Partition. Meine Boot-Partition ist jetzt irgendwie 32 Gig inzwischen groß. Und mein 5Vault selbst, mein Home ist, ich weiß nicht, 3 oder 4 Gigabyte groß, weil alles andere, was ich runterlade, landet auf der anderen Partition, sonst wär das viel zu fett.
Also ich hatte 5Vault früher mal im Laufen, hat es wirklich so, wie von Apple empfohlen, das gesamte Home-Verzeichnis einfach verschlüsselt. Funktioniert soweit ziemlich gut. Nee, es macht den Rechner natürlich deutlich langsamer. Das war zumindest bei dem so. Das ist sicherlich der Grund, warum du das alles in andere Orner spielst. Und zum Zweiten ist es, was wirklich ganz furchtbar ist, dieses 5V-Volumen wächst und man schrumpft nicht automatisch wieder. Hinten und wieder beim Runterfahren fragt der Rechner mal, hey, dein 5V-Volumen, da ist so viel Platz drauf frei, soll ich das mal ein bisschen shrinken? Dann schrinkt er da so eine Ebene.
Das ist aber jetzt anders. Mit 10,5 fragt er nicht mehr, sondern macht es automatisch, weil sich ja auch das Format geändert hat.
Geht jetzt schneller, ja? Also ich hab das mit 10,4 das letzte Mal gemacht oder so. Und dann das nächste Problem war, dass ich irgendwann mal Probleme hatte auf dem 5 Volt Volume, dass das nämlich korrupt geworden ist. Und dass es kein Programm gibt, mit dem man diese reparieren konnte. Also das ging nicht mit einem Festplattendienstprogramm, das konnte das nicht mehr. Und da hab ich dann wirklich langsam Angst um meine Daten bekommen.
Das ist auch mein totaler Horror.
Und dann hab ich mit Carbon kopiert. Ich konnte auch nicht wieder den 5 Volt deaktivieren Button klicken, weil da hat er mir irgendwann gesagt, hey bei der Überprüfung deines 5 Volt Volumes ist ein Fehler aufgetreten. Das ist der Grund, warum ich es gerne gelöscht hätte. Oder wieder rückgängig gemacht hätte. Können wir so nicht, musste er erst reparieren. Wie es zu reparieren war, konnte mir auch niemand sagen. Das hat er vielleicht da nicht hingekriegt. Auf jeden Fall ist da mit Carbon Copykloner, hab ich dann wieder die Daten auf dem geöffneten 5 Volt Volumen auf eine externe Platte geschoben und hab's dann wieder zurückgespielt. Das hat dann Gott sei Dank funktioniert. Und seitdem ist mein Rechner wieder deutlich schneller.
Also ich denke, Apple wird über kurz oder lang nicht drum rumkommen, wirklich eine richtige Festplatten-Verschlüsselung anzubieten. Und nicht nur diese Home Directory in verschlüsselten Disküben.
Vielleicht mach ich mir meinen Spaß, und wenn mein Rechner dann wieder kommt aus der Reparatur und ich ihn sowieso platten muss...
Machst du einfach mal 5 Volt.
Mach das mal TrueCrypt stattdessen. Gibt's ja noch diese Lösung, wo man die gesamte Festplatte mit verschlüsseln kann. Kann man ja mal eine Woche lang ausprobieren.
Okay, na wenn du dir das erlauben kannst auf der Büchse, dass mal alles weg ist. Aber der Punkt ist, ich finde, es muss wirklich in die Firmware rein. Also das muss wirklich etwas sein, dass wirklich jedes Bit verschlüsselt ist. Das müssen sie einfach bringen können. Niemand könnte es besser machen als Apple. Ich meine, sie haben wirklich die vollständige Kontrolle über die ganze Hardware. Wenn sie mehr Firmware-Support dafür brauchen, dann bauen sie das einfach ein. Und hatten wir schon ein paar Mal ZDFS und so weiter. Wäre da auch, sagen wir mal, die richtige Basis, wenn sie wirklich auf ZDFS gehen und die Möglichkeit haben, Krypto damit zu machen, dann sollen sie das bitte auch im Boot-Volume machen. Denn es gibt immer wieder so Sachen, wo man eben nicht weiß. Hier, Time Machine zum Beispiel, File Vault, da sagt er dir, ich kann dann nur die Dateien, wenn du da gerade eingeloggt bist und so. Was heißt das? Wenn ich nicht eingeloggt bin, macht er dann keinen Backup? Oder macht er dann ein Backup von dem ganzen Image? Aber wenn ich eingeloggt bin, macht er ein Backup von den Dateien?
Ein File Vault machte halt nur ein Backup, wenn du dich ausloggst.
Das heißt, wenn ich die ganze Zeit eingeloggt bin, habe ich keine Backups mehr?
Nicht von einem File Vault, ja.
Das heißt, ja, aber das ist so wirklich für mich das. Ich bin immer eingeloggt.
Und du kannst auch nicht drin brausen und so. Es geht nicht.
Genau. Und das ist für mich eigentlich das Feature. Das heißt, das passt halt nicht.
File Vault ist...
Schön, dass es da ist, aber es löst nicht alle Probleme.
Wenn man die Sicherheit unbedingt braucht, dann...
Dann hast du schon mal den Arsch gerettet.
Es ist natürlich gut. Und ich denke, wenn man auf Reisen ist, sollte man auf jeden Fall einen Rechner haben, der...
Zumindest einen Teil der Daten verschlüsselt hat.
Genau. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig mit demselben Datenset durch die Gegend. Weil es gibt so viele Länder, die jetzt irgendwie so auf dumme Ideen kommen mit Ah, sie haben einen Computer dabei, da schauen wir nochmal drauf. Und das sieht ja interessant aus, den nehmen wir doch mal mit und so. Also Israel ist da ganz gut. Kanada, USA haben alle jetzt schon irgendwie solche Bestrebungen.
Ist man da nicht auch verpflichtet, das Passwort im Zweifelsfall rauszudrücken?
Wenn du mit einem anderen User reinmachst, einfach 30 User, dann wird er ja kaum sagen, du musst jetzt alle User einloggen, sagst du geht nicht, da kaut er mal...
Ja, weil wir wissen, es gibt Situationen und es gibt auch so Organisationen, die, wenn sie das Passwort von dir haben wollen, da finden die dann auch schon einen Weg. Und denen will man dann auch nicht gehen. Also es ist so eine Sache.
Apropos Passwort, nächste Frage. OnePassWD.
Ja, OnePassWord wird gefragt, was wir davon halten. Haben wir schon mal gesagt, also ich hab das schon mal gesagt. Ich kann da jetzt auch nicht sehr viel Neues zu sagen, außer dass ich finde, dass das ganz praktisch ist. Ich hab mich allerdings immer noch nicht dazu durchgegangen, es zu kaufen. Aber ich bin so kurz davor. Ich find's noch zu teuer.
Ich find's dafür, ich hab's, mir ist es irgendwann mal hinterhergeflogen, mit Bunchs und Bundle. Mac heißt, glaub ich. Hab's mir daraufhin mal ein bisschen näher angeguckt. Bin so, halt die Grundidee halt ich für super besonders. Ich benutze. Und jetzt gerade auch, wenn's dann eine kostenlose ist, wird ja von One Password eine Lösung fürs iPhone geben, die dann hoffentlich auch endlich mal Passwordverschlüsselung aufs iPhone bringt. Aber ich bin nur so ein Teil...
Es gibt keine Keychain auf dem iPhone, ne?
Es gibt keine Keychain auf dem iPhone.
Das ist halt echtes Drama vielleicht.
Das ist fast noch wichtiger als Copy und Paste. Ja, viel. Und vor allen Dingen keine Synchronisierung der Keychains. Das wäre also, dass ich die Passwörter, die ich auf meinem Mac habe, auf dem iPhone hätte.
Ja, aber Mobile Media das anbietet.
Mobile Media bietet das bestimmt nicht fürs iPhone.
Naja, nicht fürs iPhone, aber grundsätzlich haben sie das eingebaut.
Und One Password halte ich... Ich find's... Ich nutze es nicht, weil es ist irgendwie... Es integriert sich nicht gut in Safari, es integriert sich nicht gut in Firefox, es ist mir... Wenn ich das Programm offen habe, habe ich auch automatisch... Also ich kann... Und das ist mir wirklich negativ aufgefallen, wenn ich das Programm starte und ich habe das Passwort für One Password im Schlüsselbund gespeichert, brauche jemand nur das Programm zu starten und kann all meine Passwörter einsehen, ohne nochmal irgendeinen Passwort-Sicherheitshalber eingeben zu müssen. Also Schlüsselbund besser. So richtig glücklich bin ich nicht.
Gut, was ich hier... Hier wird noch gefragt, was wir von my.onepassword.com halten, dass man die Password bei dir auf dem Server speichert. Das wusste ich noch gar nicht, dass das geht. Security and freedom together at last. Naja, das schauen wir uns lieber nochmal genauer an, bevor wir da eine Aussage zu machen.
Ich hab's nicht getestet, also ich weiß es nicht.
Gut, da muss man nicht nur testen, da muss man vor allem mal drüber nachdenken, was ihr Modell hier jetzt eigentlich ist. Das können wir jetzt aber so schnell nicht abhaken. Schauen wir nochmal. 10 vom Server. Das ist wieder zu lang.
Da geht's darum Open LDAP und Groupware-Kalender und so weiter.
Das sind ganz viele Sachen. Macht mal einfach Fragen, kurze Sachen. 5Volt, wie speicherhungrig ist das? Soll es die Performance drücken? Ja, tut es, haben wir schon gesagt.
Speicherhungrig braucht der Platte so viel wie die Daten sonst auch. Also es ist nicht größer oder kleiner.
Arbeitsspeicher.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er hier von RAM redet oder von Platte.
Aber Arbeitsspeicher brauchst du auch nicht unbedingt mehr.
Genau.
Wenn ein Programm beendet wird, stehen weniger Arbeitsspeicher frei zur Verfügung als vor dem Programm.
Wenn das Programm halt irgendwie Gigabyte Daten von der Platte legt, dann liegen die halt im Cache. Das ist das, was beim Activity-Monitor vorher grün war und dann nicht mehr grün ist, weil es halt als Cache benutzt wird.
Genau, das kann dann wiederverwendet werden.
Das wird aber frei, sobald...
Zu sagen, was wirklich frei ist, ist gar nicht so einfach bei diesen modernen Speicherverwaltungen, weil die einfach sehr viel Caching machen. Genau.
Aber das Schlimmste ist, dass eher was Gutes ist.
Festplatten-Defragmentierung lohnt sich das oder doch nicht? Antwort braucht man nicht mehr.
Also seit 10.2 gibt's ja in Half S Plus und mit dem...
Da sind ja schon drei drin.
Nee, es kam mit dem Journaling, das kam noch schon so als halbes Feature. Das war schon, 10.2 ist auf jeden Fall ewig her. Und das defragmentiert selber, aber nur, wenn die Datei gelesen wird und wenn sie kleiner ist als 20 MB, sonst nicht. Und aus mehr als vier oder fünf Teilen besteht sonst auch nicht. Ich hab mir den Code im Kern mal angeguckt und gepatcht, dass bei mir bis alle Dateien, egal wie groß die sind, defragmentiert werden. Und dann wird es aber schon langsamer, weil dann muss die 200 MB oder wie groß das Ding auch immer ist irgendwie kompensiert werden.
Das Hauptproblem ist ja wirklich mit diesen kleinen Dateien.
So sieht es aus. Die haben das schon nicht schlecht gemacht mit diesen 20 MB, das hat schon Sinn.
Also ich setze keine Defragmentierungssoftware oder sowas ein, weiß auch gar nicht, gibt es da überhaupt irgendwas, was aber jetzt zum Beispiel...
Na klar, wie heißt der Disk Warrior, der macht das doch auch. Der räumt auch einmal ordentlich auf.
Nee, der Disk Warrior macht keine Defragmentierung. Der Disk Warrior macht nur ein neues Directory. Der scannt den Platteninhalt und baut dir ein neues Verzeichnis zusammen, testet das, lässt es dich testen, du kannst das so virtuell marken.
Entschuldigung, wenn du was reparierst, aber er kann noch auch defragmentieren. Das sind doch zwei Sachen.
Also was... Also was ich auf jeden Fall...
Oder verwechseln wir uns jetzt?
Na gut sein. Also was ich öfters mache, oder nicht öfters mache, sondern gelegentlich, wenn ich mal ganz, ganz viel Zeit habe und ich weiß, was zu tun ist, so alle anderthalb Jahre oder sowas, dann spiel ich mit Carbon Copycloner alle Daten meiner Platte auf eine externe Platte.
Und schieb sie danach zurück.
Und spiel sie danach wieder zurück, womit sie quasi defragmentiert sind. Und das macht schon einen Unterschied.
Also was ich noch einen Tipp geben kann, ist mir immer passiert, ich saß im Zug, wollte irgendwie mir meinen von der DVD, nee, Quatsch, Entschuldigung, meinen runtergeladenen Movie angucken. Also eine DVD hab ich per BitTorrent runtergeladen und der DVD-Player ruckelt wie Sau. Ich saß im Zug und wollte den Filmguckern nichts zu tun. Und ich dachte, das kann ja mal nicht sein, dass mein Rechner es nicht schafft, diese DVD abzuspielen. Und irgendwann kam mir dann die Idee, dass er es nicht schafft, schnell genug von einer Platte zu laden. Und da hab ich die gesamte DVD, also 4 GB, einfach gesagt, kopier dich mal, so macht man Duplikat. Hab das Original weggeschmissen und dann konnte der DVD-Player das abspielen. Das heißt, das BitTorrent hat das damals so zerstreut auf der Platte gespeichert, dass der DVD-Player es nicht geschafft hat, schnell genug diese Daten wieder einzulesen. Wahrscheinlich weil er nicht genug irgendwie gecached hat, weil die keine Ahnung, es ist nicht abgeschrieben.
Aber wir reden von einem Image auf Festplatte, nicht von einer DVD selber.
Wir reden von Files auf einer Festplatte, ja. Und also fragmentieren oder defragmentieren ist schon wichtig, gerade bei BitTorrent. Aber zur Not reicht es auch von der Hand einfach nochmal, wenn man fertig ist, Duplikat anlegen, das alte löschen und dann ist es wieder gerade.
Ja, 100 GB frei haben und man hat echt mal einen entspannten Computer. Ja, also Disk Warrior, ich hab eben nochmal nachgeguckt, macht nicht defragmentieren. Disk Warrior fast, das ist eine Besonderheit von Disk Warrior. Das ist auch der Hauptgrund, warum es immer besser funktioniert hat, als diese ganzen Norton-Repair-Scheiße, die nämlich immer irgendwelche Bugs und Code hatten und dir dann am Ende nämlich dein kaputtes Fallsystem noch kaputter gemacht hat.
Also Norton-Repair hat mir Festplatten zerstört, die vorher noch liefen.
Hatt ich auch.
Ja, aber im Disk Warrior auch. Also ich hatte mit Disk Repair-Programmen noch nie Glück.
Ich hatte mit Disk Warrior extrem viel Glück und ich kann jedem nur Disk Warrior empfehlen, das auszuprobieren, sollte wirklich mal was im Arsch sein. Ich habe, glaube ich, in neun von zehn Fällen immer Erfolg gehabt und in dem zehnten Fall ist es zumindest danach nicht schlechter gewesen als vorher.
Disk Warrior habe ich auch schon gute Geschichten von gehört.
Weil, also nochmal, was er macht ist, er zieht sich den ganzen Inhalt der Platte rein, analysiert den auf Basis der noch verfügbaren Direkturistrukturen, aber auch auf Basis der Strukturen auf der Platte und baut sich ein neues Verzeichnis zusammen. Packt das in einen unbenutzten Bereich der Platte und ersetzt dann einfach den alten Direkturikram durch den neuen Direkturikram. Und das ist sozusagen sein Ansatz, weil das Problem bei zerstörtem Fallsystem ist primär Direkturie und damit haben sie viel Erfolg. Also kann man wirklich sehr empfehlen.
Werdet man, welche Möglichkeit hat man als regulärer Nutzer des T-Mobile-Infos im europäischen Ausland Online-Dienste preiswert zu nutzen? Ich würde sagen, die Antwort ist keine.
Weil es genetloggt. Und Prepaid gibt es halt nicht. ist der Grund, warum man sein Telefon in Italien kaufen möchte. Haben wir uns doch gar nicht berichtet, ne? Der ist ja iPhone jetzt in Belgien doch nicht ganz so frei ist, wie wir letztes Mal dachten.
Ist es nicht?
Ich dachte so.
Also ich hab gehört, dass die Verkäufer behaupten, es wäre ein Netlock oder ein Landeslock, aber das ist in der Praxis funktioniert.
Apple behauptet es auch und es funktioniert auch in der Praxis. Allerdings ist irgendein komischer Weirdo locker da drin. Man muss den iTunes-Store irgendwie einmal auf Belgien umschalten und dann geht's irgendwie. Das hat jemand in so einem Blog berichtet. Ich hab's nicht, haben wir das schon erzählt. Tatsache ist, in Italien gibt's auch, richtig offiziell, Apple sagt das selber auf seiner Webseite, Unlocked Phones mit Prepaid-Vertrag und um den Preis habe ich jetzt nicht so ein bisschen weniger.
Muss man den Prepaid-Vertrag dann mitkaufen erstmal?
Klar, aber das ist doch nicht so viel.
Meine Eltern werden in die Schweiz fahren und ich glaube, da werde ich mir dann ein genetlocktes iPhone mitbringen lassen, was es aber auch mit Prepaid-Vertrag gibt, dann sogar relativ günstig. Ich glaube, so die große Version für 5 Euro.
Aber heißt das, man muss dann ein iPhone Plus nochmal wie Prepaid extra holen? Weil die brauch ich ja dann eigentlich nicht.
Du zahlst dann 0 Euro für den... Also du kaufst das Telefon mit Prepaid-Vertrag zu einem Preis und dann schmeißt du den Prepaid-Vertrag weg.
Das ist auch nicht so viel.
Könnte sein. Hast du ja im Gleichen eine Karte für 100 Dollar Gesprächs... oder Euro oder was auch immer Gesprächsgut haben, doch auf jeden Fall mit reindrücken.
Also Telefon, auf jeden Fall die italienischen...
Achso, aber bei der Schweizer Variante dazu?
von mindestens einer Person, die ein Italien Telefon gekauft hat, und ist erfolgreich. Nach der Aktivierung bei Telekom Italia im Store, mit dem Pre-Pad, genau, auf Twitter hat sie das berichtet und in Finnland lief es danach mit ihrem Provider ohne irgendwie Änderungen. Sim-Karte, Austausch und fertig. Und das ist eigentlich das, was man haben will.
Na eigentlich möchte man so im eigenen Land in Laden gehen, aber das ist die...
Podcast-Länge, bitte nicht länger als vier Stunden.
Okay, wir waren also noch unter. Noch?
Oh man.
Quartalsergebnisse, bla bla bla. Wollen wir jetzt wirklich alle Kommentare durchgehen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Na ja, also so ein bisschen...
Wir haben jetzt die drei Stunden voll.
Na, sind ja nicht mehr viele. Also zu den Quartalsergebnissen hatten wir ja schon seine schlechten Nachrichten. Das ist ja, kann man wissen halt nicht, also kann sein, aber ist unklar. MTDAP hatten wir auch schon vorhin. Ja, was heißt ZDAP? Ich hab das halt so eingerichtet, wie die sagen, dass man es einrichtet. Man kann da halt nichts ändern, sondern man kann halt nur hören.
So, defamitieren... Wir sollen die positive Grundstimmung nicht verlieren.
Na, dazu kann ich noch mal sagen, weil manche beschweren sich ja, wenn wir sagen, Apple ist Evil und so, dass wir irgendwie keine Fans werden. Aber das Gegenteil von Liebe ist ja Hass und... Nee, ist ja nicht Hass, sondern Gleichgültigkeit. So war's. Genau.
Nach Stunde 3 entwickelt der Mobile-Max-Podcast völlig neue Qualitäten. Weil wir schon so verspult sind mit den ganzen Themen, dass wir jetzt auf so eine Blümchenwiese Metaebene kommen und sitzen hier irgendwie mit verschränkten Beinen. Das liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass... Trinken noch keine Club-Marte mehr, sondern das Tee ausreichend... Okay, also wir haben die positive Grundstimmung nicht verloren und das wird auch so schnell nicht passieren. Services sind Evil, hatte ich berichtet. Die Service-Grabba haben wir auch glaube ich drüber berichtet. iPhone-Erwerb Italien haben wir gerade gehabt.
Auto würde ich dringend von abraten, weil Auto fahren und Fernsehen ist doof.
Ja, dann brennt das Auto. Blablabla, 10.5, Apfel-I, Schnickschnack. Was haben wir hier noch?
Was war denn das Apfel-I-Schnickschnack?
Na, das geht um diese Lokalisierung. Da hat jemand gefragt, das wurde hier ausreichend beantwortet. Ich weiß nicht, kennst du dieses Feature? Also mir war das neu, dass man Apfel-I auf eine Applikation machen kann und dann gibt's da so einen Tab, wo man die Sprachen ausklicken kann.
Und was soll das? Developers ist gut zum Sprachentest. Zum Beispiel brauche ich meine Sprache nicht umstellen, weil ich hab halt Englisch. Und wenn ich aber ein Programm entwickle, was irgendwie deutsch, italienisch, französisch ist und so weiter, dann kann ich da mal einzeln durchklicken und das dann so probieren.
Und ich hab gestern ein Programm ausprobiert, Rulers heißt das, was eigentlich ein sehr schönes Programm ist, aber wirklich, ich würde sagen, von Google Translate übersetzt worden ist. Da lohnt es sich dann auch, die deutsche Sprachversion abzuschalten bzw. zu löschen.
Ich benutze meinen Mac sowieso nur auf Englisch, von daher...
Und es gibt manchmal Bugs in deutschen Versionen, die dann in englischen Versionen nicht vorhanden sind. Also es gibt Fälle, da lohnt es sich dann, falls man Fehler entdeckt hat, auf die englische Version umzuschalten.
Ja, dann gibt es hier noch irgendwie den Hinweis, dass diese Multisim-Karten, die Datenflatrate fürs iPhone bei Telekom, auch in anderen Anwendungen anwendbar ist. Das heißt, ich kann eine Multisim-Karte auch in mein Nokia stecken und dann auf meinem selben Complete-Strafe umzusaufen.
Das geht ja auch nicht anders, weil du hast zwei iPhones.
Aber da fehlt ja noch der zweite Satz. Alle hier genannten Preise und Konditionen gelten nur bei Verwendung der von T-Mobile überlassenen SIM-Karte in einem von T-Mobile Deutschland GmbH im folgenden T-Mobile erworbenen iPhone.
Ja, ich glaube, da haben sie einfach nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Ja, haben sie offensichtlich nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das separat abrechnen. Aber man weiß es nicht.
AGB steht im Zweifelsfall über Presser-Erklärungen, nehme ich mal an, oder?
Ist noch jemand, der viele Probleme mit dem App Store hat? Hatten wir auch schon berichtet.
Genau. Wissen wir nicht. Ja, Exchange geht nicht.
Hatten wir alles schon, ist ja auch keine Frage.
Aber eine schöne Push-Lösung für März. Ich hab auch schon mal ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Ich hab gestern mal was ausprobiert. Wir sollen weniger über das iPhone reden, heißt es hier noch.
Das ist mehr so PHP. Genau.
Letzte Sache, das ist das letzte hier. Gibt es erste Erfahrungen mit Xcode 3.1? Ich hab Developer-Fluchen hören.
Also das SDK fürs iPhone ist ja schon die ganze Zeit 3.1 gewesen, also Beta und seit letzter Woche gibt es das dann auch Final. Funktioniert alles super voll toll. LLVM kann man als Compiler einfach, also den LLVM GCC, man muss ja jetzt unterscheiden, gibt es auch so einen Artikel von einem Chris Hansen, oder wie heißt er?
Haben wir ja auch schon ausführlich drüber geredet letztes Mal.
Genau, kann man einfach einschalten, geht GCC 4.2 genauso und OpenMP habe ich noch nicht probiert und diesen C-Lang Analyzer habe ich... OpenMP ist so eine Erweiterung vom GCC, das OpenMP steht glaube ich auch für...
Maschinenpistole.
ja, weiß ich nicht. Processing, parallel, tralala. Du kannst in deinem Code irgendwie eine Schleife angeben, dann kannst du sagen, hier der Schleifenzähler ist irgendwie, das könnte er parallel machen, die Ergebnisse sind aber nicht. Also kannst du sagen, welche Variablen irgendwie beachtet werden sollen und welche nicht für die parallele Ausführung und dann teilt er das automatisch in Threads auf.
Verstehe.
Also wenn du einen riesengroßen Job hast, dann kannst du dem schon im Code sagen, hier, teilt es mal so auf, wie du gerade da CPUs am Start hast.
Ich wusste, dass Apple das in ihre eigenen Frameworks sowas mit eingebaut hat, aber ich wusste nicht, dass es auch OpenMP gibt und sie das auch unterstützen. Na gut, umso besser.
Ist eigentlich nicht so schlecht, hab's halt noch nicht benutzt.
Na gut.
Du wolltest jetzt noch eine Sache?
Ich wollte noch eine Sache, wir müssten mal kurz hochspülen, weil... Hoch?
Jetzt waren wir so schön am Ende?
Ja, ja, aber ich hatte...
Du hast auch schon eine E-Mail gepusht, meintest du?
Ich wollte eine E-Mail pushen, genau. Ich hab noch keine schöne Lösung gefunden, falls irgendjemand was hat.
Push it.
Salt and Pepper?
Ja. Ich find's eher gut, dass du das nicht auswendig singst.
Jetzt sag schon, du hast also E-Mails gepusht.
Ich wollte, ich hab's nicht geschlappt. Ich suche noch eine nicht-Exchange-Open-Source, einfach zu implementieren.
Gab's auch letztens so eine Seite, wo zwei, drei Tools beworben wurden, die das können?
Ich hab eins davon ausprobiert, das hieß, glaube ich, T-Push. Das hat aber nicht so richtig funktioniert. Also ich kann zwar über diesen T-Push-Account...
Da muss man wahrscheinlich einfach bei Google nach Exchange-Ersatz suchen, oder?
Na so schlau war ich auch schon.
Es gibt Open-Source-Projekte, die halt auch Exchange nachprogrammieren.
Aber die diese Push-Mail-Unterstützung haben, bin ich immer noch auf der Suche nach irgendwas. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich wirklich den ganzen Spam überhaupt auf dem Handy haben will, wahrscheinlich wäre es dann eh nach drei Minuten wieder abschalten. Aber man will es ja mal gesehen haben.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall was.
Das ist eine tolle Antwort.
Ja, sorry, aber...
So, jetzt ist auf jeden Fall keine Zeit mehr, irgendwas zu erklären. Eigentlich hatte ich mir mal vorgenommen, dass wir mal wieder ein bisschen was erklären.
Das Leben des Universums.
Wir haben heute noch ein bisschen was über unsere Formate erklärt. Was ich mal ganz gerne erklären würde, ein bisschen ausführlicher ist, wie das eigentlich ist mit dem Mobiltelefon und dem Mac und wie das alles so zusammengeht. Du weißt schon, die Modemskripte und das PPP. Das ist alles so prä-iPhone.
Was ich euch beiden gerne erklären möchte, wie ganz dringend man pullern muss, wenn man zwei Flaschen getrunken hat. Also lasst uns doch einfach heute mal.
Nächstes Mal gibt es nur noch Tee, und dann machen wir hier so hippie Session. Und Windel. Wenn du möchtest auch. Das wär natürlich was. Und wie nennen wir die Sendung jetzt?
Du hattest am Anfang mal irgendwas.
Wie wär's mit Reboot tut gut?
Reboot tut gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Sagen wir Tschüss. Wir haben es ja noch nicht mal vorgestellt. Diesmal.
Ich war Dennis.
Ich war Tim.
Und ich bin immer noch Max.
Und du bist immer noch Max. Und das war's. MobileMax 009. In zwei Wochen geht's weiter. Und wir haben uns gefreut, dass ihr uns zugehört habt.
So lange.
Danke fürs Durchhalten.